spéciale de bonjour chez vous au
lendemain des sénatoriales vous saurez
toutes des résultats des sénateurs
viendront débattre en plateau l'analyse
de nos experts nos envies spéciaux dans
les départements et bien sûr la presque
quotidienne régionale bonjour chez vous
spécial sénatoriales 2023 demain à 7h30
sur Public Sénat
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bonsoir Tam bonsoir Thomas bonsoir à
tous on vous souhaite la bienvenue en
direct sur Public Sénat journée
événement journée exceptionnelle
évidemment pour nous à l'occasion de ces
élections sénatoriales on est ensemble
jusqu'à
22h30 beaucoup de questions politiques
beaucoup danger à décortiquer notamment
la droite et le centre vont-ils
renforcer leur majorité dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat est-ce que le groupe
Renaissance les macronistes sont en
danger aujourd'hui et le rassemblement
national peut-il va-t-il faire son
retour à la Haute Assemblée quelle
personnalité ont déjà perdu leur siège
ou pourraient le perdre et puis à
l'inverse qu'elle sénatrice qu'elle
sénateur vont faire leur entrée dans la
Haute Assemblée nos équipes se
mobilisent depuis ce matin et jusqu'à ce
soir pour vous faire vivre ce temps fort
de la vie politique alors si vous êtes
avec nous vous êtes certainement fan de
soirée électorale vous avez vu cette
mosaïque ça fait partie des grands
classiques on est présent dans 4
départements quatre points chauds de aux
élections avec nos envoyés spéciaux on
va les revoir nous serons dans le Nord à
Lille avec Samia dechir Mathias se
trouve lui dans la Moselle à Metz on
sera dans les Hauts-de-Seine à Nanterre
avec Audrey buttaz et enfin Steve
Jourdain est à Paris pour nous faire
vivre le scrutin de la capitale de
l'Hôtel de Ville Alexandre Poussard lui
il est en ce moment dans l'escalier
d'honneur à quelques pas de l'endroit où
le roi Charles était cette semaine pour
ceux qui sont férus de ressemblance
c'est un peu notre Prince William à nous
alexandre Poussin Alexandre qui nous
rejoindra dans cette magnifique salle
des conférences du Sénat pour accueillir
de nombreuses réactions politiques à son
micro et les résultats ça sera avec
Quentin avec Quentin Calmet que nous
retrouverons très régulièrement pour des
points complets départements par
département et Quentin il y a déjà 16
sénateurs qui ont été élus on l'a appris
ce midi au scrutin un majoritaire alors
un mot sur eh bien les princip
personnalité dont on sait qu'elles vont
déjà rentrer au palais de Luxembourg
bonjour à vous bonjour à vous Thomas
également depuis ce midi on a vu
effectivement l'élection de 16 premiers
sénateurs et on voit une prime au
sortant car sur ces 16 élus il y en a 12
qui sont des sénateurs sortants comment
ça avec la Mayenne il y a deux sièges
pour voir et bien la centriste Elizabeth
Doisneau qui est rapporté un général du
budget de la Sécurité sociale elle est
réélu elle va donc occuper un de ses
deux sièges le second est en bas à
l'otage on verra donc le résultat une
fois le scrutin dépouillé puisque depuis
17h30 on a commencé le dépouillement
dans ces départements dans tous les
départements dans l'Orne la sénatrice
sortante Nathalie Goulet et réélu pour
la troisième fois dans ce département
normand dans les Landes là aussi primo
sortant avec les socialistes Éric
kerouche et également Monique Lubin tous
les deux réelus dès le premier tour
deuxélus socialiste en Haute-Loire c'est
la majorité sénatoriale de la droite et
du centre qui engrange des sièges le
centr Olivier sigolotti et réélu dès le
premier tour tout comme le LR Laurent
duplombte on continue cette fois-ci avec
des nouveaux entrants dans le lot on va
avoir un rivet le meilleur PS de Cahors
à la chambre haute du parlement
Jean-Marc vaissouze était du dès le
premier tour interrogation sur le second
siège avec et bien un second tour qui va
départager la candidate sortante c'est
notre histoire tante socialiste en gel
Preville du candidat en ballotage
favorable il est radical de gauche qui
s'appelle Raphaël dobay il a encore en
liste pour le second tour on continue
avec les personnalités qui vont entrer
au Sénat on a vu à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon une
personnalité être élu dès le premier
tour il s'agit de l'ancienne ministre
Annick Girardin ministre souffrances
Hollande et sous Emmanuel Macron elle va
rejoindre la chambre haute du parlement
et bien contre-performance en revanche
pour l'actuellement du gouvernement
Sonia bakez qui est secrétaire d'État à
la citoyenneté elle est battue en
Nouvelle-Calédonie on va voir les noms
des deux sénateurs qui sont élus dans
cette collectivité d'outre-mer il s'agit
de George naturel qui a été élu dès le
premier tour il émet un divers droites
loyalistes et autres faits marquants
c'est l'arrivée au Sénat de Robert zohuy
qui est le second élu dans ses
sénatoriales en Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est
une première un élu indépendantiste va
faire son entrée au Sénat c'est donc
l'une des informations marquantes de
cette journée Thomas on va régulièrement
faire de la pédagogie également dans
cette soirée électorale on va rappeler
que dans ce scrutin il y a des
départements scrutin majoritaires et
d'autres à la proportionnelle exactement
au total il y a 170 sièges qui sont
remis en jeu c'est à peu près la moitié
des 348 sièges de sénateurs et regardez
effectivement il y a des départements
qui sont concernés en France
métropolitaine on parle de 38
départements et on y ajoute 6
collectivités d'outre-mer avec vous le
disiez Thomas de type de scrutin les
départements les moins peuplées les plus
ruraux que vous voyez ici en bleu clair
et bien il y a deux tours d'élection
avec un scrutin majoritaire et dans les
départements qui sont en bleu foncé on
élit les sénateurs au scrutins
proportionnel avec un scrutin de lys
avec un scrutin qui est organisé toute
la journée de 8h30 jusqu'à 17h30 et ce
sont ces départements en bleu foncé que
l'on va particulièrement surveiller
pourquoi parce que ce sont eux qui
lisent le plus de sénateurs regardez par
exemple Paris qui est concerné il y a 12
sièges à pourvoir même chose dans les
Hauts-de-France avec le nord et le
Pas-de-Calais avec respectivement 11 et
7 sièges à pourvoir et on va surveiller
trois autres départements Thomas Etam on
va surveiller la Loire-Atlantique 5
sièges la Moselle dans le Grand Est cinq
sièges également l'Isère 5 sièges voilà
pour les chiffres clés et un petit peu
aussi les premiers résultats que je
pouvais vous donner ce soir merci
beaucoup Quentin vous retrouvera donc
très très régulièrement dans cette
soirée électorale n'hésitez pas à nous
faire signe quand vous avez des des
résultats marquants vous pouvez vous
aussi suivre en temps réel ces résultats
sur notre site sur notre plateforme
Public Sénat point fr ils sont
actualisés
minute par minute vous y trouverez
également les articles de décryptage de
notre rédaction web qui dit soirée
électorale dit bien sûr invité politique
ils seront
nombreux CD sur ce plateau
20h et notamment des présidents de
groupe parmi lesquels Bruno Retailleau
et Liana Sassi Claude malurey François
Patriat ou encore Hervé Marseille mais
aussi les nouvelles personnalités qui
vont faire leur entrée au Sénat et puis
autour de cette table on recevra
également et ils sont déjà des experts
pour nous aider à analyser les résultats
les enjeux de cette élection on vous
présente nos premiers invités Anne levad
bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
professeur de droit président de
l'Association française de droits
constitutionnel je ne le supplie depuis
quelques mois mais ça n'est pas grave
vous vous êtes dans nos cœurs encore
présidents pardon Bruno cotreesse
politologue bonsoir Bruno bonsoir au
CNRS et aussi pof également avec nos
Vincent barthini bonsoir vous êtes
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'Université de Nice et à l'École
polytechnique et chercheurs associés au
CEVIPOF et enfin l'incontournable
Mathieu croissanto notre éditorialiste
politique et sur ce plateau bonsoir
Mathieu bienvenue à vous je commence
avec vous pour nos cotresses peut-être
sur la première le premier résultat un
peu un peu marquant qui est d'ailleurs
tombé en début fin de matinée début
d'après-midi Sonia bakez qui perd en
Nouvelle-Calédonie faut-il en tirer une
leçon générale ou annonciatrice d'une
soirée difficile pour on va dire le
parti majoritaire le parti de la
majorité payantiel c'est clair que c'est
comme une mauvaise annonce un très
mauvaise annonce on pourrait dire même
pour la majorité on sait que ça va être
compliqué pour le parti présidentiel qui
dispose de 24 sénateurs aujourd'hui sans
doute de retrouver ces 24 sièges
expliqués dans la vie politique de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie elle a été membre de
gouvernement elle est président de la
Province Sud de nouvelle exécutif au
gouvernement donc c'était briller un
premièrement premier mandat ça n'a pas
marché donc forcément c'est pas une très
très bonne nouvelle bien évidemment ça
va poser la question peut-elle rester ou
pas au gouvernement parce qu'on sait
qu'une seule question qu'on allait poser
à nevad peut-être il y a pas il y a pas
forcément d'automaticité mais ça ça
fragilise un ministre juridiquement
aucune automaticité puisque même bien
évidemment et c'est l'originalité de la
cinquième on ne peut pas être
parlementaire et membre du gouvernement
en même temps d'ailleurs il était dit
que ce ne serait pas elle qui siégerait
mais sont suppléant le fait que
maintenant depuis
une quinzaine d'années une pratique
s'est développée qui est en général
quand un membre du gouvernement mais ça
n'est qu'une pratique quand un membre du
gouvernement se présente soit au
sénatorial soit au législatives et
battus effectivement il est fortement
incité à démissionner Mathieu croissanto
le problème il est politique il n'est
pas forcément juridique c'est difficile
de rester au gouvernement quand on a
perdu une élection c'est le cas
généralement au législatives oui c'est
c'est difficile et d'ailleurs aucun
battu au législatives on est resté au
gouvernement sous Emmanuel Macron donc
ça serait une forme de jurisprudence si
on laissait Sonia Bacquet à son poste
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour le
gouvernement parce que c'était la seule
ministre à se présenter donc se perdre
le ministre qu'ils avaient c'est pas
bien c'est une mauvaise nouvelle parce
que c'est pas un petit dossier dont elle
a la charge en ce moment la citoyenneté
c'est quand même un sujet dont on entend
beaucoup parler après ça montre une
chose c'est que les élections
sénatoriales ne sont pas automatiques
qu'il y a beaucoup plus de suspense
beaucoup plus de rapports de force
politique qui s'exprime que ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer certes ce sont des
grands électeurs et on pourrait dans
certaines circonscriptions se dire bon
ben voilà ça va voter comme ci comme ça
mais il y a des surprises possibles et
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé on
voyait d'ailleurs pendant que vous vous
parliez les les uns les autres quelques
images de vote de grands électeurs il y
en a 79000 qui sont appelés aux urnes
obligés de voter c'est une des
spécificités de ce scrutin on a vu
Marine Le Pen Patrick canner qui est à
la fois grand électeur et candidat
évidemment on a vu Gabriel Attal et
quelques autres Yannick Jadot aussi oui
on a aussi vu Anne Hidalgo
d'autres résultats marquants sur cette
première salle c'est qu'il y a peut-être
une prime au sortant aussi Vincent
Martini c'est ce que nous disait Quentin
à l'instant on en a vu beaucoup qui ont
été réélus dès le premier tour
intéressant si on compare l'espèce de
valse au mandat en général qui prévaut y
compris à l'Assemblée nationale il
semblerait que le Sénat c'est un peu un
monde un peu parallèle c'est-à-dire
c'est un monde de stabilité politique on
en reparlera peut-être tout à l'heure
lorsqu'on parlera de la différence entre
l'Assemblée de Sénat mais aussi on a le
sentiment que c'est une chambre dans
lequel les parties traditionnelles
résistent contrairement à l'Assemblée
nationale où ils sont en général laminés
ils représentent pas par 20% des députés
alors que chez les Sénateurs ça
représente une immense majorité et à ce
titre là en effet ces reconductions elle
montre aussi une stabilité qui est celle
des territoires d'une certaine mesure
puisque vous êtes élu par les grands
électeurs qui sont majorité des conseils
municipaux dans des exécutifs locaux qui
sont beaucoup plus stables et beaucoup
moins volatiles donc c'est un temps plus
long donc ça explique en partie cette
stabilité on pourrait trouver que le
décalage par rapport à
la société qui votent en France et est
un peu trop importante si on compare
effectivement aux élections
présidentielles ou aux élections
législatives mais c'est aussi un point
d'ancrage qui dans l'équilibre
démocratique est important alors oui
c'est un point d'ancrage je pense que
les institutions en France elles se
mélangent justement des institutions
dans la vocation a changé est importante
et d'autres qui au contraire doivent
demeurer des pôles de stabilité parce
que la politique elle a besoin de ton
cours mais aussi de temps beaucoup plus
long et on peut se réjouir pour ceux qui
défendent le bicaméralisme en France
c'est à dire qu'il y a une chambre qui
soit celle de l'actualité la plus
brûlante celle aussi des peut-être d'un
ton plus vif aussi et puis celle d'une
structure plus lente un temps plus lent
d'une stabilité plus importante en tout
cas ceux qui défendent le Seigneur pense
que c'est une de ses forces et puis on a
eu un roi qui a défendu le bicaméralisme
ici même c'était à quelques mètres d'ici
dans la semaine allez on va commencer à
aller régulièrement on vous l'a promis
dans nos départements témoins en quelque
sorte on pourrait les appeler comme ça
des points chauds de cette soirée
sénatoriale on va rejoindre tout de
suite Samia dechir qui est avec Olivier
Mo Linari dans le Nord donc depuis Lille
ou le président du groupe socialiste
Patrick Canet veut repartir pour un
nouveau mandat tout comme l'ancien
ministre elle est en Martinique de Brest
comment ça se présente Samya bonsoir
et bien ça s'annonce serrer très serré
un Thomas ici dans le Nord toutes les
têtes de lys qu'on a pu croiser ce matin
dans les bureaux de vote nous l'ont dit
sur les 11 sièges de sénateur à pourvoir
il y en a plusieurs qui vont se jouer
dans un mouchoir de poche pourquoi parce
qu'il y a énormément de listes ici dans
le Nord il y en a 16 listes pour 11
siège de sénateurs à pourvoir et ses
divisions ça n'arrange évidemment
personne a commencé par Patrick canard
vous l'avez dit le président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat il est tête de liste
ici dans le Nord aujourd'hui les
socialistes ils ont deux sièges de
sénateurs dans le Nord Patrick canard
voudrait bien en gagner un troisième
mais ça pourrait être difficile pour lui
parce que face à lui il a cinq autres
cinq autres listes de gauche qui se
présente donc ça pourrait bien
l'empêcher de gagner ce troisième siècle
vous avez aussi cité tout à l'heure Marc
Philippe de Bresse le sortant les
républicains qui est tête de liste de la
droite ici dans le Nord c'est un ancien
ministre lui clairement son objectif
c'est le maintien c'est que la droite
puisse garder les deux sièges de
sénateurs dans le Nord a priori c'est
faisable sur le papier mais la présence
de candidats indépendants pourrait
peut-être risquer à la droite de perdre
l'un de ces deux sièges on se bouscule
aussi au centre droit ou on compte pas
moins de 3 listes donc il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de monde et tout ça ça pourrait
ça pourrait faire les affaires du
rassemblement national l'un des
meilleurs espoirs du parti c'est Joshua
Hochard le candidat dans le Nord qui
pourrait être élu même si encore une
fois rien n'est gagné pour lui non plus
on le saura maintenant dans quelques
heures puisque les bureaux de vote
viennent juste de fermer ici dans le
Nord et on va commencer le dépouillement
merci merci beaucoup Samia pour toutes
ces explications et on vous retrouve
bien sûr tout au long de cette soirée
Bruno cotress Samia l'a dit il y a des
divisions importantes à gauche notamment
bien le président du groupe socialiste
Patrick Kanner et qui fait face à la
dissidence de Martine filleul qui est à
la sénatrice sortante et qui était
longtemps première de la fédération du
Nord ça peut jouer des tours à la gauche
pour vous
ça joue des tours le micro le micro le
détour en général quand vous avez bien
évidemment des candidatures dissidentes
dans des scrutins où il y a pas beaucoup
d'électeurs quand il y a des candidats
dissidents avec des centaines de
milliers d'électeurs c'est assez
marginal par contre quand on a pas
beaucoup d'électeurs avec des électeurs
qui notamment se connaissent sont des
stratégies les invisibles des autres
alors là effectivement ça peut réserver
des ça peut réserver des surprises et il
y en aura sans doute quelques-unes ce
soir alors il y a des divisions pas que
chez les socialistes il y a aussi des
divisions à droite à on le verra tout à
l'heure
notamment à Paris mais c'est vrai que ce
type de ce type de scrutin tu as un
petit peu mécaniquement parce qu'une
certaine forme d'inertie on le disait
tout à l'heure du du Sénat donc tout
assemblé qui génère une forme d'inertie
dans les dans les on va dire dans les le
jour des élections où on retrouve des
sièges tenus par des sénateurs depuis un
certain nombre de mandats forcément ça
aiguise les appétits dans la même
famille politique ANOVA pour vous c'est
quoi l'enjeu principal d'une soirée
comme celle-là une soirée sénatoriale
alors il y a deux niveaux aussi j'ose
dire il y a évidemment l'enjeu politique
qui est de l'issue puisqu'on sait que
l'élection sénatoriale et aussi le
moment où on peut
apprécier l'ancrage local d'un certain
nombre de formations politiques c'est
d'ailleurs je pense évidemment le défi
pour le parti qui soutient le président
de la République sans doute aussi pour
le rassemblement national afin de voir
si les victoires qu'ils ont pu avoir
notamment aux municipales sont
susceptibles de changer la donne la
deuxième chose c'est que la
configuration du Sénat même si ça n'est
que la moitié des sénateurs qui ont
vocation à être renouvelées évidemment
aussi avoir une incidence sur le rôle
qui sera le sien dans les institutions
le fait que dans la mesure où 170
seulement sur 348 sont changés il n'y
aura vraisemblablement pas de
bouleversement intégral mais on voit
bien que si on regarde dans la dans la
majorité lr100 triste il y a une gamme
de bleu vous pourrez dire ça comme ça et
voilà certains centrices qui soutiennent
le gouvernement d'autres LR qui sont au
contraire dans une opposition marquée ça
va être très intéressant de voir comment
les nouveaux élus vont se positionner
oui et puis on sait en plus que le Sénat
a toujours une attention particulière à
l'équilibre politique d'ailleurs la
preuve en est que bien qu'il y ait moins
de sénateurs que de députés par exemple
le bureau a davantage de vice-président
pour assurer la représentation du
pluralisme et bien sûr sur des textes un
peu compliqués comme ceux qu'on nous
annonce pour les discussions de
l'automne l'immigration par exemple
évidemment amener à ce que des groupes
de petites tailles puis jouent un rôle
déterminant alors vous en avez parlé un
tout à l'heure l'un des enjeux de ce
scrutin et bien c'est l'arrivée ou non
du rassemblement national au Sénat et
nous sommes en direct de Metz en Moselle
avec Mathias Arès et Julien s'engèle la
Moselle justement Mathias c'est l'un des
départements où il pourrait y avoir
l'élection d'un sénateur RN
oui un département dans lequel le
rassemblement national place énormément
d'espoir ici l'extrême droite a des mers
à des conseillers départementaux
régionaux des députés également
l'extrême droite qui compte également
sur le fait que les idées de Marine Le
Pen un fusil si peut-être plus
qu'ailleurs pour glaner des votes de
grands électeurs autre motifs d'espoir
ici pour le rassemblement national et
bien c'est que Jean-Louis Masson
sénateur sortant ayant rallié Marine Le
Pen en 2021 ne remplit pas cette année
il pourrait donc laisser sa place à un
sénateur du rassemblement national le
rassemblement national qui a donc décidé
d'investir un maire rural Michel
Rambourg maire de vancourt une petite
commune il se veut le candidat des
campagnes face au métropole et il va
donc avoir ici je peux vous l'assurer
des nouveaux visages ce soir à l'issue
de ces sénatoriales puisqu'il y a deux
sortants qui ne se représentent pas
Jean-Louis Masson comme je vous le
disais mais également Jean-Marc
todaychini ancien sénateur socialiste
ancien ministre socialiste de la place
qui crée forcément des ambitions très
listes ce soir sur la ligne de départ
pour 5 sièges il faut le rappeler en
Moselle des cartes qui vont donc être
rebattues parmi les listes que l'on peut
citer qui peuvent nourrir des espoirs
forcément il y a cette liste estampillée
majorité sanatones qui est mené par
Jean-Marie maison à parenté Union
centriste qui a donc décidé cette année
de s'unir avec Catherine belrichi
également sénatrice sortante les
républicains il y a une autre sorte à
droite Christian erzogh et
l'ancienne-colistière de Jean-Louis
Masson cette fois elle a fait campagne
sur son nom et sur ses différences avec
son ancien allié en politique à gauche
cette fois c'est le premier fédéral
socialiste Michael Weber qui espère
faire un siège il a été adoubé par
Jean-Marc todéchini lui-même il a sur sa
liste certains communistes du
département mais pas tous une union qui
n'a pas pu se faire avec les verres ou
encore avec la France insoumise des
listes qui seront donc également sur la
ligne de départ à gauche et qui devrait
priver Michael Weber d'un deuxième siège
parmi les outsiders qu'on peut également
citer il Anne boucher c'est une
candidate malheureuse aux dernières
législatives et leur représentait alors
les LR cette fois elle est sous la
bannière horizon et d'ailleurs elle a
reçu jeudi le soutien d'Édouard Philippe
c'était à Sarreguemines en somme
inscritin ouverte qui pourrait créer des
surprises ici et qui donc avec la
multiplication des listes comme je vous
le disais pourrait créer un risque de
dispersion des voix merci beaucoup
Mathias Mathias avec Julien Sengel donc
en Moselle à Metz Mathieu croissanto on
va on va se concentrer un peu sur la
question du rassemblement national si
vous voulez bien il y a la tentation
pour l'ORL dans jamber ce ces élections
ça va dépendre quoi du d'un petit nombre
de sénateurs s'il y en a deux trois cinq
je ne sais pas si c'est possible
peut-être voilà en tout cas il y a une
volonté de ne pas engendrer il y a une
volonté d'avoir le plus possible de
sénateurs pour le rassemblement national
le problème c'est qu'on l'a dit ce sont
des grands électeurs qui votent et que
les grands électeurs mais le feront le
rassemblement national n'en a pas
beaucoup parce que le dernier cru des
municipales en 2020 n'a pas été bon pour
le national il n'a pas été bon pour le
parti de Marine Le Pen ils ont perdu des
villes ils en ont gagné certes on a tous
en mémoire évidemment à Perpignan par
exemple mais ils en ont perdu et surtout
ils ont moins de conseillers municipaux
qu'ils n'en ont eu par le passé donc ça
fait moins de moins de grands électeurs
possibles c'est le reflet de
l'implantation locale de ces parties
c'est le même problème pour Renaissance
et encore le problème est encore plus
flagrant pour pour les insoumis tous ces
partis qui considèrent qu'ils peuvent
enjamber les scrutins intermédiaires Ben
se font régulièrement taper au Sénat
parce que ils n'ont pas assez de gens
pour pour les élire après ça serait une
victoire symbolique pour le
rassemblement national d'avoir c'est
plus facile quand on parle de véritable
de la dernière fois
Stéphane Ravier qui les a quittés depuis
pour rejoindre au contexte et reconquête
pardon et puis David Racheline qui les a
quittés en tout cas plutôt choisi lui de
conserver sa mairie de Fréjus plutôt que
son mandat de sénateur mais en avoir
plusieurs 4 5 peut-être 6 oui ça serait
une mini victoire on se souvient en tout
cas que l'entrée en force en juin 2022
du rassemblement national à l'Assemblée
nationale 89 députés a été une vraie
surprise en fait cela montre aussi que
les du matériel qui sont la traduction
des élections municipales ça montre que
ces municipales on avait beau s'être
intéressé à cet un nombre de mairies
très médiatiques Hénin-Beaumont aillant
Beaucaire etc qui avait été gagné par le
rassemblement national finalement leur
implantation locale n'était pas si forte
on voit qu'il y a deux vies politiques
dans ce pays la vie politique entre
guillemets j'allais dire d'en haut
c'est-à-dire celle des élections
nationales qui ne sont pas celles du
Sénat mais en tout cas qui reflètent la
représentation nationale à travers les
députés ou là vous avez des
implantations
relatives qui existent des groupes
parlementaires du RN de renaissance la
France insoumise mais qui ne reflète pas
du tout une autre vie politique par le
bas qui est qui est celle qui se traduit
beaucoup dans les élections municipales
des conseils généraux et régionaux mais
aussi évidemment par ricochet du Sénat
là vous voyez bien cette dichotomie
cette manière et qui fait Marine Le Pen
elle parle d'une incongruité politique
quand elle quand elle dit qu'elle a pas
de sénateur est-ce que ça l'arrange pas
même si on peut l'entendre tout dépend
qui doit donner le lin en fait de la
représentation nationale on peut tout à
fait défendre l'idée au contraire que le
ces groupes gazeux disaient hier
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui concerne aussi un
peu l'organisation du RN à sa manière et
bien ils ont un effort qu'ils n'ont pas
fait en fait de son racine localement et
qui montre quand même qu'ils ont un
problème dans le rapport à la démocratie
c'est vrai pour le RN c'est aussi vrai
pour le groupe Renaissance évidemment un
problème l'implantation c'est le cœur de
la vie politique et d'une certaine
manière beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs
disent qu'il faudrait revenir sur la
reloi 2014 qui interdisait au sénateur
et au parlementaire d'avoir un
enracinement local pour empêcher cette
mandats
y compris maintenant dans la majorité
présidentielle qui a envie chez Horizon
par exemple un sujet qui sera j'imagine
sur la table lors de les prochains
mandat des sénateurs parce qu'on sait
qu'il y a un certain nombre de sénateurs
qui sont favorables à revenir en arrière
sur ces questions mais encore une fois
voilà je pense que cette faiblesse de
racinement peut le voir de deux côtés
soit on dit ils ont une faible
enracinement si on dit surtout les
parties traditionnelles ont une de
résistance supérieure à celle dont on
évoque en général dans les médias les
parties ne sont pas totalement mortes
puisqu'ils existent dans les territoires
alors je le rappelle 170 sièges sont en
jeu pratiquement la moitié du Sénat il y
a 1829 candidats et candidats 79000
grands électeurs je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure si vous voulez vous savoir dans
votre département si les résultats sont
déjà tombés je le rappelle vous pouvez
aller sur notre plateforme public
senna.fr et puis grâce à notre soirée
spéciale on va comme ça d'une ville à
l'autre on est tout de suite en
Île-de-France ou plus d'une cinquantaine
de sièges sont en jeu dans les
Hauts-de-Seine Nanterre en y est avec
Audrey buttaz et Marion goussi et ici
c'est le candidat Renaissance qui est en
mauvaise posture
oui Thomas on vient d'ailleurs de voir
Gabriel Attal le ministre de l'éducation
qui est venu voter puisqu'il est
toujours conseillé municipal de Vanves
et donc grand électeur il a ensuite
échangé longuement avec Xavier yakovelli
le candidat macroniste un soutien de
poids puisque Xavier yakovelli apathie
dans cette campagne des liens distendus
entre Emmanuel Macron et les élus autres
handicap ici dans le département le
MoDem a rejoint Hervé Marseille le
président du groupe Union centriste au
Sénat qui se voit bien remporter deux
sièges sur les 7 à pourvoir ici dans le
département pour le reste la liste LR
portée par Roger caoutchi voudrait faire
mieux qu'en 2017 où la droite était
partie divisée quatre sièges au lieu de
3 c'est l'objectif mais il y a un mais
Marie dos ashleiman la joint tonnerre
d'Asnières a décidé de porter une liste
dissidente elle pourrait donc empêcher
la liste de Roger carochi de faire ses
quatre sièges et puis du côté de la
gauche on a une union derrière le
sénateur communiste sortant Pierre
ouzulia qui a réussi à s'allier avec les
et le Parti socialiste mais pas la
France insoumise et lui il espère aussi
briguer deux sièges ça va être très
compliqué ça va être très serré mais on
dit qu'en coulisse les Hauts-de-Seine
font des surprises à chaque scrutin donc
réponse d'ici une grosse sert à peu près
Thomas merci merci beaucoup Audrey on
vous retrouve bien sûr pour avoir les
réponses à toutes c'est surprises à leur
Bruno cotress c'est un département où on
voit la majorité présidentielle qui est
donc présente sur différentes listes
vous avez la liste renaissance de Xavier
yaccovelli qui l'ont paraît plutôt mal
parti pour l'instant mais il y a aussi
celle du président de l'UDI qui est
aussi président du groupe Union
centriste ici Hervé Marseille il a
réussi à avoir le modem horizon sur sa
liste on se dit que rien ne va plus chez
les amis d'Emmanuel Macron en tout cas
c'est que c'est compliqué au centre et
on va le voir ça devait devenir de plus
en plus compliqué au centre et notamment
au centre droit dans notre vie politique
ce qui se passe ce Sénat représente
totalement majorité scénario et majorité
présidentielle ça match pas forcément au
Sénat il y a des modèles qui sont dans
la sénatoriale et qui sont en même temps
dans la majorité présidentielle donc
voilà c'est compliqué et on voit
effectivement très clairement très
clairement dans ces élections
sénatoriales la difficulté du parti
présidentiel avoir été implanté dans
toutes ces petites communes il faut
quand même rappeler en France il y a 72
% de nos communes qui ont moins de 1000
habitants il y a 78 % qui ont moins de
10000 habitants et le parti présentiel a
beaucoup investi dans les grandes
métropoles et donc du coup il a du mal
il lui manque des grands électeurs dans
cette France des petites voire très
petites communes on va le retrouver sans
doute dans les résultats ça prend du
temps un ancrage local pour un pour un
nouveau parti politique et Renaissance
est à nouveau parti politique
alors c'est un nouveau parti politique
et j'ajouterai qui a été conçu
initialement comme n'étant pas un parti
politique puisque il était même qualifié
de mouvement ce qui était quelque chose
de pas parfaitement clair et identifié
et qui reposait aussi beaucoup non pas
sur le l'adhésion j'allais dire comme
traditionnellement on peut le voir dans
les partis politiques mais davantage sur
l'idée qu'il y avait une forme de
volontariat mais que tout ça a été
extrêmement flexible et souple donc en
réalité je crois que il y a pas eu de
travail traditionnel de construction
d'un parti avec notamment dès le départ
des l'élection pour son premier mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron la mise en place de
structures partisanes locales et c'est
évidemment ces structures partisanes
locales qui ensuite sont déterminantes
pour faire des campagnes locales Mathieu
croissanto en revanche le groupe
centriste paraît lui très bien implanté
ça peut être l'un des gagnants peut-être
de cette élection c'est un groupe qui
peut faire défaire les majorités ici il
a une place très importante oui parce
que c'est un groupe qui fait entendre sa
petite musique personne ne vote j'allais
dire droit dans les bottes de du patron
du groupe au Sénat on sait que les
sénateurs ont chacun une sensibilité
dans chacun une autonomie de pensée ils
ont chacun une autonomie politique même
s'ils sont cohérents et globalement
quand on est à droite on vote avec la
droite et quand on est au centre mais là
ça devient plus compliqué parce qu'on
peut voter parfois avec la droite assez
souvent et puis sur certains textes on
peut voter aussi avec la gauche
en plus on sait que les centrices voilà
sont parfois des carpes et des lapins et
que c'est pas forcément
il faut le dire mais comme dans d'autres
parties on peut dire les choses il y a
évidemment des sensibilités qui sont
différentes qui sont liées à l'histoire
politique française
on a suffisamment critiqué les députés
godillots les députés Playmobil pour euh
et et là renaissance pour le coup et la
majorité c'est vrai pastille
complètement de son absence d'ancrage
local alors est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas
voulu ou est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas su la
question se pose au bout de 6 ans c'est
pas seulement qu'ils n'ont pas voulu
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas su ils n'ont pas
pu et aujourd'hui on le voit bien
Emmanuel Macron a réussi son opération
de sulfater l'échiquier politique à
l'échelle nationale en le PS et LR sont
quand même très grande difficulté chacun
est obligé de se réinventer ça va
prendre du temps en revanche ils n'ont
pas su prendre la place et créer une
alternative cohérente avec une partie un
parti c'est un leader c'est un programme
c'est des intellectuels qui travaillent
voilà aujourd'hui le programme le leader
tout ça est à l'Élysée et il y a pas ça
pas réussi à infuser dans la société il
y a pas de courant il y a pas de gens
qui portent la voix qui réfléchissent à
haute voix sur ce que peut être le
macronisme et donc ça ça pose un vrai
problème pour le futur et là qui se lit
ce soir dans évidemment les résultats
des sénatoriales Vincent Martin ça veut
dire que on prépare ici et et à
l'Assemblée ou dans tous les états
majeurs politiques on prépare déjà
l'après Emmanuel Macron c'est ça la
caractéristique de ce second mandat on
parle souvent du canard boiteux aux
États-Unis c'est bon ben voilà on sait
qu'il ne se représentera pas la
caractéristique c'est tout le monde est
déjà dans la course de de l'après
Emmanuel Macron oui alors une course qui
va être un peu longue bien je pense
qu'on l'a prépa activement mais ce que
vous dites est particulièrement juste
pour la droite française le Sénat est
appelé potentiellement à devenir une
prise de guerre pour le futur candidat
de la droite française qui souhaiterait
et qui verrait ici une des chambres
importantes du pays pouvoir
éventuellement le soutenir je vois le
Gérard Larcher on le dit à chaque
élection va jouer un rôle pivot sur
aussi le peut-être le choix les soutiens
qui va apporter en tout cas ça sera un
endroit où les organisations de la
droite française dans les prochaines
années peu intervenir puisque vous avez
fini par exemple s'intéresse
particulièrement à l'élection
sénatoriale même si c'est pas forcément
pour ce coup-ci peut-être plutôt pour
dans 3 ans que ça peut être un tremplin
pour 2027 alors oui mais surtout c'est
l'occasion pour gérer l'archet de
rappeler que pour lui il doit Philippe
fait partie de la famille de la droite
et de mettre en scène les proximités
avec les uns et peut-être plus les
distances avec les autres à ce titre là
je crois vraiment qu'il faut observer le
Sénat dans ce sens là il me semble que
le Sénat c'est non seulement une
résidence des part traditionnel mais
c'est aussi un endroit où on prépare
l'avenir
Bruno cotress ce qui est intéressant
aussi ça va être on l'a dit tout à
l'heure de voir comment les nouveaux
sénateurs et sénatrices vont se
positionner dans ce cadre là puis alors
il y a un match dans le match moi qui
m'intéresse beaucoup et qu'on va suivre
de près c'est le match entre horizon et
Renaissance est-ce qu'il y aura plus de
sénateurs au sénatrice horizon que le
sénateurs Renaissance d'ici 21h ou 22h
bah voilà ça c'est vraiment une des
éléments de la soirée les plus
intéressants les plus excitants pour
ceux qui suivent la vie politique parce
qu'on voit bien qu'effectivement en
fonction de la progression de l'un et
peut-être du manque de progression de de
l'autre évidemment il y a d'autres
choses qui sont en train de se tramer et
en particulier est-ce que Édouard
Philippe si jamais c'était le cas qui
progresse son groupe progrès au Sénat
est-ce que ça accentue la dynamique
qu'il souhaite impulser entre maintenant
et les mois qui arrivent affirmer sa
candidature à la présidentielle montrer
lui il est ancré dans les territoires on
sait que c'est un des points forts du
mouvement de l'ancien Premier ministre
horizon il a beaucoup d'élules locaux
qui sont assez cotés où il a des élus
locaux qui peuvent être y compris dans
le camp des républicains qui s'y
retrouve qui trouvent que il fait partie
de la famille et donc effectivement ça
c'est une des données une des données
fondamentales des prochains des
prochains mois quel est le poids de
Horizon dans le dispositif à l'intérieur
de la majorité présidentielle toujours
sans aucun doute mais de plus en plus
s'affirmant et ou affirmant sa musique
sa particularité parce que rappelons-le
il faudra quand même un moment donné si
Edouard Philippe veut se présenter à la
présidentielle qu'il explique qu'est-ce
qui le différencie
et on va continuer
terminer je m'amène à Paris Thomas on va
aller dans la capitale ou 12 sièges sont
à pourvoir un nom loin d'ici à l'hôtel
de ville de Paris on retrouve Steve
Jourdain et Jean-Baptiste Gaillot
bonjour Steve et ici à Paris et bien la
gauche uni espère un véritable
raz-de-marée
oui Thomas utilisé tout à l'heure une
métaphore sportive et bien ici on peut
dire que la gauche joue quasiment à
domicile regardez où je me trouve je me
retrouve dans la salle des fêtes de
l'hôtel de ville de Paris un hôtel de
ville qui vous le savez est tenu par la
mer socialiste Anne Hidalgo et ses
alliés écologistes et communistes et
c'est cette même alliance qui s'avance
unie dans ce scrutin des sénatoriales le
bureau de vote on verse ce matin à 8h30
la gauche espère ici faire rentrer un
huitième sénateur la gauche qui compte
déjà sept sièges au Palais du Luxembourg
en tout cas en ce qui concerne la
circonscription de Paris et laisse faire
un huitième c'est en tout cas l'objectif
aujourd'hui objectif à droite ici et
bien sauver les meubles limiter la casse
on compte les quatre sièges LR ici à
Paris en tout cas pour la droite et bien
l'objectif c'est d'éviter de de sauver
ces quatre sièges le problème et bien
c'est que la droite par très désuni il y
a une liste menée par la sénatrice
sortante Catherine Dumas et puis deux
autres listes dissidente il y a un
Séverine qui mène une liste dissidente
qui est bien la présidente de la
Fédération LR de Paris et il y a aussi
le trait Sarkozy de Pierre Charon qui
mène une liste dissidente puis un mot
sur la majorité présidentielle la
majorité présidentielle du compte
seulement un siège de sénateurs ici à
Paris on la personne de Julien Bargeton
Julien barjoton se dit confiant il
espère sauver son siège de sénateur ce
qui est certain c'est que ce qui se joue
aujourd'hui à l'hôtel de ville de Paris
c'est évidemment les sénatoriales le
visage du Sénat pour les trois
prochaines années mais aussi peut-être
pourquoi pas la succession d'Anne
Hidalgo la succession qui aura lieu en
2026 et en tout cas quelque chose qui
est beaucoup revenu dans les bouches ici
des différentes équipes fermeture des
bureaux de vote 17h30 on devrait avoir
les résultats autour de 19h merci merci
beaucoup Steve il n'y a donc pas que la
présidentielle derrière les élections
sénatoriales il y a aussi les mun
icipalités
spéciaux pour pour des points complets
des résultats au fur et à mesure
résultat officieux résultats officiels
vous aurez tout ça et puis alors ici
aussi dans la salle des conférences il y
a des résultats qui s'affichent on est
avec Alexandre Poussard qui est un tout
petit peu derrière nous à quelques à
quelques dizaines de mètres Alexandre et
expliquez-nous c'est quoi le décor
ah oui Thomas je suis un petit peu là
dans la Ruche des résultats de cette
salle des conférences du Palais du
Luxembourg au Sénat vous le voyez
derrière moi il y a mes confrères et
concerts journalistes qui travaillent et
qui est plus les premiers résultats de
ces élections sénatoriales qui sont
tombés c'est ici que vont être réalisés
et bien les réactions les interviews de
politique durant la soirée on commence
également à voir des sénateurs qui
arrivent dans cette salle des
conférences pour voir les premiers
résultats pour les voir sur ces grands
cubes blancs que vous voyez avec
quelques papiers qui vont être affichés
par département alors là pour l'instant
il y en a pas beaucoup parce qu'il y a
seulement les résultats du premier tour
et très vite et bien le puzzle de ces
résultats des élections sénatoriales va
être remplies par les services du Sénat
les résultats donc publiés par le
ministère de l'Intérieur merci beaucoup
Alexandre pour pour toutes ces
informations Anne Le vade quand on se
penche sur le mode de scrutin il y a un
côté enfin on se dit qu'un c'est
compliqué à travailler sur sur le mode
de scrutin des élections c'est la
toriales quand même
alors oui effectivement et la raison
c'est que d'abord c'est l'héritage de
l'histoire parce que depuis presque
trois républiques il y a un mode de
scrutin qui est très différent de celui
de l'assemblée et avec ce système un peu
un peu composite j'entre pas dans le
détail puis la deuxième raison c'est
quand on a deux chambres il n'est pas
anormal que ces deux chambres soient
élues dans des conditions complètement
différentes afin qu'elles ne soient pas
le clone de l'autre
exactement et que qui plus est le Sénat
ayant constitutionnellement pour mission
de représenter les collectivités
territoriales effectivement il fallait
que la circonscription électorale soit
le département ça veut dire qu'il peut
pas y avoir de redécoupage électoral par
exemple pour les sénatoriales puisque
c'est le département qui joue et le fait
est que s'il y a deux modes de scrutin
différents c'est parce que l'autre
critère comprend en considération pour
élire des représentants c'est évidemment
la démographie or il y a des
départements très peuplés l'exemple
consiste toujours c'est la Lozère et
puis il y a des départements beaucoup
plus peuplés dans lesquels il y a donc
beaucoup plus d'élus au regard du nombre
d'électeurs
c'est une question qu'on peut se poser
Gérard Larcher va
selon toute vraisemblance enchaîner un
cinquième mandat à la présidentielle
d'abord même si ça reste très ponctuel
le Sénat n'a pas toujours été à droite
voilà
le fait que
on a au terme des élections locales
plutôt des victoires notamment à
l'échelons des petites communes enfin
des petites communes des très nombreuses
du plus grand nombre de communes plutôt
des résultats qui sont qui sont
favorables à la droite
pour autant je crois que en réalité la
composition du Sénat elle est encore
beaucoup plus compliquée que cela parce
que résumer le Sénat pour être une
chambre de droite aujourd'hui c'est très
simplificateur au regard ça a été dit de
la place des centrises de la place d'un
certain nombre de groupes qui ne sont en
fait ni véritablement à droite ni à
gauche ni même exactement au centre et
puis il me semble que le Sénat
aujourd'hui sur le plan politique est
presque dans une période idéale pour lui
parce qu'il est dans une forme de de
d'opposition relative c'est à dire que
voilà le pire pour le Sénat c'est d'être
de totalement la majorité du
gouvernement parce que dans ce cas-là
évidemment c'est l'Assemblée nationale
qui joue le rôle déterminant et le Sénat
est en quelque sorte un peu en retrait
comme une espèce de supplétif et l'autre
hypothèse c'est quand il est
frontalement dans l'opposition et dans
ce cas-là c'est pas très bon non plus
puisque immédiatement on retrouve la
critique de toute façon il ne sert à
rien il est toujours contre et on va
faire l'emporter le dernier mot à
l'Assemblée nationale alors que là il
est celui qui peut débloquer des
situations celui qui peut légitimement
exercer un contrôle c'est un rôle très
important qui a le sien aujourd'hui oui
Vincent Martini sur ce rôle du Sénat
notamment depuis la dernière et les
dernières élections législatives comment
est-ce que vous pourriez le qualifier
c'est un partenaire constructif un allié
qui est plus ou moins là parce qu'on
entend quand même le président du groupe
LR Bruno Retailleau dit qu'il est très
clairement dans l'opposition
alors oui le rôle du Sénat c'est un rôle
assez complexe ce regard des dernières
élections d'abord parce qu'il faut
rappeler à vos téléspectateurs qui le
savent évidemment que les élections
législatives ont porté une majorité
relative donc en fait le rôle du Sénat
devient de plus en plus important
puisque déjà il y a une difficulté de
former une loi qui fasse objet d'un
consensus et donc le Sénat peut jouer un
rôle de position d'autant plus fort
qu'il s'appuie sur la faiblesse relative
de la majorité présidentielle à
l'Assemblée nationale ça c'est une
première chose deuxième chose le Sénat
il joue un rôle quasiment de
contre-pouvoir c'est peut-être un peu
exagéré de le dire mais en tout cas de
contrôle du gouvernement dans ses
missions il y a l'idée de contrôle de
l'action d'exécutif et dans un monde
politique français ou le pouvoir
exécutif cannibalisent un peu à une
tendance à cannibaliser les autres
pouvoirs et bien le Sénat on l'a vu dans
les commissions d'enquête parlementaires
on se rappelle de l'affaire Benalla
évidemment et bien fait l'objet d'une
sorte de contrepoint aussi il peut être
dernier élément un verrou un verrou
lorsqu'il s'agit par exemple de
faire des réformes institutionnelles et
bien on se rappelle qu'en 2019 le scénar
les avait bloqué alors on avait dit
qu'il y avait un contexte particulier
qui était celui de l'affaire Benalla de
2018 mais en réalité ce verrou s’exerce
aussi lorsqu'il s'agit
d'empêcher un certain temps de réforme
que le sénateurs considèrent
par exemple évidemment c'est
probablement d'ailleurs même l'exemple
le plus important donc il peut aussi là
jouer un rôle j'allais dire de respect
de l'État de droit lorsqu'il considère
que et bien cet État de droit est mise
en danger par les dispositions que les
les députés qui sont plus sensibles au
gouvernement puisqu'on le sait sont
l'émanation du pouvoir exécutif à
certains égards pour elle les emmener
dans une direction qui ne serait pas la
bonne et bien là le Sénat joue un rôle
de contrepoint elle est priorités aux
résultats comme promis on retrouve
Quentin calmé avec un zoom un coup
d'oeil sur les territoires d'outre-mer
on vous écoute Quentin Thomas
effectivement si collectivités
d'outre-mer qui sont concernés par ce
renouvellement j'ai des résultats pour
quatre d'entre elles on va commencer
avec Mayotte où on voit la victoire de
l'ancien président du conseil général de
Mayotte en 2004 et 2008 il s'appelle
Saïd Omar Wally membre du parti nouvelle
élan pour Mayotte il est élu avec 56%
des voix le deuxième siège est pour le
sénateur de la majorité présidentielle
tany Mohamed Souali qui est un sénateur
sortant qui est donc créé lu avec 48 %
de voix on continue avec la réunion ou
les résultats sont également officiels
de sénateurs de gauche vont entrer au
parlement à la chambre haute du
parlement de sénateurs de droite sont
élus Evelyne Corbière et Audrey bellim
sont à gauche et donc une progression
par rapport aux équilibres des sénateurs
sortants il n'y avait pas de
parlementaire de gauche à la Réunion à
noter Viviane Mallet était lu pour les
LR Stéphane foissin pour les centristes
de l'udipe on continue avec d'autres
résultats que l'on avait déjà vu depuis
ce matin mais ce sont des résultats très
importants puisqu'on a vu un membre du
gouvernement être battu Sonia baquestre
secrétaire d'État à la citoyenneté qui
est battue en Nouvelle-Calédonie on va
avoir les noms des deux sénateurs qui
ont été élus dans ce dans cette
collectivité d'outre-mer il s'agit de
George naturel et lui dès le premier
tour il est maire d'hivernes et
loyalistes de Dumbéa autre fait marquant
l'arrivée est d'un élu indépendantiste
Robert Zowie qui est le second élu dans
cette élection en Nouvelle-Calédonie ont
terminé avec une dernière personnalité
marquante qui va faire son entrée à la
Chambre haute du Parlement il s'agit il
s'agit d'Annick Girardin qui a été
ministre pendant les quinquennats de
François Hollande puis d'Emmanuel Macron
elle était du aujourd'hui à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon on va se revoir
très vite Thomas et Tam car
effectivement les résultats vont
commencer à se multiplier puisque le
dépouillement et bien est en train de se
terminer dans beaucoup de départements
Thomas merci beaucoup n'hésitez pas à
vous nous faites si vous n'êtes pas très
loin quelques quelques mètres légèrement
en dessous de nous on est on est tous au
Sénat évidemment Mathieu croissant on a
démarré ce premier débat autour de du
destin de Sonia bagages j'ai une
question qui est peut-être un peu
basique mais c'est plus compliqué est-ce
que c'est plus compliqué de faire
campagne quand on est min
dans un territoire comme celui-là enfin
voilà est-ce que s'il n'y a pas là aussi
parce qu'on tire une leçon un peu
générale mais il y a pas aussi une
question de présence ou est-ce qu'elle
est-ce qu'elle était suffisamment
présente pour faire campagne auprès des
élus dans dans son département alors ça
c'est une vraie question notamment pour
un territoire qui est métropole donc
c'est c'est sans doute une vraie
question après normalement il y a quand
même un petit avantage compétitif quand
vous êtes quand vous êtes ministre parce
que quand vous êtes ministre vous êtes
considérés comme plutôt proche du
pouvoir et donc plutôt influent et donc
pouvant peut-être orienter ou obtenir de
meilleurs décisions c'est des dossiers
quand vous en êtes loin voilà donc c'est
plutôt un un avantage surtout auprès de
grands électeurs qui sont généralement
des des élus qui sont eux-mêmes à la
tête de collectivité qui participent
eux-mêmes à des projets d'avoir un
relais à Paris dans la capitale au
pouvoir avec des entrées ça fait c'est
plutôt et je dis ça voilà c'est la vie
politique c'est Emmanuel Macron n'a pas
toujours été très populaire auprès des
territoires des élus locaux avec toutes
les Ré
être ministre de cette majorité là en ce
moment c'est vrai que c'est peut-être un
peu plus compliqué parce que la
situation politique l'ère on l'a rappelé
vers l'année a été quand même très très
complexe cette réforme des retraites qui
a été très contestée il est vrai il y a
chez Emmanuel Macron une pratique
extrêmement verticale de pouvoir qui a
tenté en tout cas en début de du premier
quinquennat de fer fille de décor
intermédiaires et d'une certaine façon
de traiter les élus comme comme des gens
qui suivraient de toute façon les
orientations générales fixées par la
politique elle est sur nationale ça a
changé quand même un peu il faut le dire
la crise covid la crise des gilets
jaunes sont passés par là et petit à
petit le prisme a changé à l'Élysée mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a toujours cette idée
d'un pouvoir déconnecté hors sol et
peut-être que cette étiquette là cette
petite caricature quand on est la
majorité on dit que c'est une caricature
quand on est dans l'opposition on dit
que c'est une réalité mais voilà cette
éthique est là en tout cas et peut-être
un peu lourd la portée alors on a tout à
l'heure parlé du pouvoir de contrôle du
côté contre-pouvoir du Sénat et à ce
propos on va rejoindre
Alexandre Poussard qui est dernière nous
celle des conférences avec le président
socialiste de la commission des finances
c'est Claude Raynal qui a également
présidé récemment et bien la commission
d'enquête sur le fond Marianne c'est à
VOUS Alexandra bonsoir Claude rénal
alors on parlait sur le plateau du rôle
de contrôle du gouvernement de la part
du Sénat et finalement la commission
d'enquête sur le fond Marianne que vous
a que vous avez présidé bien elle a mis
vraiment en valeur ce rôle de contrôle
oui comme d'ailleurs un certain nombre
de commissions qui ont été mené depuis
quelques années par le Sénat que ce soit
parce que le fond Marianne bon on a
beaucoup mis l'accent sur cette sur
cette commission d'enquête et puis c'est
la dernière mais bien avant il y a eu
celle sur
McKinsey qui a été extrêmement
importante très suivie et surtout suivez
des faits c'est à dire que derrière tout
d'un coup le gouvernement s'est rendu
compte des sommes qui dépensaient je
crois qu'ils avaient jamais sommet les
les sommes qu'il dépensaient pour les
cabinets conseils et donc cela a été
fait ça a été utile et suivi des faits
vous voyez de la même façon on a eu une
commission d'enquête extrêmement
intéressante et extrêmement importante
dans l'avenir sur les questions de qui
possède de la presse et des jeux
d'influence dans la presse et là aussi
je crois que ce travail là du Sénat
extrêmement riche extrêmement profond
fournira des résultats dans les dans les
prochains mois et aura des échos voilà
donc il y a d'un côté quelquefois des
commissions bancaires qui sont comment
dire un peu très populaires qui sont
très regardés mais il y a aussi tout un
travail de fond permanent sur des sujets
qui sont finalement qui aboutissent à
des modifications dans la manière de
travailler du gouvernement et c'est ça
qui est le plus important alors
effectivement il y a eu des commissions
d'enquête très médiatique pendant les
deux quinquennats d'Emmanuel Macron
notamment en souvient de la commission
enquête sur l'affaire Benalla en 2018
est-ce que vous diriez que c'est
investigations ces enquêtes sénatoriales
ça a tendu les relations avec l'exécutif
bon je n'ai pas eu conscience en tout
cas si vous voulez en ce qui concerne en
tout cas la dernière je ne l'ai pas
ressenti ainsi et si on l'a pas ressenti
ainsi c'est que je crois qu'on a essayé
et qu'on a fait un travail tout à fait
neutre du point de vue politique c'est à
dire qu'on a établi des faits on a
montré des problématiques et on a laissé
chacun jouer son rôle on aura d'un côté
le parquet qui s'est saisi des questions
finalement judiciaires et on aura de
l'autre côté la question politique de
manière générale le gouvernement a
tranché si je puis dire merci beaucoup
Claude Raynal pour votre réaction
merci beaucoup merci Alexandre poussat
évidemment très régulièrement vous
participez à nos à nos débats grâce à
vos invités politiques on va voir tiens
quelques images de dépouillement en
cours et 18h18 on va avoir
régulièrement autour de cette soirée
électorale les résultats des grandes
villes Landes à Paris en train de
dépouiller les les votes des grands
électeurs on reste sur cette thématique
des commissions d'enquête Anne Levade il
y a il y a ceux qui critiquent en disant
oui American et c'est un presque une
américanisation notre vie politique avec
le côté spectaculaire sauf que moi je
suis frappé par le travail qui est fait
et tous ceux qui participent à ces
commissions d'enquête qui sont pas
seulement d'ailleurs les missions
d'information sont souvent surpris par
le travail effectué la qualité la
précision des questions posées
alors c'est vrai qu'il y a eu une forme
de de j'allais dire presque révolution
culturelle autour de ces questions de
commission d'enquête même si et on a
tendance à l'oublier le Sénat a été à
cet égard pionnier c'est-à-dire que même
s'il est commissions d'enquête
évidemment ont pu être mise en place
depuis les premiers temps du régime
parlementaire en pratique sous la
Cinquième République c'est le Sénat qui
au début des années 70 va initier les
premières commissions d'enquête
justement parce qu'il est conscient que
dans le schéma institutionnel des
premières décennies de la Cinquième
République il n'a pas un rôle
véritablement important donc en réalité
il y a une forme de tradition
sénatoriale pour exercer ce contrôle
sous une forme alors le terme va
peut-être faire sourire j'allais dire
apaiser au sens où il n'y a pas comme
contrepartie la possibilité de renverser
le gouvernement c'est-à-dire que c'est
une grande différence avec l'Assemblée
nationale ou bien sûr on peut avoir des
commissions d'enquête mais où on sait
aussi que ça peut déclencher derrière
une motion de censure et que le climat
peut être suffisamment éruptif pour
conduire à cela alors que vous sur le
côté apaisé mais sauf pour ceux qui sont
sur le grill des questions
ça on est bien d'accord
a été une espèce de de tournant aussi
parce que il y a eu la un choix
stratégique en quelque sorte de
s'emparer de cette affaire qui en plus
survient alors que on est en session
extraordinaire que se pose donc la
question de savoir si on peut organiser
la commission d'enquête c'est donc le
président de la commission des lois qui
transforme la commission des lois en
commission d'enquête enfin voilà il y a
eu un jeu en même temps avec le
règlement du du Sénat qui le rendait
possible et qui a conduit à ce que cette
commission soit particulièrement
observée dans un contexte l'année 2018
qui par ailleurs était délicate pour
l'exécutif Bruno cotresse Anne Levade
disait à l'instant que et bien les
commissions d'enquête ça fait partie de
l'ADN depuis un certain temps déjà du
Sénat mais c'est vrai que c'est assez
récent que le grand public s'intéresse
autant aux commissions d'enquête ça date
de l'affaire Benalla ça aussi permis de
redorer l'image du Sénat à ce moment-là
oui incontestablement alors au-delà
évidemment le public a été très marqué
d'abord par la recette benalapi par les
travaux de cette commission d'enquête
avec des scores d'audience absolument
incroyables pour vos antennes d'ailleurs
bravo
record d'antenne à la commission
d'enquête Benalla mais alors il faut
essayer de situer ça mais un peu plus un
peu plus gênant ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est que le Sénat qui est
des perçu comme une institution un peu
lointaine avec un mode d'élection un peu
mystérieux des sénateurs on sait pas
très très bien ce qui ce qu'ils font ben
d'un seul coup à un effet d'accéléra
d'accélérateur considérable et d'autant
plus important que le Sénat quand même a
quand même toujours un certain nombre
d'enjeux pour montrer que l'institution
colle un peu davantage aux
préoccupations de la société il y a
toujours quand même un peu en toile de
fond la question de la bonne
représentation il y a deux tiers des
sénateurs qui sont élus à la
proportionnelle mais il reste un tiers
aux majoritaire donc ça fait l'objet de
débat effectivement et puis il y a la
question de la parité il y a que 36% de
sénatrices même si ça progresse il n'y
avait que cinq femmes en 1959 là on en a
11 aujourd'hui donc il y a une
progressions d'enquête contre balance ce
procès en représentativité
des sénateurs moyens d'âge 60 ans à
l'Assemblée nationale 49 ans donc voilà
et ça contrebalance effectivement cette
image un peu on va dire un peu lointaine
du Sénat merci
que contrairement à l'Assemblée
nationale ou pour un peu exister les
députés doivent accepter une forme de
personnalisation c'est-à-dire qu'on
connaît les députés essentiels de
l'Assemblée nationale au Sénat la
particularité du Sénat c'est que le
Sénat a acquis ce pouvoir à travers les
commissions parlementaires qui est un
pouvoir collectif c'est comme collectif
qu'on connaît cela évidemment les les
fans de politique connaissent gérarchie
connaissent un certain nombre peut-être
de présidents de groupe mais la plupart
des sénateurs et c'est pas leur faire
offense que le dire cela sont totalement
inconnus du grand public et d'ailleurs
il n'essaye pas de jouer la carte de la
personnalisation et dans un système
politique qui se nourrit totalement de
personnalisation de personnalisation qui
est ambivalente parce qu'elle permet de
faire connaître des acteurs politiques
et une action ou une décision politique
mais qui est aussi le revers de cette
médaille parce qu'elle crée beaucoup de
polarisation autour de évidemment du
président de la République mais autour
de n'importe quelle personnalité qui va
se présenter devant les médias pour
pouvoir
s'affirmer aussi en tant qu'individu le
Sénat est un lieu et c'est le sud de ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure un
lieu où les parties traditionnels ont un
rôle et où pour retrouver cette formule
de qu'on utilisait que tu sais pierre
ronzo wallon le culte de
l'impersonnalité joue encore c'est à
dire que ce qui compte c'est que les
sénateurs soient connus comme groupe
mais pas comme individu et puis c'est
peut-être Bruno cotress en bon on peut
rester avec vous sur le fait que ces
commissions d'enquête mais aussi les
missions d'information elles sont qu'aux
présidées par des représentants de
familles politiques qui s'opposent aussi
dans l'hémicycle sur le dans les débats
et dans sur le des lois donc là on est
aussi dans dans ce contraste par rapport
à l'Assemblée nationale d'une
co-construction
finalement de l'action de l'action
parlementaire oui si on voulait étendre
le tableau il faudrait de ce point-là
situer d'ailleurs le Sénat dans
l'ensemble de nos institutions à côté
aussi de la troisième assemblée le
conseiller économique social
environnemental qui lui aussi joue
beaucoup la carte au fond du dialogue
beaucoup de monde du Conseil Économique
Social disent là on peut au palais
d'héna on peut discuter le patrona peut
discuter avec les syndicats les
différents membres de la Société s'ils
peuvent dialogues entre eux au Sénat la
même chose les différentes formations
politiques les différents groupes
peuvent s'unir on le voit régulièrement
par exemple dans le travail de rapport
d'enquête rapports sur des points précis
de l'action publique dans l'évaluation
de l'action publique également et
effectivement ça fait partie de ce de ce
bon équilibre des pouvoirs alors on va
continuer de d'évoquer ce rôle de
contre-pouvoir mais on rejoint tout de
suite
Alexandre Poussard alors rejoint pas
très loin il est juste derrière nous
dans cette salle des conférences
magnifique salle des conférences quand
même un privilège de travailler ici et
un terme quelques années que vous
travaillez à la rédaction de Public
Sénat je ne vais pas dire pour bien je
ne serais pas un délicat mais c'est
quand même un bonheur absolu de
travailler dans un cadre comme celui-là
je le rappelle et donc Alexandre poussa
il est pour les réactions politiques
avec Philippe mouiller le sénateur LRD
Deux-Sèvres à vous la main Alex et oui
Philippe mouiller vice-président du
groupe LR au Sénat bonsoir Philippe
mouiller bonsoir quels sont les enjeux
pour vous de ce scrutin sénatorial 2023
on va pas se mentir la majorité de
droite et du centre ne n'est pas très
inquiète ce soir non non tout à fait
donc pour nous un des enjeux c'est
justement de pouvoir confirmer
stabiliser si finalement cette majorité
et à travers ça c'est aussi la prise de
position politique la façon dont nous
traitons les sujets les textes de loi
qui est confirmé par les résultats
justement quel doit être la stratégie de
la majorité de droite du Sénat est-ce
que elle doit être constructive avec le
gouvernement ou vraiment marquer son
opposition je crois qu'il faut qu'on
garde notre marque de fabrique et c'est
ce sera la reconnaissance si les choses
se déroulent correctement dans dans les
urnes globalement on prend les textes au
fur et à mesure on a une ligne politique
qui est claire le jeu généralement nos
pudding de position sont connues et donc
à chaque texte bien nous regardons
comment nous pouvons améliorer les
textes et faire en sorte que nos idées
ne convictions se retrouvent dans les
votes qui se traduisent ici au Sénat
donc c'est vraiment un travail texte par
textes alors forcément de temps en temps
avec un lien étroit avec le gouvernement
et de temps en temps en opposition ferme
lorsqu'on n'est pas d'accord sur le fond
des textes finalement vous ne faites pas
selon vous de politique politicienne
nous aide pas dans une opposition
systématique non non je crois que on est
surtout dans une démarche de porter nos
convictions de porter nos choix
politiques et donc on se traduit par les
textes que nous votons et ça c'est
marqué d'autant plus dans cette année
dans la première année du quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron finalement il y a une
relation qui s'est intensifiée entre la
droite sénatoriale et le gouvernement
notamment sur la forme des retraites et
entendu de par la situation l'Assemblée
nationale on voit bien que le dialogue
politique se passe en grande partie
aujourd'hui au Sénat et donc en gardant
cette ligne en gardant cette volonté qui
a le plan de l'archet va pouvoir
toujours avoir un intérêt général qui
est l'intérêt de la France et bien au
fur et à mesure on travaille sur ces
textes là et je vous dis parfois on
trouve des désaccords comme pour les
retraites inversement de temps en temps
on est dans un affrontement ou en tout
cas de nos positions claire en quelques
mots Philippe mouillé pour finir la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales ici au Sénat Catherine de roche
ne se représente pas et ce que vous êtes
intéressé par le poste oui clairement
j'ai fait acte de candidature possède
commission mais c'est un deuxième sujet
après les élections sénatoriales la
bataille des commissions ce sera après
ces élections sénatoriales ici au Sénat
et voilà à chaque chose en son temps
mais il pense en se rasant Philippe
mouillé un mot sur les expressions que
vient d'utiliser Philippe mouiller mais
tu crois sans dos texte par texte c'est
l'expression qu'on entend beaucoup dans
la bouche de la première ministre
Elisabeth borne et on voit donc là un
membre de la majorité sénatoriale
vice-président du groupe qu'il emploie à
son tour le courant ne passe pas mal
entre le gouvernement et la majorité
sénatorielle il a dit une chose très
juste Philippe mouillée en gros ici au
Sénat on travaille les textes avant la
couleur des textes et ça c'est quelque
chose qui quel que soit le contexte
politique se vérifie on a ici des
artisans de la loi souvent des biens
plus fins connaisseurs de la loi qu'à
l'Assemblée où on est plus dans le
combat politique dans le combat
polémique ça c'est une chose après
texte par text oui ça s'est vu parce que
le gouvernement l'exécutif tente une
chose qu'ils pensent à bille
c'est-à-dire de démarrer au Sénat pour
essayer de caler une majorité avec la
droite et ensuite de revenir l'Assemblée
en disant ben vos copains du Sénat ont
voté donc est-ce que vous pouvez voter
le même texte
les énergies renouvelables il y a eu la
sécurité
l'immigration on verra voilà donc oui ça
peut marcher sur sur certains textes
mais ça ne marche pas toujours parce que
le Sénat et la droite sénatoriale aussi
une identité propre qui n'est pas
forcément majoritaire chez l'air et en
tout cas pas majoritaire au groupe LR à
l'Assemblée ou c'est parfois difficile
de distinguer une ligne donc il y a pas
d'effet mécanique automatique mais c'est
vrai que le Sénat plutôt jouer le jeu
que lui proposait l'exécutif c'est pas
une chambre de blocage c'est une chambre
de contrôle on l'a dit c'est une forme
de contre-pouvoir mais ça jamais été une
chambre de il y a eu des oppositions
historiques parfois oui avec des
allers-retours des navettes et le Sénat
qui disent non mais au final on sait que
c'est l'assemblée qui a le dernier mot
donc le Sénat n'a aucun intérêt à jouer
le blocage pour le blocage alors qu'il
peut peser sur les textes et là avec un
gouvernement en exécutif affaibli il a
les moyens de peser sur les textes à
condition bien sûr qu'il soit suivi au
palais gourmand il est 18h30 si vous
nous rejoignez à l'instant sur l'antenne
de Public Sénat soirée spéciale élection
sénatoriales déjà des surprises les
premières tendances les leçons à tirer
tout au long de cette soirée en
attendant jusqu'à 22h30 pour décortiquer
les leçons politiques de de ces
élections à la haute assemblée et nous
sommes toujours avec notre mosaïque avec
tous nos journalistes qui sont en duplex
depuis les différents
un show de France notamment dans le Nord
à Lille nous sommes avec Samia dechyr et
Olivier Molinari Matthias se trouve dans
la Moselle avec Julien Sengel ils sont à
Metz et nous sommes aussi dans les
Hauts-de-Seine à Nanterre avec Audrey
bietaz et Marion goussi et puis à Paris
c'est Steve Jourdain et Jean-Baptiste
Gaillot pour nous donner les résultats
envoyés les images de dépouillement tout
à l'heure les images de dépouillement à
Paris à l'hôtel de ville on aura les
résultats on l'espère dans quelques
minutes des résultats justement Quentin
Calmet est là pour nous en donner très
régulièrement on rejoint tout de suite
Quentin qui est dans le le studio des
émissions de Public Sénat rebonsoir le
nouveau studio c'est moi qui voilà la
joie de pouvoir présenter les résultats
depuis le nouveau studio de Public Sénat
effectivement je vous donne quelques
rappels de résultats qu'on a depuis
plusieurs heures maintenant avant
d'avoir une Myrielle de nouveaux
résultats qui devrait arriver dans les
prochaines minutes on va regarder
rapidement ce qui se joue par exemple en
Mayenne puisqu'il y a deux séries pour
voir et qu'on a déjà vu une personnalité
être réélu dans ce département il s'agit
de la centriste Elisabeth Doisneau connu
pour être la rapporteur général du
budget de la Sécurité sociale elle a été
élu des premiers tours dans l'Orne c'est
la sénatrice centriste Nathalie Goulet
qui est élu pour un troisième mandat de
sénatrice dans ce département normand
dans les Landes c'est un carton plein
pour les socialistes sortant
Eric kerrouch et Monique Lubin c'est
intéressant car Eric kerrouch il
pourrait vouloir être candidat à la
présidence du groupe socialiste face à
Patrick Kanner on verra ça dans un
deuxième temps après l'élection
sénatoriale dans la Haute-Loire carton
plein pour la majorité de la droite et
du centre de sénateurs sont réélu dès le
premier tour le centriste Olivier
ségolotti Le LR Laurent Duplomb un très
connu pour son engagement sur les
questions de l'agriculture dans le Lot
un nouvel entrant le maire PS2 Cahors
Jean-Marc vesus fort est élu dès le
premier tour on va voir qui de Angèle
Préville ou du radical de gauche Raphaël
Daub encore en liste pour le second tour
sera élu dans ce département et on
termine avec des personnalités tout
d'abord la secrétaire d'État la
citoyenneté c'est l'information
importante de la journée Sonia bac S qui
est battu en Nouvelle-Calédonie car et
bien ce sont deux élus qui sont élus
Georges naturel de ceinture qui sont les
Georges naturels divers droites et
également Robert Zoé qui est un élu
indépendantiste qui a fait son entrée à
la Chambre haute du Parlement et on
termine avec une ancienne ministre
Annick Girardin qui était lui à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et qui va donc
faire son entrée au Sénat voilà Thomas
des résultats il y en a beaucoup qui
arrivent on se prépare ici à la cellule
résultats merci beaucoup Quentin à tout
à l'heure et si vous voulez suivre
minute par minute voilà la publication
de ces résultats n'hésitez pas à aller
sur le site la plateforme Public Sénat
point FR et nous sommes toujours sur ce
plateau avec la professeur de droit
constitutionnaliste Anne Levade
également avec nous à Bruno cotress
politologue chercheur au CNRS et aussi
pof Vincent Martini professeur de
sciences politiques et Université de
Nice et à l'École polytechnique vous
êtes également chercheur associé aux CVP
et Mathieu croissanto éditorialiste
politique on va peut-être parler ce là
on a on a encore beaucoup de temps
ensemble pour se concentrer sur les
enjeux de cette soirée et de se scrutin
peut-être famille politique par famille
politique je commence avec vous Mathieu
alors par la droite allez on va
commencer par la majorité de droite et
du centre on a fait plusieurs émissions
ensemble de sciences publiques depuis
deux trois semaines ou ont commencé
toujours par dire il y a pas beaucoup de
suspense et puis après on se rendait
compte que finalement il y avait il y
avait pas mal d'inconnus à à lever on
devrait quand même pas changer de
majorité au scénar on peut dire ça sans
trop de crainte de se tromper non a
priori si jamais on est extrêmement
surpris mais en toute logique en toute
cohérence la droite devrait conserver sa
majorité après ce qui est toujours
important c'est voilà est-ce qu'on va
être 5 postes de moins 5 postes de plus
beaucoup plus le même nombre voilà ça ne
devrait pas remettre en cause en tout
cas les ambitions de Gérard Larcher et
la droite est plutôt dans une situation
confortable elle aborde ses sénatoriale
d'une façon confortable elle est plutôt
bien implantée on le sait localement
elle a plutôt réussi sa dernière vague
de municipale en 2020 elle a sauvé les
bastions elle a plutôt réussi aussi ces
élections régionales donc il y a pas
tellement de soucis ou de suspense après
c'est que va faire la droite de sa
majorité sénatoriale c'est plutôt ça la
question qui se pose est-ce que ça peut
être le camp de base de la recomposition
de la droite on sait que à l'Assemblée
nationale on en disait un mot tout à
l'heure c'est un peu le foutoir les
députés ne se sentent pas un féodés
alors à leur partie ne se sentent pas
obligés d'appliquer la ligne et chacun
se considérait élus sur son propre nom
par ses propres électeurs et mène un peu
sa barque au Sénat c'est différent il y
a la possibilité de mener un vrai
travail de fond pour recomposer la
famille LR essentiellement puisque c'est
c'est cette droite là qui tient et qui
tient le lead dans le groupe de la
majorité sénatoriale on sait qu'il y a
des personnalités importantes au Sénat
Bruno retaillod qui a des ambitions il y
en a d'autres donc voilà est-ce que le
droit sénatorial peut devenir le
laboratoire de la recomposition LR à la
fois sur le plan des idées mais aussi
sur le plan j'allais dire de la tactique
ou de la stratégie électorale
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
cette exécutif qui tend la main
l'exécutif c'est pas facile une fois il
tend la main une fois aimé une baffe
mais c'est est-ce que est-ce que la
droite va continuer de subir ou est-ce
qu'elle va essayer de prendre
l'initiative comme il y a vite parfois
ces grands anciens on pense évidemment à
Nicolas Sarkozy qui lui est plutôt dans
l'idée d'une main tendue à l'exécutif
pour mieux la contrôler
du coup on s'intéresse un peu à la ligne
qui pourrait sortir des urnes parce
qu'on l'a dit il peut y avoir aussi
différentes nuances de bleu au sein de
cette droite qu'est-ce qui peut
l'emporter notamment dans ce contexte où
on voit aussi bien sûr et bien les
ambitions d'horizon qui arrivent à côté
de celle DLR oui ce qui est intéressant
c'est que la question de savoir si la
droite va garder la majorité pas une
question on l'a dit ou quasiment pas une
question en revanche les nuances dont
vous parlez c'est-à-dire la projection
d'horizon aussi le des groupes centrist
comment vont-ils résister ce qu'ils vont
pouvoir trouver un espace sachant que
les centristes c'est pas les centrist de
renaissance c'est les centrices associés
au centre droit et qui eux cherchent à
exister depuis un certain nombre
d'années justement dans cette espèce de
réorganisation globale de la vie
politique et bah le Sénat peut être
aussi une occasion pour eux de peser à
droite dans l'avenir des gens autour des
amis d'Hervé Morin par exemple le
nouveau centre d'union centriste etc qui
sont représentés ici et là au Sénat
galaxie du centre la grande galaxie qui
joue un rôle fondamental de parti plus
que pivot même au Sénat et bien ils
peuvent ici espérer peser dans l'avenir
encore une fois je suis pas sûr que le
Sénat sera le lieu où ça va se faire
c'est plutôt que le chien va devenir un
outil un instrument potentiellement pour
la droite d'une future potentielle
conquête du pouvoir en 2027 si elle
devait il parvenir Samia Dechy est avec
nous en duplex en direct de l'île dans
le Nord avec Olivier Molinari un point
sur les résultats les faits les premiers
faits marquants dans le Nord et puis
surtout les enjeux de cette soirée Samia
et bien en fait on est encore en plein
dépouillons ici dans le Nord Thomas et
il y a du suspense de l'anxiété même
pourraient-on dire chez les têtes de
liste parce qu'il y a du monde ici
beaucoup de monde on l'a dit tout à
l'heure il y a 16 listes pour 11 sièges
de sénateurs à pourvoir alors certains
sortants bien sûr sont sûrs d'être élu
on pense à Patrick canard président du
groupe socialiste au Sénat ou encore
Marc Philippe daubrais le sénateur
sortant les républicains qui est anciens
ministres l'enjeu en fait c'est plutôt
de savoir combien de sièges vont faire
leur liste qui va gagner des sièges qui
va en perdre comment on va s'en sortir
le centre est-ce que les divisions de la
gauche et de la droite vont profiter au
rassemblement national est-ce que ce
rassemblement national va réussir à
faire élire ici un sénateur au Sénat
c'est très difficile pour l'instant de
répondre encore à ces questions parce
que tout va se jouer pour certains
sièges dans un mouchoir de poche on
attend donc toujours le résultat du
dépouillement qui est en train de se
dérouler juste derrière moi ici à la
préfecture du Nord à Lille merci merci
beaucoup Samia Bruno cotreesse on disait
qu'il y avait pas tellement de suspense
sur ce scrutin mais on voit quand même
et bien qu'il peut y avoir de grandes
divisions qui peuvent faire rebattre les
cartes dans certains départements très
observés comme celui du Nord oui des
divisions on l'a dit tout à l'heure des
dissidents de candidatures des
situations locales beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus complexes et encore une
fois on en parle depuis plusieurs fois
la situation au centre est une situation
intéressante mais à gauche aussi il va y
avoir de ce point de vue là des choses
extrêmement intéressantes qui vont qui
vont se passer et pour revenir sur la
gauche sans elle est fin d'une certaine
façon est-ce qu'on peut dire
effectivement puisque la la gauche était
dans la foulée des élections
législatives de 2022 on va dire dans la
trajectoire de la nupesse cette nouvelle
formation politique très récente avec
déjà des difficultés de gouvernance de
fonctionnement et effectivement on voit
qu'au lendemain décèdentoriales il va y
avoir sans doute une grande explication
peut-être peut-être un peu saignante à
l'intérieur de la de la nupaise Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a déjà d'ores et déjà montré
on va dire que lui considérait que
c'était un casus belli de ne pas avoir
fait cet accord au moment des
sénatoriales et surtout avec la
perspective des européennes derrière ou
la carrément on est maintenant dans une
difficulté très grande avec des tensions
très fortes à gauche on y reviendra aux
enjeux de la gauche mais je reste sur la
question de la majorité sénatoriale elle
est récent triste elle va le le premier
juge de paix ça va être ça va être
vraiment intéressant de voir comment les
nouveaux sénateurs se positionnent ça va
être le texte immigration on peut
l'imaginer on va commencer à voir si ça
va être un juge de paix non la première
étape ça va quand même être la
composition des groupes et aussi la
désignation des présidents de groupes
politiques parce que
là aussi alors évidemment ça concerne
tout le spectre mais pour la droite ça
va quand même amener à compter les
troupes même si il y a pas la majorité
des sénateurs LR qui voit aujourd'hui
leur siège remis en jeu la question va
être de savoir si effectivement il y a
un groupe horizon ou
il se positionne et que font les
sénateurs qui seraient élus sous cette
bannière et donc ça ça va déjà être des
éléments j'allais dire d'arbitrage après
le c'est pas tellement le juge de paix
ça va être le jugement en quelque sorte
c'est là qu'on va voir si le calcul est
bien fait ou pas mais comme ça a été dit
à plusieurs reprises le fait est que la
discipline de vote au Sénat au sens
discipline de groupe et beaucoup moins
forte et beaucoup moins problématique si
j'ose dire qu'à l'assemblé c'est à dire
que on sait bien que c'est pas dans la
culture des sénateurs que d'imaginer de
de virer un sénateur au motif qu'il
n'aurait pas voté comme l'ensemble de
son groupe donc ça ça change la donne
sur des sujets aussi délicats avec
l'immigration peut-être avant de avant
de rejoindre Mathias pour un nouveau
duplex Mathieu un mot là-dessus parce
que on a on a évoqué les la difficulté
parfois de lire la stratégie LR entre le
Sénat d'un côté l'Assemblée nationale de
l'autre est-ce que c'est plus lisible
sur la question de l'immigration ou pas
c'est à dire que est-ce qu'il y a plus
d'unités de pensée si j'ose dire sur ce
texte là entre la majorité
sénatoriale lrsentriste et les députés
LR oui on peut l'imaginer on peut
l'imaginer parce que l'immigration est
devenue maintenant un cheval de bataille
pour LR quasiment un des seuls qui lui
restent puisque si on caricature on peut
dire que la politique économique elle a
été
Emmanuel Macron a fait une OPA dessus et
le côté
identitaire a été pris par
eczémo et parfois Marine Le Pen donc il
reste la question de la sécurité de
l'immigration et sur l'immigration c'est
vrai que pour le coup il y a moins de il
y a moins de divergences à l'intérieur
du parti en interne et sans doute entre
députés et sénateurs que sur la question
des retraites où on a une droite un peu
à front renversé souvenez-vous puisque
le texte initialement était quand même
une copie quasi conforme de du travail
qui avait été fait ici au Sénat
plusieurs côtés
d'une façon un peu curieuse là sur le
sur le texte immigration on voit bien
que il y a quand même une sensibilité
commune qui est partagée l'idée c'est de
ne pas voter aussi au caricatures de
voter les mesures dures méchant avec les
méchants des Gérald Darmanin pour
caricaturer et de ne pas voter les
mesures dites douce notamment la
question la fameuse question de la
titularisation des des sans-papiers dans
les secteurs en tension est-ce qu'on
leur donne des papiers ou non les
gentils avec les gentils comme des
gendarmes ça elle est ne veut pas
entendre parler
problèmes major
ité exactement exactement parce qu'on
sait il y a une sensibilité pour le coup
qui est différente dans le groupe dans
le groupe centriste on sait qu'il y
avait Marseille n'a pas forcément et il
dit la même position que ce qui peut
être engagée par le le travail à droite
et l'air au Sénat allez on retrouve tout
de suite Mathias as à Metz où il se
trouve avec Julien Sengel Mathias
pourrait bien des résultats aux
conditionnel pour l'instant
absolument ici la liste estampillée
majorité sénateur sénatorial serait en
train de réaliser un tour de force la
liste emmenée par Jean-Marie mizon à
parenté Union centriste accompagnée avec
Catherine belriti elle qui est investie
par les républicains réaliserait un très
bon score et pourrait faire ce soir de
voir trois sièges ici auquel cas il
pourrait emmener avec eux à Paris le
premier adjoint à la mairie de Metz le
docteur qualifié qualifié dans l'ordre
protocolaire ensuite on trouverait
Michael Weber le socialiste réaliserait
aussi un siège ce soir ici un seul mot
un siège seulement tout comme Christine
erzog autre sénatrice sortant
ancienne-colistière de Jean-Louis Masson
ensuite et bien cette quatrième position
elle est à la lutte entre le RN Michelle
Rambourg et la candidate horizon Anne
boucher qui pourrait tous deux se
batailler le dernier siège ici du
département de Moselle un dernier siège
qui leur reviendrait seulement si et
seulement si la liste Jean-Marie maison
et Catherine bellettier ne réaliserait
pas ce soir un troisième siège Tam merci
merci beaucoup Mathias merci Mathias on
le voit et bien finalement le RN c'était
plus tendu qu'on peut l'imaginer pour
l'instant pour la quatrième position ce
n'est pas assuré sur la Moselle Bruno
cotress et on voit en revanche et bien
la majorité sénatoriale qui est encore
une fois très très bien implanté si ça
se confirmait c'est illustrerait encore
une fois qu'aux élections sénatoriales
et bien il faut avoir des des troupes
s'ils sont ces grands électeurs qui sont
issus en particulier des conseils
municipaux on voit il y a vous savez il
y a de l'ordre de 500 000 conseillers
municipaux en France
l'immense majorité l'écrasante majorité
d'entre eux n'ont pas d'étiquettes
politiques ceux qui sont estampillés
rassemblement national il se compte par
quelques centaines et donc effectivement
il y a un problème de de réservoir de de
voix le jour des élections sénatoriales
pour que des conseillers des délégués de
conseil municipaux estampillés RN vote
pour leur cand et on voit à quel point
pour des formations politiques y compris
comme le rassemblement national qui a
qualifié sa candidate deux fois au
deuxième tour de la présidentielle
combien il est difficile pour eux
d'exister dans les profondeurs du pays
malgré les excellents résultats du RN
aux élections législatives aussi où ça
progression dans les différents scrutins
locaux mais c'est pas l'équivalent par
exemple des républicains et juste alors
même que la Moselle n'était pas un
terrain qu'il aurait été
particulièrement défavorable
rassemblement national au contraire
c'est un terrain où j'étais plutôt bien
implanté oui c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'on en a fait l'un de nos points
chauds Vincent Martini mais est-ce que
ça veut dire parce que il y a un secret
du vote
vous voyez ce que je veux dire donc on
pourrait avoir des des conseillers
municipaux qui ne sont qui sont encartés
à un autre parti choisir le
rassemblement national avoir un autre
caché enfin on a du mal à quand même
même si j'ai bien entendu vos
explications à ne pas trouver cette ce
système de vasque communicants entre les
scrutins nationaux et notamment ce que
tu as un présidentiel et un scrutin
comme celui-ci oui c'est assez étonnant
deux trois sièges ça nourrit comme les
critiques aussi à l'encontre du scrutin
au Sénat critique que je trouve un peu
injuste mais c'est vrai qu'il y a des
critiques qui supportent sur le collège
électoral le scénar beaucoup plus que
sur le scrutin le scrutin c'est vrai
très compliqué à comprendre de
l'extérieur les grands électeurs la
double bon en tout cas pour le disons
que les les Français qui sont pas
forcément très proches des institutions
c'est pas très facile à comprendre en
revanche c'est vrai qu'il y a des
critiques qui sont opérées sur la nature
du collège électoral un collègue
électoral où on sait que les 8% des
grands lecteurs les communes les plus
rurales pèsent sur beaucoup plus dans le
collège électoral donc là il y a un peu
un décalage aussi entre
la représentation telle qu'elle devrait
s'opérer y compris si on prend au
sérieux cette idée du sida comme une
chambre des territoires est-ce peut-être
un mot sur lequel je voudrais insister
parce que beaucoup de Français de vous
dirais le Sénat chambre des territoires
moi je ne connais pas mon sénateur
j'habite dans un territoire rural le
sénateur et pas une personnalité locale
très identifiée bien au contraire il est
il est relativement invisibilisé en
revanche les sénateurs revendiquent de
porter au Sénat les intérêts des
territoires ruraux mais c'est pas la
même chose là vous avez un décalage sur
l'idée même de ce que c'est que la
représentation la représentation c'est
être
identifié par les gens qui vous
désignent d'avoir un lien avec eux et
c'est par ailleurs porter leurs intérêts
et on voit bien que là là il y a une
incongruité dans ce que vous vous disiez
c'est à dire que probablement pour que
les scénars représente vraiment les
territoires il faudrait qu'il y ait des
deux dimensions et une troisième
dimension qui est la salle de votre
question c'était il faudrait qu'elle
puisse aussi faire écho à d'autres types
d'élections et c'est là où le
probablement le bât blesse c'est-à-dire
que il est probablement contestable que
alors qu'on connaît les résultats du
rassemblement national dans sa tombe de
territoires
où ils ont cisté une implantation en
tout cas des votes importants à d'autres
types d'élection le fait qu'il n'y ait
pas de vase communicants en effet pose
probablement une question de leur
représentation au niveau national allez
on vous propose un zoom sur un autre
département les Hauts-de-Seine tout de
suite on y retrouve Audrey Vedas qui est
avec Marion Gucci alors là aussi le
dépouillement est en cours beaucoup
d'incertitudes
oui et d'ailleurs les résultats mettent
beaucoup plus de temps que prévu à
arriver il devrait arriver d'ici une
minute à l'autre vous le voyez derrière
moi des paravents ont été tirés pour que
le dépouillement puisse faire dans le
calme il y a une incertitude vous le
savez à savoir si le sénateur macronisme
Xavier yakovelli conservera son siège il
a fait une campagne au long cours il est
parti en campagne en janvier son
entourage se montre confiant mais il a
handicap le modem ici dans le
département a rejoint la liste du
sénateur et du président du groupe Union
centriste Hervé Marseille incertitude
aussi chez les LR puisqu'il y a une
dissidence qui pourrait empêcher Roger
caoutchi de faire le nombre de sièges
qu'il souhaite et puis du côté de la
gauche elle est unie cette année
derrière pierre ouzulia les écologistes
et les socialistes que l'on rejoint mais
pas la France insoumise est-ce que ça
suffira à faire de siège pour l'instant
l'incertitude est toujours de mise les
résultats qui devraient tomber d'une
minute à l'autre Thomas Etam merci
beaucoup pour toutes ces informations
évidemment vous n'hésitez pas vous nous
prévenez c'est vous qui qui prenait la
main dès que des résultats
officiels tombent dans dans vos villes
respectives allez on ouvre un chapitre
focus sur sur la gauche nup ou pas nu
pendant quelques sortes Anne Levade il y
a aussi on a commencé à l'évoquer tout à
l'heure mais je voudrais vous poser la
même question il y a cet enjeu pour les
parties de gauche qui sont
représentés au Sénat de faire leurs
preuves sans la France insoumise de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon alors oui
indiscutablement à l'échelle nationale
et d'ailleurs Jean-Luc Mélenchon l'a
bien compris raison pour laquelle il a
réagi dans les termes où il l'a fait
j'ajoute que dans le cas particulier du
Sénat il y a quand même un parti qui a
un enjeu particulièrement lourd c'est
les communistes puisque pour des raisons
de répartition
géographiques là il se retrouve avec les
trois quarts de leur groupe qui est
remis au pot si j'ose dire pour pour le
renouvellement donc il y a un vrai enjeu
parce que aujourd'hui le groupe CRC donc
le groupe communiste est déjà un groupe
qui n'est pas très nombreux
[Musique]
on se souvient que à plusieurs reprises
on a même abaissé le nombre minimum mais
dans l'histoire longue si j'ose dire du
Sénat pour que les communistes puissent
continuer à avoir un groupe et là le
fait que 75 % des sénateurs du groupe
qui sont amenés à remettre leur siège en
jeu ça n'est pas négligeable évidemment
ils n'y sont pour rien là c'est la
question de la répartition des sièges
contenus du nombre d'élus communistes en
fait en région parisienne pour pour
l'essentiel et de fait cette question là
à l'échelle du groupe et donc du Parti
communiste peut aussi devenir un
argument bien sûr pour la nuque en
expliquant combien c'était un mauvais
calcul que de partir en ordre dispersé
la preuve c'est que il n'y a plus de
groupes communistes ou ils auront
beaucoup de mal à en constituer donc
parfois le les hasards si j'ose dire
font mal les choses et peuvent conduire
à ce que sa complexifie encore les
choses et puis après
le groupe socialiste lui très
légitimement peut un peu comme elle est
parce que il est j'allais dire un groupe
historiquement fort et bien implanté
escompté avoir là aussi peut-être
quelques sièges de plus ou quelques
sièges de moins un peu comme on disait
tout à l'heure pour elle on est dans la
même gamme Mathieu croissanto ces
derniers jours on a beaucoup parlé des
querelles dans la nuque entre elle et
fille le Parti communiste avec notamment
Fabien Roussel on voit là dans cette
élection qu'elle est fit a présenté des
listes dans tous les départements
qu'est-ce que ça dit de l'avenir de la
nuque à venir possible ou pas il y a
aussi la querelle des européennes
derrière qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
sur l'avenir de la nups au Sénat il y en
a pas il y en a pas
donc voilà il y a pas de prison il y a
pas de passer il y a pas de future on
sait bien que c'est pas là que ça se
passe que d'une certaine façon je disais
tout à l'heure le Sénat peut être le
laboratoire de la composition de la
droite va être d'une certaine façon le
Zéna peut être le laboratoire de la
composition de la gauche sans les
insoumis
si il était le spectateur le comprendre
en gros le Parti socialiste les écolos
et les communistes après les
législatives avaient besoin de la France
insoumise et donc ils se sont ralliés à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour sauver un
maximum de sièges possibles au Sénat
c'est une autre affaire ils ont pas
besoin des insoumis et donc ils l'ont
fait aucun cadeau aux amis de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon alors on peut juger que c'est
une mauvaise manière que font les
socialistes les communistes et les
écologistes alors camarades insoumis
c'est un rapport de force politique ils
ont avalé beaucoup de couleurs au Palais
Bourbon ici au Sénat ils entendent bien
faire entendre leur voix plus de sièges
à gagner en intégrant elle est fille
une sensibilité de gauche qui est
différente on est dans une culture de la
discussion du débat qui peut parfois
être salée poivré mais on est d'une
culture du compromis pas de la
compromission et ça n'est pas du tout
l'attitude qui a été adoptée au Palais
Bourbon ou sous l'égide de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon on sait qu'il veut tout
conflictualiser et donc tout est devenu
sujet de de basson et non plus de de
discussion ici la gauche est différente
elle ne veut pas de cette avenir là dans
la nupestre c'est-à-dire d'une gauche
inféée aux insoumis donc c'est pour ça
qu'il y a pas de cadeaux c'est pour ça
que les insoumis sont partis en solo et
on l'a dit tout à l'heure comme ils sont
pas implantés ils auront pas de grands
résultats
justement vous parler de résultats on va
aller voir Quentin Calmet pour un
nouveau point sur les résultats Quentin
notamment sur les Français de l'étranger
ou encore la Haute-Marne vous avez des
résultats à nous communiquer exactement
thème puisque pour les Français établir
de France on parle de deux à trois
millions de Français qui sont
effectivement établis en France il y
avait 6 sièges de sénateurs à pourvoir
voici les résultats officiels il y a
effectivement deux sortants qui seraient
élus réélu la socialiste ancienne
ministre de François Hollande Hélène
Conway Mouret mais également le LR Renan
Leleux la liste divers droites de
l'Alliance solidaire des Français
d'étrangers engrange deux sièges avec
Evelyne Renaud et Garabedian et Jean-Luc
Ruel enfin d'autres candidats comme
Olivia Richard qui devrait se diriger au
groupe centriste et également Mathilde
Olivier pour les écologistes feront leur
entrée au Sénat d'ailleurs à propos de
Mathilde Olivier elle a 29 ans elle
devrait siéger dans le groupe écologiste
et elle pourrait devenir la future
benjamine du Sénat un rôle protocolaire
important notamment lors de la cérémonie
de l'élection du président du Sénat on
passe à la Haute-Marne effectivement où
on voit les luth divers droites
Anne-Marie Nédélec être élu et Bruno
Sido un sénateur et LR sortant et réélu
avec près de 34 % des voix un mot pour
vous dire que les plus gros départements
devraient avoir leurs résultats dans
quelques instants nous parlent de
quelques minutes même pour le
Pas-de-Calais qui élit cette siège de
sénateur Thomas on vous retrouvera dès
que vous aurez ces résultats évidemment
Quentin on reste sur ce chapitre
consacré à la gauche et notamment à la
nuque Vincent Martigny quel sens ça de
maintenir cette organisation si elle
n'est pas capable de partir unie aux
élections là c'est les sénatoriales mais
ça va être la même chose aux européennes
alors je vais vous dire ce que je dis
souvent sur chapitre de la nuque c'est
que moi je suis plutôt à contre-pied de
ce que disent la plupart des gens sur la
nuque je pense que la nuque c'est une
alliance qui fonctionne parce qu'elle
arrange tout le monde ou plutôt la
destruction de la nuit pourrait plus
d'inconvénients que le fait de rester
dans une sorte d'incongru parfois c'est
vrai dans certains cas on a vu que là il
y a pas d'accord le LFI partent séparés
on voit bien évidemment qu'il y a des un
accord qui qui bouge c'est à dire qu'il
a été signé sous le saut des insoumis
dans un premier temps avec une
domination très forte bon bah scruter
après scrutin les autres partenaires
essaient de rééquilibrer les choses et
surtout il faut dire que vous parliez de
culture politique qui selon vous Mathieu
croissant de l'hôtelier au Sénat je
crois surtout que le profil des
sénateurs correspond beaucoup plus à
cette vieille gauche socialiste ou
sociale démocrate qui n'a aucune
sensibilité même pour les thématiques
que développent y compris les les
députés socialistes qui rejoignent la
nuque donc vous savez que le PS c'est
assez fracturé par ça on va dire ils
sont plus Carole Delga ou Bernard
Cazeneuve que que
ce sont des gens qui croient que on peut
faire revivre le socialisme un peu
certains diraient à la papa en tout cas
celui de du Parti socialiste de François
Hollande et ils ont pas cette
sensibilité là c'est pas seulement une
question là on peut pas prendre le PS et
[Musique]
force de groupe avec
Eric Kerrouche qui est sénateur
socialiste des Landes qui a été réélu au
premier tour face à Patrick Kanner qui
n'a pas fait mystère du fait que la
nuque c'était pas forcément son truc
c'est clair que on voit ces
différenciations qui s'expriment
maintenant très clairement très
clairement à gauche qui sont d'ailleurs
pas nécessairement générationnel et une
dimension un peu générationnelle quand
même les jeunes élus qui sont rentrés à
l'Assemblée nationale grâce à la
coalition de la nuque il faut rappeler
que le pilier de la Nupe c'est la
candidature unique dans les
circonscriptions ce qui fait que moi
aussi je suis assez prudent sur ceux qui
enthèrent un peu vite la nuit parce
qu'il y aura un rendez-vous qui va quand
même être les législatives de 2027 et où
là les sortants qui n'auront eu commanda
mais ils savent qu'ils doivent tout pour
une partie d'entre eux à la coalition de
la de la dupe mais effectivement on va
devoir ces éléments de de
différenciation et ces éléments de
différenciation sont liés à une profonde
divergence
sur l'Europe on l'a dit et c'est vrai
enfin là on a assisté à des noms
d'oiseaux et des accusations visant
Fabien Roussel enfin bon je vais pas
refaire toute l'histoire mais quel
est-ce que vous avez étudié ça de
l'impananouir et donc la perspective des
prochains des prochains qu'il faut pas
oublier que du côté des électeurs de la
gauche du côté des sympathisants des
parties politiques de gauche une
profonde aspiration à l'unité profonde
rappelons-nous l'épisode de la primaire
populaire Christiane Taubira donc une
profonde aspiration à l'unité et c'est
vrai qu'une image de nom d'oiseaux qui
commence à voler dans tous les sens
d'expression publique de défiance de
dénigrement à l'intérieur du du camp les
électeurs généralement sanctionnent la
division quant à atteint un point de
dysfonctionnement très important donc
d'une certaine manière pour la pour la
nuit pêche il y a effectivement une
Amora une hémorragie qui va falloir
rapidement arrêter allez on parle de la
nuque on va aller voir et bien Paris ou
la gauche et très unie d'ailleurs on va
retrouver Steve Jourdain qui se trouve à
l'hôtel de ville de Paris avec
Jean-Baptiste Gaillot où en est-on Steve
du dépouillement
beaucoup de tensions beaucoup
d'électricité ici dans cette magnifique
salle des fêtes de l'hôtel de ville de
Paris ça fait maintenant une heure que
le dépouillement a commencé le
dénouement est imminent qui seront les
12 sénateurs qui entreront ce soir au
Palais du Luxembourg est-ce que et bien
la gauche va parvenir à faire entrer un
huitième sénateur et qui en a déjà 7 et
qui part uni à ce scrutin est-ce que la
droite va parvenir à maintenir ces
quatre sièges de sénateurs de Paris elle
qui part désunit réponse dans quelques
instants ce qui est certain tame et bien
c'est que il devrait y avoir de grandes
figures du paysage médiatique qui
entreront au Palais du Luxembourg ce
soir je pense par exemple à Yannick
Jadot le candidat écologiste à la
dernière élection présidentielle ou
encore Agnès rêveren la présidente de la
Fédération LR de Paris et puis il
devrait y avoir aussi des grandes
figures de la vie politique qui
quitteront ce palais du Luxembourg je
parle évidemment encore au conditionnel
car on n'a pas encore les résultats mais
quelqu'un comme Pierre Charron le
Sarkozy de Pierre Charon encore Julien
barjoton le sénateur Renaissance
pourrait quitter ce soir et bien le
Palais du Luxembourg résultat dans
quelques minutes je vous tiens au
courant Tom merci beaucoup Steve
évidemment vous nous rappeler dès que
vous avez les résultats tiens d'ailleurs
je vous propose une image parce que là
il est un peu plus de 19 ans on va
commencer à rentrer dans la
proclamation de résultats officiels on
peut peut-être voir l'image de Nanterre
donc préfecture des Hauts-de-Seine pour
l'instant personne derrière le micro
mais si on nous envoie cette image c'est
que c'est imminent donc on va avoir des
résultats à vous proposer et évidemment
il y aura priorité à l'annonce de ces
résultats je m'excuse par avance de
devoir peut-être vous couper la parole
dans quelques minutes on parle des des
écologistes écologiques et d'ailleurs on
va aller voir tout de suite Alexandre
non loin de nous qui se trouve avec un
sénateur écologiste avec le sénateur
Thomas dossu effectivement le groupe
écologiste on avait vu et bien ça
Renaissance il y a trois ans il pourrait
encore y avoir une poussée ce coup-ci
Alexandre oui je me trouve avec Thomas
dessus bonsoir quels sont les attentes
les espoirs des écologistes dans ces
sénatoriales 2023 vous espérez encore
surfer sur vos bons résultats aux
municipales de municipales de 2020 dans
certaines grandes villes
ce qui s'est passé en 2020 c'est qu'on a
fait la démonstration d'une écologie des
territoires on s'est implanté un peu
partout en France et donc effectivement
le sénatorial sont le reflet de cette
implantation et donc on espère que le
groupe va grandir ce soir on a beaucoup
d'attentes dans les dans les résultats
qui vont arriver bientôt une petite
réaction sur la conquête d'un siège en
tout cas pour les écologistes avec
l'élection de la signatrice des Français
établis hors de France mathildevier
écologie c'était une bonne nouvelle pour
votre groupe mais oui c'est une
sénatrice qui viendra nous rejoindre une
jeune sénatrice et donc on est très
heureux de de cette de cette nouvelle
sénatrice on espère qu'elle pourra
travailler très vite avec nous et puis
c'est aussi la marque de d'implantation
des écologistes dans les élus les grands
élus en or de France donc oui c'est
important pour nous dernière question
sur le fait qu'il n'y ait pas d'alliance
de laupes dans ces sénatoriales mais des
alliances de gauche un peu à l'ancienne
entre socialiste communiste et
écologiste c'est équilibrer le rapport
de force avec les insoumis à gauche non
franchement faut pas le voir comme ça je
pense que c'est aussi le reflet de cette
sélection qui est très particulière qui
vient des territoires et sur le
territoire on n'a pas pu trouver un
endroit où on aurait pu faire cet accord
et donc on peut le regretter mais il
faut pas en faire la fin de la nupesse
ou quelque chose ça ne mérite pas en
tout cas toutes les noms d'oiseaux qui
sont échanger durant cette campagne sur
cette question là merci beaucoup Thomas
dessus merci Alexandre à très vite
évidemment pour d'autres réactions
politiques à votre micro Mathieu
croissanto donc on ouvre un focus sur
sur Europe Écologie Les Verts c'est
l'une des familles politiques qui peut
raisonnablement espérer voir son nombre
de sièges progressés au Sénat oui parce
que c'est une famille politique qui a
progressé aux dernières municipales
alors après il y a eu tout un nombre de
villes on a en mémoire les grandes
villes qui sont des gens mais gérées par
des maires écologistes qui sont pas
concernés forcément par le
renouvellement du scrutin si vous prenez
Bordeaux si vous prenez Strasbourg si
vous prenez Lyon voilà ce sont pas sont
pas des des municipalités enfin des
départements qui sont qui sont concernés
mais oui de toute façon on sait que il y
a une implantation locale des
écologistes ça a pris du temps beaucoup
de temps c'était d'abord dans les
centres urbain et ça reste encore dans
les grandes métropoles mais petit à
petit le parti écologiste s'implante
après on a d'ailleurs une couleur là
aussi une sensibilité différente entre
ces élus de terrain écologistes et puis
le groupe écologiste qu'on peut voir à
l'Assemblée nationale ici au Sénat ils
sont plus proches des élitesens entre
guillemets dans la tonalité que ce qu'on
a au Palais Bourbon ou le bourbon on a
des écologistes qui ont enchaîne des
thématiques très sociétales parfois
complètement
décalé de leur terrain traditionnelle de
l'écologie mais qui sont pas du tout sur
la même ligne que ceux que ceux ici donc
c'est assez drôle oui c'est vrai que ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure Vincent
Martini ça n'est pas lié au fait que ce
soit le Sénat et le Palais Bourbon mais
on a dans chaque famille politique des
sensibilités quand même très différentes
on peut lire entre ce qui se passe ici
et ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée
nationale alors ça compte on vient de se
donner l'info peut être de l'information
depuis Xéna ça recompte dans les
Hauts-de-Seine ça se joue à deux voies
après donc donc vous imaginez l'étape
tension dans lesquelles peuvent être les
les sénateurs sortants ou ceux qui se
présentent
on parlait à l'instant du fait que il
pouvait y avoir des gains de sièges
écologistes notamment les Français de
l'étranger on l'a entendu il y a les
Yvelines il y a aussi bien sûr Paris où
il y a quand même une personnalité qui
est très attendue c'est celle de Yannick
Jadot l'ex-candidat malheureux à la
présidentielle qui pourrait donc rentrer
au Sénat ça serait une nouvelle
médiatique et puis pour le groupe
écologiste oui c'est clair d'abord parce
que c'est une personnalité politique et
très identifiée grâce à son parcours
politique et aussi la présidentielle de
2022 malgré un résultat très décevant
moins de 5% des votes de votre exprimé
et c'est vrai que pour Yannick Jadot qui
a eu un gros passage à vide derrière
cette présidentielle tellement décevante
pour lui pour rejoindre ce que disait
Mathieu croissant de tout à l'heure sans
doute qu'il a plus sa place dans ce
qu'il représente sur les bancs du Sénat
à l'Assemblée nationale où on aurait
attendu de lui qu'il est leadership de
la parole extrêmement puissant
extrêmement fort donc de ce point de là
c'est vrai que c'est c'est intéressant
certains observateurs de la vie
politique disent que le territoire
parisien pourrait nourrir celui d'autres
ambitions un jour on ne sait pas voilà
lui parler de son ambition ça ne serait
pas peut-être un message optimal du
point de vue de du point de vue de tu
peux du rôle des élus de la crédibilité
de la parole des de la parole des élus
mais oui il y a une nouvelle politique
de la soirée peut-être peut-être très
peut-être très importante et d'autant
plus que la la Gauche à Paris est plutôt
en phase on va dire avec le type de de
gauche dans lequel Yannick jados se sent
bien Vincent Martini vous nous parliez
tout à l'heure de la
personnification ou l'incarnation là on
a quand même une figure politique
qui va selon toute vraisemblance devrait
pas y avoir de grandes surprises
intégrer le Sénat est-ce que c'est quand
même une bonne nouvelle aussi de grandes
figures politiques même si j'ai bien
entendu vos arguments tout à l'heure je
sais pas si c'est une bonne nouvelle ça
c'est je peux pas vraiment juger mais la
relation des Français avec avec
l'Institut du précédent parce que les
personnalités politiques lorsqu'elles
sont très fortes elles ont évidemment un
effet où elle draine la tension sur une
institution c'est une bonne chose mais
aussi elle faut qu'elle se fonde dans
une façon de faire qui est celle de la
logique parlementaire du Sénat qui est
un peu comme je le disais tout à l'heure
un peu l'inverse de ça donc tout va
dépendre de quel type de sénateur sera
notre nouvelle élu s'il est un sénateur
qui travaille et qui fait du collectif
etc ça peut être positivement pour son
groupe pour la gauche au Sénat et pour
le Sénat en tant que lui-même mais toute
la va dépendre encore une fois de
comment il va jouer sa partition et
encore une fois c'est un équilibre assez
fin qui n'est pas du tout le même et
donc Yannick Jadot il a pas forcément
l'habitude du Sénat et on va voir un peu
comment tout ça fonctionne en tout cas
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que la façon de
fonctionner par rapport à l'incarnation
qu'on retrouve au Sénat et beaucoup plus
en ligne avec ce que écologie et vert
défend Europe Écologie Les Verts est
très mal à l'aise avec la
personnalisation du pouvoir
l'incarnation la Cinquième République à
ce titre-là Yannick Jadot qui était sur
une île d'ailleurs qui était pas celle
de la majorité d'Europe Écologie verte
c'est un peu là le paradoxe c'est celui
qui croyait le 20 KFC le plus de défend
l'idée d'une incarnation au sein de sa
famille politique qui se retrouve dans
l'instant ce qui est le plus en ligne
avec le reste de son parti enfin voilà
en tout cas il y a ici là je crois des
raisons d'espérer pour le groupe
écologiste qui pourra avoir une
personnalité forte en son sein qui
attirera l'attention sur lui encore
quelques petites informations
pouvoir apprendre conditionnel on
apprend que dans l'Oise le sénateur
sortant sénateur LR Jérôme Bacher serait
battu au profit d'un autre sortant
Olivier Pacaud qui également rattaché au
groupe et qui ferait lui deux sièges
bien sûr à confirmer tout à l'heure avec
Quentin on parlait du groupe écologiste
Mathieu croissanto à l'instant
l'une des choses à laquelle on va
s'intéresser aussi c'est la place de LV
dans ce groupe écologiste parce
qu'aujourd'hui et bien notamment le
président du groupe n'est pas membre de
LV ça a été important pour ce groupe de
dire qu'ils avaient un président qui
était indépendant du groupe on va aussi
prêter attention à ses équilibres là oui
alors là on rentre dans la cuisine
interne j'allais dire des écologistes
mais c'est vrai que c'est important
c'est vrai que c'est important parce que
on l'a dit aussi au Sénat on a des
groupes composites qui ne reflètent pas
forcément les les parties politiques
nationaux donc pour ça qu'il y a pas non
plus de culture de vote sur le doigt de
la couture du pantalon il y a pas de
discipline de vote à pulser par les
centres des partis c'est le cas pour ce
groupe écologiste qui a souvent eu des
personnalités particulières assez forte
d'ailleurs mais qui n'était pas
forcément affilié aux parties est-ce que
ça sera l'occasion pour élever de
prendre le lead sur sur ce groupe
écologiste on va bien voir mais c'est
sûr que de toute façon avec une
personnalité comme comme Yannick Jadot
on va voir une autre voix de l'écologie
qui va s'exprimer
en tout cas ça on va avoir quand même
parce que c'est une caisse de résonance
on va avoir une autre voie de l'écologie
aujourd'hui on a une écologie qui est
portée à l'Assemblée nationale par des
députés très médiatiques parfois
minoritaires selon la dit sur dans sur
certains sur certaines thématiques dans
leur propre partie je pense à Sandrine
Rousseau qu'on entend très fort là on va
avoir d'une certaine façon peut-être
voir ce profiler le notre round du match
Jadot Rousseau à travers ce que ce que
l'ancien député européen pourra exprimer
depuis les travées du Palais du
Luxembourg on fera à 21h à un débat à
100% politique avec des président de
groupe président et présidente de groupe
Bruno taillot lien assassy Claude
malloret Marseille ce rôle là qu'est-ce
qui se joue autour de la présidence d'un
groupe Kate quel prérogative quelle
influence qu'est-ce que pourquoi c'est
important Anne Levade alors c'est
important dans le jeu institutionnel
parce que
la présidence de groupe est au-delà de
l'Incarnation est une fonction qui fait
participer à un certain nombre
d'instances internes au Sénat c'est
d'ailleurs la même chose à l'Assemblée
nationale je pense par exemple à la
Conférence des présidents qui réunit
entre autres les présidents de groupe et
les présidents de commission et qui
arrête l'ordre du jour et puis les
présidents de groupe ont aussi justement
la possibilité de demander la création
d'une commission d'enquête bref ils ont
vraiment un rôle moteur et ce roule
moteur
il va à l'échelle de leur groupe et même
si au Sénat la discipline est moins
importante ou moins resserré on va dire
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale il va
nécessairement ent une forme d'image de
l'ensemble du groupe c'est à dire que
selon que le président du groupe se
positionne comme résolument d'opposition
résolument en alliance etc forcément ça
donne le sentiment parce que chaque
parlementaire n'est pas adapté à
s'exprimer en tant que tel ça donne le
sentiment que il y a une ligne du groupe
elle est tout de suite c'est bien on va
retrouver Quentin Calmet qui se trouve
dans le studio quelques mettre en
dessous de nous pour faire un point à
part car Quentin vous avez de nouveau
résultat voilà j'ai des résultats pour
deux départements on va commencer avec
celui du Lot puisque on savait que le
maire PS de Cahors Jean-Marie vaissouze
fort était élu au premier tour on a le
nom de la deuxième personne qui était
élu il s'agit du candidat radical de
gauche Raphaël daubet qui a gagné ça
signifie que la sénatrice socialiste
sortante en gel previl et battu dans ce
département on continue juste à côté le
département voisin du Lot-et-Garonne à
Agen ou la sénatrice Christine
bonfantidos on arrive en tête avec 48%
des votants d'un scrutin qui a été très
serré il a fallu les deux tours de
l'élection pour départager les candidats
LCG au groupe LR elle est donc réélu le
deuxième candidat illus s'appelle Michel
Masset il est candidat divers gauche
donc qui est dû dans ce département on
termine avec deux informations qui nous
ont été données par le groupe socialiste
du Sénat le sénateur rachidt mal serait
réélu dans le Val-d'Oise ainsi que
Jean-Claude Tissot dans les départements
de la Loire on attend maintenant un
patiemment les résultats à Nanterre il
devrait arriver d'un instant à l'autre
Thomas et merci beaucoup Quentin
manifestement sa recompte alors on est
toujours pressé nous journalistes et
observateurs Vincent Martini mais
combien de temps il faudra pour prendre
la mesure de des nouveaux équilibres ici
au Sénat
vous l'ayez en termes de répartition des
groupes politiques parce qu'on parlait
des 50 nuances de bleu au sein de la
majorité sénatoriales on disait que le
choix du président de groupe chez
écologiste là aussi sera un indicateur
vous voyez ce que je veux dire déjà les
présidents de groupe ça va donner un peu
une éducation la couleur de chaque
groupe et puis aussi à tous ces divers
gauche et diverses droites qui vont
devoir se positionner par rapport à
l'ensemble des groupes parce qu'il y a
des gens qui trouvent pas forcément leur
place lorsqu'ils sont le produit
d'équilibre locaux il se trouve pas
forcément leur place dans les parties
nationaux et donc ils sont pas forcément
chez les non inscrits on a une partie
qui va rejoindre le clan des non
inscrits mais une partie va se
rapprocher un peu de chaque famille
politique et on sait qu'au Sénat il y en
a un certain nombre donc il faut il y
aura cette dimension là puis il y aura
là la réélection du président du Sénat
tout ça ça va être important même si
encore une fois il y a pas 30 suspense
sur la personnalité du futur vainqueur
et pour autant c'est des occasions aussi
que les sénateurs ont de se parler et on
se positionne quand on arrive dans une
assemblée surtout lorsqu'on est primo
élu la première fois qu'on est élu bah
il faut se faire à une culture
parlementaire il faut se faire un groupe
de gens à qui vous êtes il faut se faire
aussi à ce que vous n'aimez pas ou ceux
à qui vous n'avez pas l'intention de
siéger et tout ça prend un certain temps
je prends quelques semaines probablement
déjà on aura un peu une indication de
quelle couleur pendant le Sénat et oui
Bruno cotress on avait eu un parfois des
surprises sur les couleurs politiques
prenaient certains élus on prend le cas
par exemple de Jean-Marie vandlerenberg
qui lorsqu'il a été candidat il y a six
ans était tête de liste Renaissance et
qui est qui est un qui est modem et qui
est reparti siégé au groupe Union
centriste qui est même allé jusqu'à
s'abstenir sur la réforme des retraites
c'est là qu'on voit à quel point ça peut
être plus nuancé plus complexe sans
doute notamment par rapport à
l'Assemblée
oui bien évidemment et on retrouve ce
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure qui est à
la fois toute cette toute cette richesse
et parfois un petit peu toute cette
ambiguïté de ce qui se passe au centre
au Sénat dans l'ensemble de notre vie
politique en ce moment vous étiez le cas
du Doyen d'ailleurs du Sénat sénateur
qui est modem représente qui se
représente voilà et qui
et qui au fond illustre bien illustre
très très bien cette cette problématique
de ce qui se passe de ce qui se passe au
centre et de toute la dynamique et du
fonctionnement du Sénat ou l'équation
personnelle les sensibilités
personnelles peuvent venir contredire ou
contrecarrer la logique partisane et des
tickets donc c'est ça qui fait la
richesse aussi de la vie de la vie du
Sénat et pour rejoindre la question qui
était qui était posée par Thomas aussi
en complément de la de la voix je trouve
que l'épreuve du feu ça va être quand
même les grands textes et comment les
différents groupes et les différentes
personnalités sensibilité à l'intérieur
des groupes vont se positionner sur des
textes un petit peu de de vérité il va y
avoir la question de l'immigration mais
il y aura le texte de la loi de finance
bien évidemment on se rappelle quand
même que l'an dernier la loi de finances
a été adoptée aux 49-3 finalement et
pour Emmanuel Macron pour la majorité
pour la vie la vie démocratique le débat
le débat public c'est là un point très
très important est-ce qu'on budget c'est
quand même le moment où l'on compte
c'est le grand moment de vérité voilà
c'est le grand moment de vérité on a
l'habitude de dire c'est au moment du
vote du budget qu'on sait qui
appartiendrait à la majorité qui est
dans l'opposition et donc là ça va être
la grande épreuve de vérité de voir ces
nouveaux élus et ce nouveau Sénat
comment il va se positionner sur cette
question question encore une fois tout à
fait essentielle parce qu'il n'est pas
banal dans une grande démocratie
européenne de voir la loi suprême la loi
de finances adoptée avec des mécanismes
de parlementarisme rationalisé plutôt
qu'à l'issue d'un débat avec des votes
ça paraît quand même très difficile ou
quasiment impossible que
un projet de loi de finance puisse être
adopté par le Sénat dans la
configuration qu'on imagine avec la
droite et le centre majoritaire on l'a
dit c'est un moment où on se compte
je sais pas si c'est plus difficile que
ce soit adopté au Sénat ou à l'Assemblée
dans la dans la situation actuelle parce
que le 49-3 le 49-3 voilà c'est pour
l'assemblée oui et en même temps il peut
y avoir aussi des arbitrages sur sur
certaines parties du texte
donc je pense que pour le pour le Sénat
évidemment ça va être un moment
important mais ça peut être le moment où
le Sénat peut essayer de faire peser
dans la balance certains arguments pour
justement
voir participer à la construction d'une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale qui
permettrait de ne pas recourir aux 49-3
Mathieu croissanto cette question elle
se posera aussi pour Gérard Larcher donc
comment il va se positionner lui qui
avait été cité parmi les les premiers
ministres possibles potentiels pendant
quelques semaines son attitude
en disant pour l'instant pour le moment
enfin voilà il avait à la fois
un peu un peu ses amis euh oui Gérard
Larcher il va avoir un rôle essentiel à
jouer on le sait le le président du
Sénat à partir du moment où il n'y a pas
de majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
devient un interlocuteur des facto pour
le président de la République qui en
faisait peu d'écart au début de son
mandat et Emmanuel Macron pour lui le
Sénas n'était pas forcément grand-chose
il avait pas une relation particulière
avec Gérard Larcher
avec les deux hommes c'était opposés et
une volonté de transformation du Sénat
qui avait été évoqué par Emmanuel Macron
après le mouvement des gilets jaunes qui
avait beaucoup péchéité ici au Palais du
Luxembourg ou comme ça sans en parler on
propose de transformer le Sénat le
dernier qui s'est essayé on se rappelle
que ça ne lui a pas réussi pour parler
du général de Gaulle évidemment donc oui
j'aurais un archer va avoir un rôle
idéal après pour lui parce que à la fois
en grand-mamanoutchi de la droite parce
que on a dit que c'est la droite va se
recomposer ici et puis comme
interlocuteur singulier pour pour
l'exécutif parce que j'ai relâché plutôt
un homme qui a l'habitude du dialogue et
l'habitude de passer des accords quand
ils s'engage il s'engage après sur la
question du budget moi je n'y crois pas
une seule seconde le budget c'est la
seule occasion ou l'opposition pour
raser gratis donc elle va y aller
elle va pas se priver alors que dans la
majorité on est obligé d'assumer des
choix quelque soit la couleur cette
majorité donc 49-3 obligatoire Bruno
quoi Bruno coquelet il faut plusieurs
hypothèse plus plausible et encore une
fois elle va susciter bien évidemment
beaucoup de beaucoup de débats beaucoup
d'interrogations il y a beaucoup de
politiques qui vont monter au créneau
qui vont souligner
le problème du fonctionnement de notre
système politique on se rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui dans l'opinion le recours
à l'article 49.3 est très très
négativement perçu c'est perçu comme et
bien quelque chose qui ne respecte pas
le principe de base démocratique qui est
que un débat ait lieu qui en con ce
compte à la fin en votant et c'est vrai
que ça va sans aucun doute être à
nouveau une épreuve pas évidente pour
les pour l'exécutif parce que ça
contredit d'une certaine manière le
message porté par Elisabeth borne qui
est le message du dialogue de la
concertation de la recherche des
majorités de projets à géométrie à
géométrie variable et là en si ça devait
être utilisé bien évidemment ça tord un
petit peu le bras ce principe d'autant
qu'on dit un 49,3 mais en fait il y en a
plus d'une dizaine voter pour le volet
recette puis le volet dépenses
avec un avec un effet assez délétère
dans l'opinion publique Vincent Martini
juste petite info avant que vous nous
répondiez à cette à cette question ça
recompte dans les Hauts-de-Seine ça
raconte aussi en Moselle où c'est très
très serré on sera en direct pour vous
donner les résultats dès qu'il dès qu'il
tombe l'effet de de l'usage du 49 c'est
un outil de gouvernement
c'est c'est devenu l'espèce de de de
diable dans l'opinion publique est-ce
que est-ce que c'est un danger pour le
fonctionnement normal d'une démocratie
que ce que le 49 soit à ce point associé
à une perception négative non je pense
que c'est un effet de surprise qui est
pour moi un effet de la transformation
de la notion de consentement
démocratique c'est-à-dire que sa
disposition qui était une des
dispositions du parlementarisme
rationalisé on se souvient que Michel
Rocard évidemment elle avait utilisé à
très nombreuses reprises sans que
vraiment ça phase de scandale je pense
que pour les nouvelles générations qui
sont très sensibles à la question du
consentement et consentement y compris
dans la vie des mœurs en fait elle
projette dans la sphère politique et
ainsi qu'une grande partie des Français
l'idée d'un forçage démocratique une
certaine manière on vous force à faire
quelque chose que vous n'avez pas envie
de faire sans discussion et dans une
période où on est quand même dans des
changements anthropologiques profonds ça
ne peut pas ne pas avoir de conséquences
me semble-t-il sur la vie politique et
je veux pas donner une importance trop
importante sur ce que ça signifie mais
je crois encore une fois que la
transformation la notion de 49-3 elle
est l'objet ou le produit d'une
transformation générale du regard sur la
décision le consentement politique mais
est-ce que c'était quand même passé
beaucoup plus facilement lors de
l'automne budgétaire l'an dernier où
vous avez une forme d'habitude avec ce
49,3 que et bien ce qui s'est passé avec
les réformes de retraite c'est peut-être
aussi à l'aune de cette réforme de la
façon dont ça s'est passé que maintenant
et bien le 49-3 est davantage synonyme
et bien de violence certainement de la
part du gouvernement
déjà il y a 10 ans en 2013 en 2000
pardon j'exagère en 2016 avec l'époque
de la loi el khomri c'est déjà un
déchirure mais c'est vrai qu'à chaque
fois que vous avez une crise politique
bah ça renforce ce sentiment là lorsque
vous avez trois quarts de l'opinion qui
dit on veut pas une réforme et qu'on la
fais passer d'une par une disposition du
parlementarisme rationalisé et ben vous
tenez le sentiment forcément d'un
forçage démocratique et à ce titre là
vous avez raison ça le met en lumière de
manière particulière je vous donne la
parole là-dessus tout de suite le van
mes priorités aux résultats on est avec
Quentin calmer les tous derniers
résultats en votre possession Quentin et
voilà j'ai deux nouveaux départements
dont je peux vous donner les résultats
il s'agit pour commencer des
Pyrénées-Orientales pas de changement
dans les équilibres politiques le
sortant j'en sol pour les et réélu le
deuxième siège et choix à Lauriane
jossande qui va remplacer le LR françois
Calvet et donc ça signifie qu'il n'y a
pas d'élus du rassemblement national
lance département où l'on pouvait penser
que ce parti avait une chance de
l'emporter puisqu'il y a la mairie de
Perpignan dans ce département mais donc
ce sont deux élus LR qui sont élus ce
soir on continue avec l'Orne en
Normandie la sénatrice centriste
Nathalie Goulet avait été élu dès le
premier tour ça on l'avait déjà dit et
bien on a le nom pour le deuxième siège
et c'est une surprise c'est un élu
horizon qui remporte au second siège il
s'appelle Olivier Blitz et donc il
remplace un LR puisqu'il il bat le LR
Vincent Ségouin c'est donc là par
exemple dans ce genre de cas que on voit
de léger changements et qui vont
s'effectuer à la chambre haute du
Parlement une dernière information qui
nous a été donnée par le groupe
socialiste du Sénat puisque la sénatrice
Frédéric Espana serait réélu dans les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques voilà pour ce que
je peux vous dire alors on se parle Tam
merci merci beaucoup Quentin pour toutes
ces informations et puis une autre
information à prendre attention aux
conditionnel ce n'est pas encore
officiel il y aurait et bien un premier
élu RN qui serait élu dans le
département du Nord c'est Joshua
Hauchard qui espérait effectivement
faire un siège grâce à l'éparpillement
des listes dans ce département et donc
notamment le centriste le sénateur
sortant Olivier Hainaut ferait les frais
et également on nous dit que Frédéric
marchand sénateur Renaissance qui était
en mauvaise posture ne serait également
pas élu
évidemment dans quelques minutes
à Lille dans quelques minutes genre
Larcher a parlé de jusqu'à 5 ou 10
sénateurs les projections on parle d'un
petit peu moins mais ça serait quand
même un véritable coup de tonnerre à
l'échelle du Sénat un tel score du RN
selon vous annelevan ce serait
d'une part inédit et d'autre part
effectivement le témoignage de ce que
l'ancrage local et donc l'implantation
du du parti
se confirme alors coup de tonnerre je ne
sais pas parce que compte tenu des
résultats à l'Assemblée nationale j'ai
le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui
certains pourraient considérer que il y
a même une logique à ce que au sein de
l'autre chambre et dans une proportion
moins de contenu du mode de scrutin il y
est quelques élus qui soient
rassemblement national donc
tonnerre je ne pense pas si on reste en
dessous de 10 en plus il y a pas de
groupe c'est certainement ça qui sera à
regarder bien sûr l'arrivée d'un groupe
rassemblement national voudrait dire
tout autre chose complètement probable
en termes bien sûr alors on a des images
à Paris en direct et on vous donnera
évidemment des résultats avec Steve
Jourdain dès que dès que ce sera
possible
donc l'Agence France Presse nous annonce
que le début
dans le Nord
dans le Pas-de-Calais dans le
Pas-de-Calais alors c'est dans le
Pas-de-Calais effectivement où ça serait
donc monsieur Zurich qui ferait son
arrivée au Sénat donc un nouveau
sénateur rassemblement national où il y
avait effectivement également un
éparpillement des listes dans le
Pas-de-Calais rassemblement national
officiel Anne Leval j'avais promis de
vous faire réagir quand même sur les
yeux j'ai pas oublié je suis un peu têtu
vous vouliez prendre la parole sur ce
sur ce thème alors j'entends bien
l'argument anthropologique que
qu'évoquait Vincent Martini sur ce qui
pourrait permettre de comprendre qui
aujourd'hui un tel rejet du 49.3 je
pense aussi que ce qui a
considérablement changé c'est que on a
vécu une période pendant laquelle les
politiques ont eux-mêmes en quelque
sorte déconsidérer le 49-3 je rappelle
que on a eu d'abord par exemple Lionel
Jospin Premier ministre disant moi
jamais je ne recourrais au 49-3
évidemment j'en ai pas besoin donc dans
cette période de cohabitation qui était
évidemment une période un peu
particulière et où il a en quelque sorte
laissait entendre que c'était un aveu de
faiblesse que de recourir au 49-3 quand
ensuite Nicolas Sarkozy devient
président de la République et François
Fillon Premier ministre le même message
est passé je lis les noms des deux
puisque en réalité c'est souvent Nicolas
Sarkozy qui dit je n'ai jamais utilisé
le 49-3 mais bon je passais mais de fait
pendant 5 ans on explique que quand on a
une majorité soudée on en a pas besoin
et donc quand effectivement sous
François Hollande a plusieurs reprises
ont recours aux 49-3 dans un contexte ou
qui plus est il y a des frondeurs à
l'Assemblée nationale au sein du groupe
socialiste c'est tout de suite présenter
par leurs adversaires politiques comme
étant un aveu de faiblesse donc
aujourd'hui il y a vraiment cette idée
que c'est à la fois quand on est faible
ce qui n'est pas forcément ce qui avait
imaginé les auteurs de la Constitution
de 1958 parce qu'en fait c'est un outil
d'accélération de la procédure et pas
justement quand il faut forcément
démontrer que on a on n'a pas
suffisamment de voix et la deuxième la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on a oublié
qu'en période de majorité relative on
pouvait en avoir besoin la preuve en est
d'ailleurs que Nicolas Sarkozy au moment
de la révision constitutionnelle de 2008
avait même envisagé de purement et
simplement supprimer le 49-3 ce que je
rappelle qu'à l'époque de Michel Rocard
il y avait aucune limitation dans son
usage raison pour laquelle il a été
beaucoup utilisé à ce moment de majorité
relative et qu'ensuite en 2008 on décide
de le restreindre loi de finances loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et un
texte par cession par cession voulant
dire ordinaire ou extraordinaire ce qui
ouvre quelques perspectives numériques
supplémentaires
quelques informations alors peut-être
concernant Paris on a vu une image de
d'élus de gauche souriant tout à l'heure
alors c'est pas encore officiel il y
aurait 8 sièges pour la gauche et a
priori a priori je mets beaucoup de
conditionnel Pierre Charron serait
battu Mathieu croissanto bon il y a une
leçon qui est vieille comme les
élections qui est de la leçon de la
division qui soit qui en général ne mène
pas la victoire l'union fait la force et
que la division oui ça paye pas dans les
yeux non oui c'est vrai et on le voit
bien c'est pas possible trois listes de
droite à Paris c'est même assez
incompréhensible quand on voit le combat
politique qui se mène à Paris au Conseil
de Paris on peut les suivre et qu'on
voit la virulence avec laquelle
l'opposition cette fustige la gauche qui
soit pas fichu de se mettre d'accord
pour pour mener le combat des
sénatoriales Jordan les résultats à un
instant car effectivement à gauche il y
aurait huit sièges donc les 8 premier
candidat serait élu jusqu'à Anne Souiris
la sénatrice qui serait donc élus
signatrice écologiste et au niveau de la
droite la liste de Catherine durma
serait trois sièges et la liste d'Agnès
evraine qui était en dissidente ferait
elle un siège à la députée européenne LR
soutenue par Philippe Goujon serait elle
aussi ferait elle aussi son arrivée au
Palais du Luxembourg je vous laisse
continuer Mathieu quand on se présente à
trois listes différentes pour pour une
élection c'est sûr que voilà ce qui
arrive et je disais c'est vraiment
surprenant parce que la droite a envie
de récupérer Paris et c'est que
sociologiquement c'est très compliqué
elle cherche son candidat à chaque
élection en essayant de tourner tourner
un peu autour de la de la bonne formule
et la manifestement il n'y a pas
d'autorité à droite en tout cas chez LR
à Paris il y a pas de quelqu'un qui est
capable de faire régner une forme
d'autorité pour mener le combat des
sénatoriales évidemment mais des
municipales Antoine
si on croise que vous êtes en train de
dire ça que la gauche gagne du huit
sièges de Julien Bargeton
encore reconditionnel
de la représentativité des grands partis
et a commencé par la majorité
présidentielle en les territoires alors
vous pouvez comprendre éventuellement
que Renaissance soit pas très populaire
dans dans en Moselle en revanche je
crois que c'est plus inquiétant pour
l'avenir de ce parti de savoir qu'à
Paris qui a priori son territoire
d'élection en tout cas vous pouvez bien
en 2016 évidemment et puis surtout vous
avez la population qui représente
l'électorative du parti d'Emmanuel
Macron c'était un électorat plutôt
j'allais dire plutôt de classe moyenne
supérieure plutôt éduqué vivant dans une
grande ville et bien là vous avez une
déconnexion totale puisque il y a aucun
sénateur qui est désigné alors c'est le
produit évidemment déséquilibre optique
Charron qui pouvait aussi être considéré
comme un candidat qui favorisé en tout
cas avec l'Elysée là vous avez vraiment
d'accord on peut le prendre avec des
pincettes parce que il y a une partie de
ce résultat qui est due à l'organisation
politique locale qui ne représente pas
forcément totalement la population pour
faire ça c'est quand même inquiétant je
crois pour la majorité il y a quand même
des délégués municipaux qui eux n'ont
peuvent avoir une vraie liberté toi et à
Paris ils sont nombreux donc les
délégués du conseil donc c'est là que
Bruno cotresse à Paris mais pas
seulement est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
parce que on est dans un scrutin
indirect on le rappelle mais ce qui peut
quand même y avoir un effet réforme des
retraites dans le le rejet d'un certain
nombre de candidats de la majorités
extrêmement intéressante qui a été faite
il y a quelques jours par le président
de l'association des mers ruraux de
France qui disait que ce qui lui
revenait c'est que les délégués des
conseils municipaux notamment des
petites villes et des communes de taille
moyenne on va dire ressentez une sorte
de déconnexion entre les candidats qui
venaient faire campagne vis-à-vis de en
particulier des candidats de la majorité
est-ce que eux ressentaient sur le
terrain qui sont directement en prise
avec le sentiment de deux mondes qui
n'ont pratiquement plus rien à dire
ensemble et donc effectivement c'est
vrai que toute la séquence que nous
avons vécu
retraite mais même avant l'ensemble des
crises qui ont jalonné
les mandats d'Emmanuel Macron ont pu
créer effectivement le sentiment
que le parti présidentiel est un peu
déconnecté et n'oublions pas aussi
Antoine de fond que les élus les
délégués de conseil municipaux et puis
les futurs sénateurs ce sont aussi des
animaux politiques stratèges ils savent
ils savent les électeurs et puis ils
savent qu'Emmanuel Macron
il sera plus là ne sera plus là donc
l'idée de tout devoir au parti
dans la cheville ouvrière le pilier le
créateur Emmanuel Macron va disparaître
de la vie politique peut-être que déjà
ça commence ça commence à percoler ça
commence à infuser dans les têtes autre
exemple qui montre que la macronie est
en difficulté sur ce scrutin d'autres
résultats à prendre conditionnel ceux du
Pas-de-Calais ou l'ancienne ministre
Brigitte bourguignon qui était deuxième
de liste derrière Jean-Marie vanloenberg
qui avait déjà été défaite lors des
élections législatives l'année dernière
ne parviendrait pas non plus à être
élu ça montre une fois de plus ça ne va
effectivement mais la difficulté de
Renaissance on l'a vu à Paris et on le
voit aussi dans le Pas-de-Calais malgré
une étiquette d'anciennes ministres
comme Brigitte bourguignon
oui alors je
pense aussi parfois que l'étiquette
d'ancienne ministre dans la
configuration actuelle ça peut être en
quelque sorte justement plutôt un effet
repoussoir qu'un effet un effet
incitatif
ce qui est vrai aussi c'est que ça n'est
pas parce que on a été ministre qu'on
est forcément identifié justement comme
étant proche des préoccupations des
territoires donc pour les élections
sénatoriales il peut y avoir une petite
ambiguïté si par ailleurs on n'est pas
soi-même une personnalité j'allais dire
ancrée localement donc dates sur la
personnalité l'impopularité d'Emmanuel
Macron parce que finalement c'est aussi
autour de cette question que que l'on
débat à ce moment de notre soirée
sénatoriale
est-ce qu'il est beaucoup plus
impopulaire que ces prédécesseurs ou
est-ce que cette popularité et d'autres
d'autres à d'autres leviers extrêmement
clivant mais je pense que Bruno en
parlerait mieux que moi on a eu un
président qui était extrêmement client
qui était Nicolas Sarkozy son mandat
parce que on était sur un clivage assez
classique au fond des gens de droite qui
a des réaction discours et qui le
soutenaient et puis des gens de gauche
qui pouvaient pas le voir en peinture et
qui arrivait à des niveaux de
détestation assez élevés on a vu avec
François là on a notre phénomène de de
détachement de il était il était moins
clivant mais les gens ne le voyaient pas
forcément habiter le rôle de président
de la République il était parfois
méprisé ce qui est j'ai injuste ou à
raison mais en tout cas il était il
était un peu méprisé Emmanuel Macron lui
est très clivé sur des sur des clivages
qui ne sont plus les clivages politiques
traditionnels puisque on ne sait pas un
président de droite par président de
gauche au sens d'étiquettes politiques
et on le voit dans certaines catégories
de population avec un niveau de rejet
extrêmement élevé et son soutien on l'a
vu en tout cas électoralement mais Bruno
je vais lui laisser parole on l'a vu en
et c'est la même surpris Emmanuel Macron
lui-même au moment de sa réélection en
2022 de dire est-ce que je suis le le
président des riches des retraités et
des et des centres-villes aisés
Emmanuel Macron à
terme équivalent c'est-à-dire les
présidents qui ont fait un deuxième
mandat François Mitterrand poste 1988
Jacques Chirac post 2002 dès le début on
voit que les anciens présidents mi-temps
echirera qui étaient beaucoup plus
populaires en début de mandat
qu'Emmanuel Macron de l'ordre de 15 à 20
points de popularité supplémentaires on
voit qu'après ça ça s'effiloche ça
s'effiloche Emmanuel Macron est parti de
bas dès le début de son deuxième mandat
il a une grande dégringolade dans
l'opinion au moment de la réforme des
retraites il est arrivé à limiter la
casse au fond en annonçant beaucoup de
choses au lendemain de la réforme des
retraites en un plan à un nouveau
dialogue social il est un peu limité à
laquelle il la dégringolade mais depuis
c'est un petit peu en dents de scie et
globalement on peut dire qu'il a une
popularité aujourd'hui qui est en ne
tiède danse froide voilà c'est ce que je
dirais après effectivement le contenu de
cette un peu popularité est
incroyablement clivé et depuis très vite
ça s'est joué très vite dès le début du
1er mandat d'Emmanuel Macron l'image est
une image incroyablement clivée qui
oppose deux tiers 1/3 on va dire
globalement on fait la messe tout de
suite proclamation des résultats
je vous donnerai ensuite
la répartition
donc prenons le parti de la noisette 330
voix
c'est vraiment la démocratie en direct
on voit on voit que les résultats sont
en train d'arriver il y a une petite
hésitation la prise de parole ne saurait
tarder je pense que ça y est les infos
sont claires on y va
287 voies
engagés pour la Moselle
Monsieur Laurent Muller
142 voix
majorité c'est latoriale on va
synthétiser les résultats
on reprend la main parce que c'est pas
tout à fait clair on n'entend pas bien
on comprend pas bien même pour les plus
initiés donc on va synthétiser ces
résultats de la Moselle et vous les
donnez calmement tranquillement et avec
certitude dans quelques instants dans
quelques minutes
Macron la popularité d'Emmanuel Macron
aussi dans les territoires mais j'allais
dire c'est pas forcément nouveau pour
certains présidents de la République qui
ont tout suit des réformes difficiles à
faire passer auprès des élus locaux on
pense à nos conseillers territorial pour
Nicolas Sarkozy on pense au fait que
François Hollande a eu bien sûr sa
réforme des régions là on a eu la taxe
d'habitation ils ont tous eu leur lot de
réformes qui les ont fâchées avec les
élus locaux qui même fait Emmanuel
Macron se sont formés en territoire Unis
quasiment contre lui alors oui mais je
crois qu'il y a une double particularité
dans le cas d'Emmanuel Macron d'abord
c'est que c'est le premier président qui
dès 2017 est considéré par une partie
des électeurs si on en croix les
enquêter électorales comme élu entre
guillemets par défaut c'est-à-dire que
le nombre de gens qui disent vous voulez
ce que vous l'avez élu parce que vous
défendez vraiment cette candidature ou
parce que c'était moins pire des
candidats c'est la première fois que le
l'idée du à défaut prend le pas et
deuxièmement Emmanuel Macron a une
relation très tempestieuse dès mon
arrivée au pouvoir en 2017 avec les
locaux et il a dû essayer de faire les
grands débats les rencontres avec les
élus locaux pour essayer à chaque fois
de renouer un peu le lien et on voit que
chez Emmanuel Macron il y a quand même a
priori pas la pétanque pour les locaux
de manière naturelle vous interrompt
pardon les résultats dans le
Pas-de-Calais c'est Quentin calmé si je
ne me trompe qui nous les fournit tout
de suite à vous Quentin c'est ça avant
d'aller réécouter le président du bureau
de vote de la Moselle pour vous donner
effectivement les résultats à Metz mais
le Pas-de-Calais c'est une information
importante car le rassemblement national
fait lire un sénateur ce soir
l'information est confirmée dans le
Pas-de-Calais le sénateur Christopher
Zurich va faire son retour enfin le
rassemblement national va faire son
retour dans le Parlement la chambre du
Parlement avec ce sénateur élu ce soir
voici la liste des autres candidats élus
dans ce département à Arras la liste de
Jean-François Rapin réalise deux sièges
avec la centriste Amel gaker Katia
poursuppoli réalise deux sièges avec le
sénateur RDSE Jean-Pierre corbizet Le
projet socialiste réalise un siège avec
l'élection de gérondes d'Arès le modem
Jean-Marie van lorenberg ne réalise
qu'un seul siège sur sa liste qui
signifie que l'ancienne ministre de la
Santé Brigitte bourguignon et donc
battus est une autre figure importante
dont on voulait suivre l'évolution ce
soir et donc on peut vous le dire
effectivement l'ancienne ministre de la
Santé Brigitte bourgagnon donc battu
dans le fait qu'elle est voilà pour les
résultats dans ce département on va donc
voir ce qui se passe maintenant à Metz
merci beaucoup Quentin évidemment on est
quasiment en liaison avec nos
correspondants à Metz ça va prendre
encore quelques quelques minutes Tam oui
encore donc cette information
qu'on avait commencé à donner mais cela
ferait donc deux sièges déjà pour le
rassemblement national en plus de
Christopher Zurich qui est adjoint de
Steve Briois à Hénin-Beaumont qui serait
élu au Pas-de-Calais il y aurait
également et bien Joshua Hochard qui
ferait qui est élu lui dans le Nord et
qui ferait donc son entrée au Sénat
est-ce qu'il y aurait Bruno au contraire
c'est un vote caché RN de certains
grands élus dans un scrutin comme
celui-là passez une des particularités
de ce scrutin d'abord c'est un scrutin à
bulletin secret bien évidemment on est
en démocratie mais quand il y a pas
beaucoup d'électeurs sa réserve toujours
beaucoup plus de surprises que lorsque
le corps électoral est très grand et
puis par ailleurs ces électeurs se sont
en partie des électeurs qui se
connaissent très bien il peut y avoir
des allégeances il peut y avoir des des
gens qui s'apprécient qui s'estiment
au-delà des étiquettes politiques et
donc effectivement il peut y avoir
peut-être pas l'idée d'un vote caché
mais il peut y avoir aussi des délégués
des conseils municipaux qui tiennent
compte aussi de ce qu'ils entendent des
nouveaux rapports de force et donc
effectivement on va regarder de très
très près ce qui a pu se passer dans les
territoires ou des élus en particulier
du rassemblement national vont venir
Mathieu évidemment on pourra même s'il y
a 4-5 ou 6 sénateurs du rassemblement
national difficilement comparer leur
poids à celui des 88 aujourd'hui députés
du parti de Marine Le Pen mais la
stratégie de normalisation on la verra à
l'oeuvre ici aussi ça va être
intéressant à suivre ah ben elle va être
à l'oeuvre ici dans les mêmes dans les
mêmes cravates j'allais dire les mêmes
costumes que que ce à quoi on peut
assister au Palais Bourbon puisqu'on
voit bien qu'on est vraiment dans une on
est plus que dans une stratégie de
dédiabolisation on est maintenant dans
une stratégie banalisation de
normalisation voire de notabilisation
du RN l'idée pour le rassemblement
national et de dire que ils incarnent
l'alternative en essayant d'enlever tous
les éléments tous les éléments les plus
repoussoirs alors la figure du père
Jean-Marie Le Pen on sait ça a été fait
il y a longtemps les mesures les plus
emblématiques du programme et les plus
repoussoirs enfin les plus clivant du
programme ont été abandonnés là on voit
que le rassemblement national rembourse
son prêt à sa banque russe enfin tout
tout voilà et plus dans la chaussure
l'idée c'est qu'on purge voilà pour
offrir un visage et un look renouvelé
face dans cette classe politique alors
c'est pas forcément qu'un loupe parce
que c'est vrai que le rassemblement
national a changé de position a changé
sur certaines sur certains sur certains
dossiers mais là c'est pas non plus très
surprenant enfin de voir que on a deux
sénateurs rassemblement national dans le
Nord ils sont quand même les bastions
électoraux du le pénis depuis maintenant
plus de plus de 10 ans ça serait on se
souvient de la formule de Lionel Jospin
sur l'anomalie démocratique il parlait
pas du Sénat mais du mode de scrutin
c'est notorial là on voit que c'est une
forme de correction de cette anomalie
démocratique par le nombre parce que il
y a quand même au-delà des des
conseillers municipaux qui peut y avoir
il y a aussi les dé ça reflète ça
reflète pour le coup la couleur
politique de ces territoires
où il y a eu beaucoup de mairies qui ont
été emportées par le rassemblement
national n'est pas au moins un élu
chacun
en plus ce sont des territoires qui où
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de sénateurs
qui sont tenus à beaucoup de siège pour
moi absolument d'autant plus que bon
encore une fois le fait qu'il y ait 89
députés RN à l'Assemblée nationale et 0
au Sénat à la limite presque
affaiblirable c'est en tant
qu'institution il est tout à fait
légitime que une institution qui est
parfois accusée de ne pas représenter
adéquatement les forces politiques en
présence et bien laisse une place à
l'une de ces principales forces
politiques quoi qu'on en pense mais il
faut aussi dire que là les URL vous
rejoindre quand même des gens qui sont
pas au RN mais qui au Sénat il y en a
deux ou trois députés qui ont choisi
Eric Zemmour en 2022 un apparent TLR un
en inscrit donc Stéphane Ravier
évidemment qui est
reconquête et ça sera intéressant aussi
de voir comment c'est ces gens qui vont
intégrer vont s'entendre avec leurs
anciens amis ou dans quatre Stéphane
Ravier où les gens qui ont a priori les
sympathies pour le camp politique dans
lequel il se trouve on sait aussi que
l'extrême droite est connu pour ses
divisions on l'a vu entre le reconquête
et le RN mais on va voir aussi comment
ils font pression sur la droite sur un
certain nombre de sujet moi ça
m'intéressera de voir un peu comment une
partie du groupe LR va être tenté
parfois d'aligner ces positions sociales
du RN indépendamment des jeux partisans
mais je parle vraiment dans le travail
qui va être fait sur un certain nombre
de sujets à commencer par les migrations
aussi annelevade c'est peut-être
aux conseillers
de plus en plus donc de raison de
vraiment faire campagne un dimension
très très personnelle et donc il y a des
choses qui peuvent se jouer comme ça on
prenait à François Patriat que on
pensait ne pas pouvoir réduire
c'est vraiment très très impoli parce
que c'est si mes parents étaient encore
là il m'en voudraient beaucoup de faire
ça mais bon on va on va filer en Moselle
tout de suite rejoindre Matthias Arès
pour des résultats
oui ça y est alors donc Jean-Marie
maison a réussi son pari la liste
étiquetée majorité sénatoriale rassemble
plus de 800 voix ici en Moselle et
réussit donc le pari de faire élire
trois sénateurs donc Jean-Marie maison à
parenté Union centriste Catherine
belretti investit par les républicains
et donc le docteur qualifec qualifié qui
est le premier adjoint ici à la mairie
de Metz ensuite les poursuivants sont
dans un mouchoir de poche Michael Weber
le premier fédéral socialiste réussi à
passer un siège et un seul siège ensuite
c'est donc le dernier siège et pour
Christine herzogénatrice sortante qui
avait donc été élu en 2017 sur la liste
de Jean-Louis Masson Anne boucher qui
est donc la candidate horizon n'a que
quelques voix de moi il y a elle rate
son siège ici ici en Moselle donc c'est
donc l'exploit de la soirée qu'on va
retenir ici Jean-Marie mizon réussi à
faire trois sièges en Moselle et donc à
priver aussi bien horizon que le
rassemblement national d'une place ici
merci merci beaucoup Mathias pour toutes
ces explications Mathieu croissanto
c'est la démonstration là encore une
fois que la droite et le centre
lorsqu'ils sont alliés et bien là
effectivement ils arrivent à faire trois
sièges c'était vraiment l'hypothèse
haute dans ce département de la Moselle
et donc voilà le RN pour le coup on
disait on parlait des RN qui allait
rentrer voilà RN qui ne rentrera pas en
Moselle c'est pas forcément de
l'arithmétique mais que j'ai quand même
des grands principes qui aident on en
parlait tout à l'heure à propos de Paris
trois listes et la droite est dans le
décor et là on le voit en Moselle une
liste d'unions et du coup ça fait non
seulement ça fait réélire mais en plus
c'est vrai que ça bloque le Sénat à des
concurrents réels horizon c'est un
concurrent réel pour la droite et puis
le rassemblement national évidemment
n'en parlons pas
on va pouvoir vous donner peut-être avec
Quentin Calmet je sais pas s'il est prêt
les résultats des Hauts-de-Seine c'est
quelques secondes
Poussard qui se trouve avec la sénatrice
Union centriste d'Ille-et-Vilaine avec
Françoise Gatel qui est également
présidente de la délégation au
collectivités
une première réaction à cette
information de la soirée il y aura au
moins deux sénateurs du rassemblement
national qui vont faire leur entrée au
Palais du Luxembourg alors ce n'est pas
une première parce que je rappelle qu'on
a déjà eu deux sénateurs de sénateurs FN
et en même temps au rassemblement
national et en même temps je pense que
le résultat des sénatoriales
d'aujourd'hui c'est l'issue des
municipales de 2020 et on sait que dans
des territoires
difficiles où il y a vraiment les gens
sentent qu'il y a cette fracture sociale
cette fracture territoriale il y a un
vote Front national qui s'exprime et qui
fait qu'au Sénat on va retrouver deux
voies de Front national donc il y aura
pas de coupe Front national ça c'est
certain aussi mais je pense que ça
reflète des réalités territoriales sur
lesquelles on doit tous extrêmement
vigilant et être capable de travailler
ensemble pour mettre fin à la
désespérance y compris des élus locaux
un mot sur les résultats des
sénatoriales dans votre région Françoise
Gatel puisque vous êtes élu
d'Ille-et-Vilaine et vous avez les
résultats dans le département du
Morbihan oui le département du
murmurerie était le seul département
renouvelable en Bretagne donc on avait
notre collègue Jack le nez sans triste
qui ne se représentait pas mais qui
était enfin qui soutenait une liste
conduit par le président des mains du
Morbihan Yves blunven qui est
incentriste il Pleuven a été élu mur et
le Jourdain qui était sortante et réélu
et on a une liste qui tennis un peu
dissidente socialiste
conduit par le secrétaire départementale
du Parti socialiste du Morbihan qui est
élu et là et la liste de la soeur de
Jean-Yves Le Driant qui était soutenu
par notre ancien collègue écologiste
l'abbé a été battu merci beaucoup
Françoise Gatel donc dans le Morbihan ça
veut dire que les écologistes perdent un
ciel
Alexandre pousseur n'hésitez pas
évidemment de revenir vers nous avec
d'autres invités politiques à Anne Le
vade je repose la question tout à
l'heure sur la des politiciens des des
élus locaux est-ce que c'est forcément
nouveau est-ce que c'est une tendance
qui s'accentue leur politisation ou leur
dépolluer
non parce qu'à l'échelle de de commune
de petite taille alors on a déjà
expliqué que le mode de scrutin était
très compliqué mais je rappelle que
toutes les communes quel que soit leur
taille ont au moins un délégué et que
après c'est en fonction de la taille du
Conseil Municipal que ils peuvent monter
de 1 à 15 etc donc forcément sur des
communes de petite taille on a même
parfois du mal à avoir plusieurs listes
candidates ou de les candidats en nombre
suffisants pour composer un conseil
municipal donc que ces candidats ne
soient pas politisés ça n'est pas
extrêmement surprenant j'ajoute que il
n'est pas non plus surprenant que
n'ayant pas nécessairement été politisés
au moment de la candidature et donc de
l'élection quand on est le maire d'une
petite commune on soit comme la majorité
des des électeurs beaucoup plus fluides
ou susceptible de variation que par le
passé c'est-à-dire que il me semble
qu'il y a moins d'ancrage politique qui
a 30 ou 40 ans où on était par tradition
socialiste ou RPR ou radical ou je ne
sais pas quoi aujourd'hui on voit bien
que il y a une tendance de l'électeurs à
le cas échéant plus facilement changer
de candidats et donc de type de bulletin
de vote au gré des élections votre votre
analyse sur cette versatilité on
pourrait dire ça comme ça des électeurs
français
prix global alors je vous interrompre
Quentin Calmet est prêt pardon Bruno
c'est votre tour pour les résultats des
Hauts-de-Seine oui tout à fait Thomas
nous sommes en mesure de vous donner les
résultats dans ce département qui est li
7 sénateurs la liste de Roger carochi
réalise deux sièges ça signifie que le
troisième Philippe mzek et battu sur
cette liste officielle LR c'est une
bonne performance en revanche pour le
président du groupe centriste au Sénat
RMC qui réussit à faire élire son
deuxième la deuxième personne sur sa
liste le communiste pierre ouzoullias
est réélu même chose pour les sénateurs
de la majorité présidentielle les Xavier
yaccovelli qui est également réélu et on
voit l'arrivée d'une nouvelle sénatrice
marido eschrieman qui est élu elle était
dissidente LR voilà pour les enjeux dans
ce département qui est lisait au total 7
sièges Thomas merci beaucoup Quentin
vous retrouve dans quelques minutes pour
un point
complet un tour complet de des résultats
ce sera dans quatre cinq minutes Bruno
cotresses donc on était sur la
versatilité des électeurs alors prix
globalement c'est vrai qu'on a une
tendance à ce que les électeurs se
décident un peu plus tardivement on
estime nous que de l'ordre d'un quart
des électeurs au moins prennent leur
décision finale dans les tous derniers
jours avant une élection mais évidemment
la décision finale elle est quand même
très souvent liée à un ensemble de choix
beaucoup plus ancrés sociologiquement
politiquement idéologiquement bien
évidemment mais c'est vrai que il n'y a
pas de raison que ça ne se traduise pas
non plus sur les grands électeurs des
élections sénatoriales et c'est vrai
qu'on voit s'affirmer dans la vie
politique une tendance aussi à ce que la
question territoriale soit très
importante nous voyons d'ailleurs dans
notre vie politique beaucoup de
personnalités qui commencent à
s'affirmer autour de l'idée que dans
leur territoire ils ont su prouver
quelque chose et que ça marche et donc
l'idée aussi qu'est-ce qui marche dans
une dans une France qui est de plus en
plus fracturer territorialement on
parlait tout à l'heure de d'élus des
petites communes peut-être sensibles aux
thématiques que porte le rassemblement
national éventuellement il faudra le
voir avec des données mais peut-être
sensibles à cette question il y a deux
ou trois ans dans le cas d'une grande
enquête à laquelle j'avais participé le
baromètre des territoires on avait
identifié à pratiquement un quart de la
population française qu'on considérait
comme des assignés des personnes qui ont
le sentiment qu'ils sont bloqués dans un
territoire dont il voudrait sortir mais
qu'ils ne peuvent pas en sortir et bien
cette thématique c'est une thématique
qui va prendre de l'importance politique
et il ne serait pas étonnant que des
élus locaux en tiennent de plus en plus
en disant il faut regarder comment on
peut en sortir au niveau local avec des
solutions localement négociées on se
rappelle d'ailleurs qu'Emmanuel Macron
avait fait sa première campagne celle de
2017 sur notamment la fin de
l'assignation à résidence c'était un
sujet qu'il avait identifié et on peut
dire que quand on voit comment ça se
passe là effectivement sur ces élections
que son message n'a pas suffisamment
porté mais en tout cas il n'est pas
parvenu assez fin plusieurs choses parce
que l'assignation résidence qui était
dénoncé après président de la République
elle était d'abord socio-économique à
ses yeux et la première mesure à faire
pour lui c'était de faire baisser le
chômage et pour le coup on peut être
pour ou contre cette constater que les
chiffres du chômage sont pas les mêmes
aujourd'hui qui qui assise en vrai donc
voilà après d'une façon générale dans
nos débats je pense qu'il faut pas
oublier que le Sénat et la chambre des
territoires et est aussi l'image ou à
l'illustration de ce qui se passe sur
ces territoires parfois sur ces
territoires les choix sont dictés par
des couleurs politiques j'allais dire
national par des débats nationaux c'est
aussi parfois des choix qui sont dictés
par des enjeux locaux il ne faut pas le
mésestimer à mon avis dans l'analyse
qu'on fait des résultats notamment des
dissidences notamment des lits des
listes qui peuvent se présenter des il y
a des coups de billard à trois bandes
dans les sénatoriales il faut le dire il
y a des favoris qui se retrouvent
dézinguées ou au tapis alors qu'on
imaginait que que qu'ils allaient
remporter et ça ne s'explique pas forte
forcément par des enjeux nationaux mais
parce qu'il se passe aussi sur sur le
terrain au niveau local faire une bonne
campagne électorale aussi
ne pas voir un concurrent venir et alors
que les Ratis ent et qu'il voit tous les
grands électeurs et puis il y a aussi
des règlements de comptes il faut le
dire
alors on va dans quelques minutes je
sais pas je fais je fais s'il arrive
pour savoir si Quentin Calmet est prêt
pour nous faire le tour complet des
résultats non mais ça ne saurait tarder
Vincent en Martini peut-être une
dernière intervention parce qu'on va
vous remercier les uns et les autres
pour la pertinence de vos analyses et
d'avoir partagé ces deux premières
heures 2h30 avec nous à l'instant T
c'est difficile ce que je vais vous
demander parce que on a vu les résultats
tomber tomber en temps réel etc est-ce
que vous pouvez déjà tirer une première
leçon du scrutin ou est-ce que c'est
beaucoup trop tôt
je ferai absolument pas mais en revanche
je réagir à ce que l'on voit pardon à
Christopher donc le
dessinateur rassemblement national
applaudit dans le Pas-de-Calais donc
l'un des deux sénateurs rassemblement
national qui vont déjà entrer au Palais
du Luxembourg
et pour vous avoir posé une question à
la qualité impossible de répondre
faire suite à ce que disait Mathieu
croissanto c'est vrai que les enjeux
locaux comptent mais dans les régions
dans lesquelles les grands partis
historiques tiennent encore la corde en
fait les règlements de comptes sont plus
faibles c'est quand ça va pas trop c'est
quand il y a des divisions locales quand
on regarde les paris c'est un bon
exemple voilà la droite parisienne
historiquement divisée qui n'arrive pas
à reprendre le pouvoir depuis maintenant
plus d'une vingtaine d'années et bien
les divisions elles montrent aussi
finalement des situations qui ne sont
pas que locales qui se font le reflet du
National le sud-ouest de la France par
exemple plutôt à qui à la gauche au
Parti socialiste en particulier et au
Parti radical de gauche bon bah là
évidemment vous avez moins de il peut y
avoir évidemment des dissidences des
divisions mais elles sont moindres
probablement lorsque dans ces certaines
de ces régions bien les parties
historiques arrivent quand même encore à
tenir leurs troupes donc c'est à la fois
local mais ça reste quand même aussi un
peu lié au National est-ce qu'il y a
certaines associations on a pas du tout
parlé tiens de de l'Association des
maires de France Bruno 13 alors que
c'est quand même un une entité qui
pourrait peser que dans un scrutin comme
celui-là on a relativement peu entendu
David bisna comment vous l'analysez ça
j'imagine aussi qu'il y a aussi
peut-être une forme de neutralité auquel
doivent se tenir les associations de de
de grands élus puisque évidemment tous
les maires toutes les couleurs
politiques
les présidents que ça soit le président
de l'AMF le président de l'association
des mers ruraux il représente toute la
diversité alors ils ont eux-mêmes leurs
agenda politique en tout cas c'est très
clairement le cas de David Lisnard donc
je ne doute pas qu'au lendemain des
élections régionales
n'acteur comme David Lisnard va
continuer à pousser dans la direction de
sa campagne il va inaugurer des locaux à
Paris
donc on imagine que le résultat des
sénatoriales n'est pas indifférent à sa
propre stratégie puisque lui-même est
issu d'une famille politique qui va sans
aucun doute conserver la majorité au
Sénat
le l'AMF et les autres associations
d'élus Matthieu croissanto on l'a vu ont
tenté en tout cas de se coaliser d'avoir
une parole commune aussi ces dernières
années notamment face à face
justement attaqué même au porte-monnaie
j'avais dit avec la fameuse suppression
la taxe d'habitation ils se sentait
voilà
méprisés par le pouvoir politique
attaqué au porte-monnaie et puis d'une
certaine façon pas associer aux
décisions et en revanche sur les
sifflets quand il y avait le feu à la
maison là pour le coup on avait besoin
des élus locaux donc tout ça c'est quand
même un peu un peu normalisé on va dire
il y a maintenant un dialogue qui est
engagé mais c'est vrai qu'on a vu du
coup cette fronde en tout cas cette
organisation de de de des élus locaux
sur le thème on existe et on veut être
pris en compte arrêter de venir nous
chercher quand ça ne va plus mais
associer nous avant merci beaucoup
Mathieu merci anneau de merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce cette première
partie de soirée électorale passionnant
on vous dit à bientôt évidemment sur les
antennes de de Public Sénat on va
recevoir d'ici quelques minutes nos
premiers invités politiques et comme
promis on vous propose tout de suite un
tour d'horizon on va dire le plus large
possible des premiers résultats
officiels qui nous sont parvenus grâce à
Quentin Calmet avoue la main Quentin oui
tout à fait Thomas ce que l'on peut dire
déjà et c'est l'information la plus
importante ce soir c'est qu'il y aura
globalement une stabilité qui s'annonce
pour la chambre haute du parlement la
droite et le centre vont conserver une
majorité absolue au Sénat mais il y a
une autre information importante c'est
le retour du rassemblement national ici
au Sénat ça s'est joué notamment dans le
Pas-de-Calais le RN a fait lire un
sénateur il s'appelle Christopher Zurich
et donc c'est un retour pour cette
formation politique ici à la Chambre
haute dans le même département on a vu
une contreperformance pour la majorité
présidentielle puisque l'ancienne
ministre de la Santé Brigitte
bourguignon a été battu elle était
seconde sur la liste du Modem Jean-Marie
vandlerenberg ce dernier est lui est
bien réélu il d'ailleurs devient le
sénateur et bien le doyen de
l'institution mais donc pas la deuxième
dans la liste autre contreperformance
pour une autre candidate de la majorité
présidentielle il s'agit de Sonia
baqueste qui a été battu dans une des
collectivités d'outre-mer qui est
renouvelée aujourd'hui en l'occurrence
la Nouvelle Calédonie et information
importante d'ailleurs dans ce
département c'est un sénateur
indépendantiste qui va faire son entrée
à la Chambre haute du parlement les
écologistes se réjouissent ce soir de
gagner des sièges il passerait de 12 à
16 sièges c'est l'information
communiquée par le groupe écologiste du
Sénat 12 à 16 sièges avec un symbole que
l'on peut noter l'élection de Mathilde
Olivier elle a 29 ans elle sera élue
parmi les sénateurs des Français établis
en France et c'est un symbole important
puisque à 29 ans elle deviendrait la
future benjamine du Sénat un rôle
honorifique que l'on verra par exemple
lors de l'élection du président du Sénat
le 2 octobre prochain à suivre des
départements qui renouvellent de
nombreux sénateurs en l'occurrence le
Nord on attend la liste définitive des
11 sénateurs élus dans ce département et
bien sûr Paris la capitale Thomas Etam
qui est li 12 sénateurs c'est à suivre
dans les prochaines minutes voilà pour
ce que l'on pouvait vous dire des grands
équilibre qui vont se dessiner ce soir
là de ces sénatoriales 2023 merci
beaucoup Quentin Calmet on vous retrouve
évidemment très régulièrement lors de
cette soirée consacrée aux élections
sénatoriales sur l'antenne de Public
Sénat on vous présente tout de suite nos
invités et d'abord nos invités
politiques Dominique Estrosi ça sonne
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice LR
des Alpes-Maritimes j'accue également
mais les nouveaux gel bonsoir bienvenue
à vous sénatrice des Français d’étranger
pour le parti Europe Écologie Les Verts
Claude malurey bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes le président du groupe Les
Indépendants ici au Sénat et également
avec nous sur ce plateau récupère la
constitutionnaliste Anne Charlène bézina
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
également avec nous Pascal Perrineau
politologue professeur à Sciences Po
Paris et puis le constitutionnaliste
Benjamin Morel politologue maître de
conférence en droit public à Paris 2
Panthéon à SAS vous êtes aussi l'auteur
du livre la France en miettes s'est aux
éditions du Cerf on commence avec vous
peut-être Mélanie Augel on entendait
Quentin Calmet nous nous reprendrons
dans sa voix l'annonce que votre partie
a fait tout à l'heure donc les
écologistes qui passeraient de 12 à 16
sièges ici au Sénat grand sourire
forcément
oui on va pas pleurer non évidemment le
groupe écologiste se renforce c'est le
résultat du renforcement des écologistes
au niveau local c'est pas un hasard et
on est effectivement très heureux
d'avoir à la fois un groupe qui
s'agrandit qui se rajeunit ça a été dit
je crois d'après mes informations que
Mathilde Olivier qui est donc élu de la
même circonscription que moi les
Français l'étranger sera la main jamais
une du Sénat c'est aussi important pour
nous elle a 29 ans
a priori non elle avant
et c'est aussi un groupe qui se
solidifie puisque il fut un temps
pendant longtemps les écologistes
avaient voilà des sièges parfois qui
étaient qui étaient nécessaires à cause
enfin qui dont l'élection nécessitait
des accords et là on a un groupe qui est
plus que jamais solide puisqu'il est le
résultat de notre propre force en France
et je peux vous dire aussi ce soir que
les écologistes n'ont jamais eu autant
de parlementaires nationaux que ce soit
merci beaucoup Dominique et Saudi ça
sonne une une citation du président du
groupe LR ici au Sénat Bruno Retailleau
qui il y a quelques minutes saluaient
une majorité sénatoriale confortée à
quel point votre majorité sénatoires
est-elle confortée ce soir d'abord au
niveau du groupe les républicains certes
il y a quelques pertes en ligne mais
globalement il y a une stabilité du
groupe les républicains c'est vrai que
en 2020 on avait un étiage qui était
régulièrement haut avec un groupe qui
était fort de 145 membres donc il y a
quelques pertes à lignes il y a aussi
les départements dans lesquels on
pensait pouvoir perdre et on maintient
nos positions et puis il y a des
départements dans lesquels on a vu des
listes de divisions on peut le déplorer
mais pour autant cette liste de division
permettent de faire rentrer des
personnes qui est certes sont
dissidentes mais qui devrait selon toute
logique rejoindre le groupe les
républicains après au-delà de cette
globalement stabilité ce qui est
important pour le groupe les
républicains bien évidemment c'est de
conforter comme l'a dit le président
Retailleau la majorité sénatoriale afin
que le Sénat reste au cœur du débat
public et donc c'est maintenant de voir
de combien le groupe centriste sera fort
en termes de membres comment ces membres
du groupe centriste qui sont assez
hétéroclites vont se déterminer et puis
les autres groupes aussi parce que il y
a des personne qui ont été élues dont on
ne sait pas encore aujourd'hui quel
groupe potentiellement elles vont
pouvoir rejoindre mais je crois que
aujourd'hui ce soir on peut dire que de
toute façon effectivement la majorité
sénatoriale et à tout le moins stable et
conforté vous faites notamment référence
à ce qui se passe à Paris au fait que
par exemple on a appris qu'il y aurait
certainement l'élection de Agnès even
qui se présentaient en dissidence cette
dissidence là vous vous comptez sur elle
pour quand même nourrir le groupe LR
c'est une dissidence d'hier qui va se
transformer en alliance de deux morts on
savait qu'ani c'est vrai n'était assuré
de faire son siège au vu des grands
électeurs qu'elle avait pu comptabiliser
après l'élection au Conseil de Paris
c'est la même chose aussi dans les
Hauts-de-Seine les Hauts-de-Seine
derrière la liste officielle de Roger
caroutchi il n'y a que deux postes mais
la dissidente d'hiver droite marido
eslimane est élu et donc elle devrait
théoriquement nous rejoindre je suis
encore très prudente ce soir bien sûr
quand je on voyait pendant que vous nous
parliez dominicalisation des images de
d'élus de la gauche parisienne voilà qui
euh qui manifestait qui manifestait leur
joueur juste une information de cette
queue aux résultats on apprend que
également c'est encore à confirmer que
Laurence Rossignol qui est sénatrice
socialiste sortante de l'Oise et qui se
présentait dans le Val-de-Marne serait a
priori élu donc preuve que malgré le
fait qu'elle ait changé de département
entre les deux élections et bien ça ne
lui a pas porté préjudice à l'axe
ministre des familles Claude malurey la
soirée difficile que certains
anticipaient pour la majorité
présidentielle était en train de se
produire
écoutez je pense qu'il est trop tôt pour
avoir les chiffres définitifs et qu'on
le verra à la fin et deuxièmement je
vais être assez je vais je pense qu'il
faut qu'on soit tous dans l'humilité moi
je vais parler pour mon groupe et pas
pour l'ensemble des chiffres de la
majorité présidentielle d'ailleurs mon
groupe est un petit peu
entre la majorité présidentielle et la
majorité sénatoriale donc c'est un peu
plus compliqué en tout cas en ce qui
nous concerne nous tout le monde se
réjouit ce soir visiblement comme
d'habitude après une élection moi je
pense que on peut se réjouir parce qu'on
sait déjà aujourd'hui
sous réserve
des sénateurs qui demain rejoignent une
région pas tel ou tel groupe qu'on a une
augmentation considérable du nom de nos
sénateurs en pourcentage c'est quelque
chose comme 25 à 30% on attendra demain
pour avoir les des chiffres plus précis
et par conséquent dans ce groupe qui
soit appartient des sénateurs qui
appartiennent à horizon soit qui sont
indépendants mais l'ensemble tous sont
définitive des proches d'Édouard
Philippe c'est je crois que c'est ce qui
nous rassemble
ça prouve de ce point de vue là que la
stratégie de l'implantation territoriale
puisque le gros le parti des dons
Philippe à cette stratégie
d'implantation territoriale un peu
obligé tout à l'heure les Verts en plus
de sénateurs ce soir parce qu'ils ont
gagné des grandes villes en 2020
notamment et bien ce point de vue là
l'implantation dans le dans les
territoires ce qui est vraiment la
marque de fabrique d'horizons et du
groupe des indépendants ce soir se
révèle payante malgré le fait que
souvent les élections en demi-mandat
sont des élections en sanction pour pour
notre groupe ça ne l'a pas été du tout
et quelques résultats tout de suite avec
Quentin Calmet avant de donner la parole
une première fois à nos invités experts
Quentin calmé est-il prêt pour nous
donner ses résultats ah bah il est pas
encore prête bah écoutez c'est très bien
donc je peux me tourner vers soi
vous vous étiez voilà en train de voir
les résultats tomber les les après les
autres quelle première leçon vous
général vous tirez de ce de cette soirée
sur le peut-être le rôle voilà on a
beaucoup parlé dans notre première
partie de de soirée sénatoriale de ce
rôle de contre-pouvoir du Sénat du
contrôle de de la loi est-ce que vous
pensez que ce rôle va être conforté dans
les prochaines semaines dans les
prochains mois alors les premières
leçons que ressentir c'est qu'en réalité
c'est une élection fait de plusieurs
cercles concentriques les grands
électeurs qui ont une forme d'étiquette
les sénateurs élus qui eux se
revendiquent parfois d'une étiquette
n'est pas forcément la même que celle
des grands électeurs et ensuite la
logique des groupes qui est encore
différente de celle de l'élection donc
c'est vrai que on a des élections qui
viennent s'étaler dans le temps avant de
vraiment donner leur leçon donc ce qui
est intéressant ce soir c'est qu'on a
déjà des tendances mais qu'on a le
sentiment qu'il faudra attendre encore
quelques jours pour être sûr de
connaître les grands équilibres autre
leçon celle de la grande stabilité quand
même c'est vrai que le Sénat étant cela
une deuxième vague un petit peu des
élections locales c'est qu'on a cette
tendance à la reconduction notamment
parce qu'il y a la confiance très forte
qui est faite dans les élus locaux dans
les territoires donc on la retrouve et
sur le rôle de contre-pouvoir je pense
que en effet on dit trop souvent du
Sénat c'est une chambre un peu classique
conservatrice or on le voit avec le
groupe Écologie Les Verts le groupe Les
Indépendants on a aussi ce
renouvellement de la vie politique qui
commence à faire son entrée alors certes
la vague est moins forte que ce qu'on a
au sein de l'Assemblée nationale mais on
a quand même de quoi voir ce
renouvellement donc contre-pouvoir
certainement allez on va tous vous
redonner la parole mais d'abord chose
première chose due on va tous puis se
voir Quentin quelle mai pour une
nouvelle salle de résultats et notamment
dans le Val-de-Marne oui si vous voulez
on peut commencer par le Val-de-Marne je
crois que on avait prévu de partir dans
les soldes mais allons dans le
Val-de-Marne parce qu'il y a une
information importante qui nous a été
confirmée par le groupe socialiste du
Sénat puisque l'ancienne ministre des
familles de l'enfance et des droits des
femmes souffrent en soi Hollande et
réélu dans le Val-de-Marne vous voyez
qu'ils sont bons qui réalise une bonne
performance avec deux sièges Pascal ça
va le délit pour Lyon de la gauche qui
réalise un siège on va voir à la suite
des six élus dans le Val-de-Marne dans
le département du 94 puisque on vous
disait Laurence Rossignol le deuxième de
liste sur le lion de la gauche est élu
Laurent Laffont le et bien président
centriste de la commission des Affaires
sociales et de la culture et de la
commission des culturel et d'éducation
du Sénat est réélu et on le voit le
dissident de gauche à CLI mélodi qui est
élu qui donc réalise le sixième siège
dans le département du 94 du
Val-de-Marne allez maintenant allons
dans l'Essonne car il y a un jeu de
chaise musicale important dans ce
département qui comptait je vous le
rappelle deux sénateurs LR et 3 centrist
et bien on va voir l'arrivée de deux
sénateurs de gauche dans ce département
on va voir ensemble les résultats dans
le département du 91 qui vont s'afficher
dans l'Essonne effectivement et bien
voilà on est qu'on les aura on pourra
vous les donner très précisément voilà
pour les résultats qu'on pouvait vous
donner Tam et Thomas si beaucoup et on
continue avec des résultats puisqu'on
est avec Steve Jourdain depuis l'Hôtel
de Ville de Paris on vous écoute Steve
oui depuis la salle des fêtes de l'hôtel
de ville de Paris et la gauche qui
partait Unis socialiste écologiste
communiste la gauche qui est en train de
se congratuler vous voyez actuellement
Anne Hidalgo qui parle qui fait un point
presse comme on dit un point de duplex
et qui peut-être nous parlera ensuite la
gauche qui partait donc unique qui
possédait 7 sièges de sénateurs avant
cette élection elle en récolte un elle
récolte un siège supplémentaire lui
siège donc c'est une victoire et vous le
voyez encore une fois la gauche qui se
combattue la gauche qui est unie juste
derrière moi dans cette grande salle des
fêtes cette magnifique salle des fêtes
de l'hôtel de ville de Paris il y aura
quelques nouveaux entrants quelques
nouveaux visages qu'on connaît bien de
la vie politique française puisque un
certain Yannick Jadot arrivera ce soir
au Palais du Luxembourg Yannick Jadot
l'écologie ce qui était candidat à la
dernière élection présidentielle à
droite on essayait de résister on
partait diviser ici dans cette élection
de Paris la droite qui résiste et qui
parvient à conserver ces quatre sièges
sénateurs quelques nouveaux visages
également puisque Agnès evray la
présidente de la Fédération LR de Paris
parvient et bien à faire un siège et
arriver au Sénat on retrouvera notamment
aussi Francis spinner le ténor du
barreau parisien et maire du 16e
arrondissement de Paris en revanche
goodbye Pierre Charron le 13 Sarkozy St
sénateur il était au Sénat depuis 2011
il ne parvient pas à conserver son siège
et puis un dernier mot peut-être sur la
majorité présidentielle qui avait un
siège ici à Paris en la presse en la
personne de Julien barjetton Julien
barjoton qui ne parvient pas à conserver
son siège il y a donc plus de majorité
présidentielle au Sénat pour la
circonscription de Paris et puis en
résumé Tam Thomas quelques petites
surprises ici à Paris mais quelques
confirmations aussi la droite résiste la
majorité présidentielle s'effondre et la
gauche qui arrive donc en force avec un
siège supplémentaire ce soir au Palais
du Luxembourg
merci merci beaucoup Steve pour toutes
ces informations Pascal Perrineau et
bien ses résultats à Paris c'est la
démonstration que l'union fait la force
c'était le cas là il y avait une liste
d'union ça socialiste ELV communiste
Paris en commun génération et donc un
siège supplémentaire par rapport à la
situation actuelle
a pris des risques on le savait avant le
résultat est là ce soir mais tout cela
ne doit pas obéir le cas parisien de ne
pas oublier ce qui se passe au plan de
l'ensemble du pays au plan de l'ensemble
du pays c'est une grande stabilité et la
France des territoires reste à droite et
au centre c'est tout de même la
principale leçon il n'y a pas de poussée
de gauche sensible il n'y a pas de
poussée du rassemblement national qui
aurait bouleversé la donne non la France
des territoires reste à droite et au
centre cependant la gauche résiste très
bien dans ses bastions à vous prenez des
départements comme les Landes comme les
Hautes-Pyrénées il y a une reproduction
absolument parfaite tout ça va dans le
sens d'une grande stabilité
il y a deuxième leçon la pérennité tout
de même des partis politiques
traditionnels parce que au nationale ses
grands partis LR
le Parti socialiste voyez j'en ai oublié
son nom sont en voie de disparition ils
sont en voie de disparition et là vous
avez ces parties qui continuent en effet
dans les territoires dans les
départements dans les collectivités
d'outre-mer à voir une véritable
implantation c'est à dire ce que l'on
voyait dans les élections nationales
c'est-à-dire cette coupure entre la
France nationale et la France locale
elle est très sensible elle est très
sensible ce soir et puis dernière leçon
les nouveautés parce que tout de même il
faut voir en effet la force des signaux
faibles alors il y a du côté de la
majorité le grignotage d'horizon
horizon qui est une force nouvelle
existe c'est pas encore une puissance
qui bouleverse les équilibres politiques
mais horizons commencent à exister les
écologistes connaissent sur leur terrain
habituel le terrain des grandes villes
connaissent en effet un frémissement la
majorité connaît tout de même un échec
il faut bien le reconnaître on vient de
le dire avec Paris mais il y a bien
d'autres territoires où il y a un échec
et pour le RN il faudra attendre
cependant je regardais dans des
départements je vous intéresse parce
qu'on est avec bien sûr c'est promis on
essaie de tenir les promesses d'ici
Steve Jourdain depuis l'Hôtel de Paris
avec la mère de Paris avec un Hidalgo
oui madame de Paris bonjour
satisfaite très heureuse bien sûr c'est
une belle victoire qu'on célèbre ce soir
de la gauche des écologistes rassemblées
de mon équipe municipale vous savez ça
fait vraiment plaisir parce que là il y
a 8 sénateurs et sénatrices des bosseurs
qui pour beaucoup d'entre eux sont
passés par cette équipe qui vont arriver
au Sénat et puis surtout vous savez ça
fait quand même 20 ans que la gauche et
les écologistes dirigent cette ville
bientôt disant que je suis maire de
cette ville et que n'a-t-on entendu la
droite parisienne contester notre
légitimité que n'avons-nous été en
permanence sous les coups de boutoir de
la macronie de la droite de Madame Dati
aujourd'hui on célèbre notre victoire je
constate que la macronie n'a aucun siège
et aucune représentation pour Paris ce
soir au Sénat ça n'est pas une surprise
ça veut dire que le centre ne s'est pas
du tout mobilisé autour de son candidat
et puis la droite la droite parisienne
avec Madame Dati comme bon bah
fragmentation de la droite montre que en
fait ils ne sont pas dans une capacité
de rassemblement peut-être que le
spectacle terrible
souvent clooneyce que souvent des grades
qui est donné par Madame Dati au Conseil
de Paris n'a pas attiré y compris les
grands électeurs ils en tireront les
leçons je l'espère en tous les cas nous
ce soir on célèbre une très très belle
victoire et je suis très heureuse et
vraiment voilà il y a une belle équipe
ici et nous allons poursuivre pour les
Parisiens et les Parisiens ça dit
beaucoup de ce qui est Paris donc le
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
qui ne renouvelle pas son siège est
vraiment des des enseignements à tirer
au niveau national selon vous vous savez
d'abord je pense que quand on change
de camp je veux pas dire sa veste mais
bon voilà au bout d'un moment plus
personne ne vous croit donc j'ai pris
des grands électeurs ne vous croient pas
je pense aussi que ici nous faisons un
travail sérieux on peut ne pas être
d'accord avec tout ce que nous faisons
c'est très engagé sur l'écologie très
engagé sur le social très engagé sur le
fonctionnement démocratique de la ville
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec ça
mais être en permanence dans le refus de
tout le blocage systématique de tous nos
projets parce qu'ils viennent de nous je
pense que ça les Français n'en veulent
plus en tous les gars les Parisiens n'en
veulent pas
peut-être petite dernière question à
Madame Hidalgo c'est le premier tour de
la bataille des municipales de 2026 oh
non c'est vraiment une élection
sénatoriale dans laquelle la gauche
rassemblée montre que quand elle est
rassemblée qu'elle a des valeurs qu'elle
a aussi un travail à montrer qu'elle
n'est pas simplement dans un combat
idéologique n'est pas dans l'agressivité
mais dans la construction dans le fer et
ben ça marche donc et ça conforte votre
travail vous à la mairie de Paris ah ça
conforte mon travail mais qui n'est pas
fait tout seul je suis avec une équipe
donc ça conforte le travail d'une équipe
vous savez la politique c'est un sport
collectif merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup merci vous avez essayé de
lui faire dire que les municipales
étaient derrière elle est nier Anne
Hidalgo mais Benjamin Morel on a quand
même senti bien sûr des flèches
décochées pour avec les municipales en
ligne de mire bien sûr dans ce dans
cette ville de Paris dans la capitale
Rachida Dati bomba fragmentation la
droite oui bien sûr tort de se priver en
réalité parce qu'en effet la position de
Daddy lors de cette élection et ben
difficilement déjà stratégiquement
compréhensible et probablement que la
droite part avec là un boulet au pied
après les municipales c'est très très
long tout de même je crois qu'il faut
raison garder ce n'est pas le premier
tour des municipales ce soir même si
évidemment ça donne une indication sur
et bien l'évolution du corps des élus
locaux alors quelles leçons vous
tirez-vous de cette soirée il y a
plusieurs leçons d'abord comme je disais
bien Pascal il y a une forme de
conservatisme mais c'est traditionnel en
réalité les chocs politiques les
évolutions politico Sénat mettent du
temps jusque au milieu des années 60
vous savez le groupe le plus important
ici c'était les radicaux le vieux qui
tenait en réalité ce cette chambre sous
la Troisième République et donc vous
voyez vous avez un effet retardateur
l'égoliste ont mis 20 ans à s'implanter
dans les collectivités et ensuite
exister profondément au Sénat il y a
quand même un certain nombre de signaux
faibles c'est vrai que on a une
reconduction des grandes forces qui sont
LR le Parti socialiste la nuque de façon
unie et en effet l'alliance dans le
cadre d'un tel mode de scrutin permet
d'avoir plus de sénateurs permet d'avoir
plus d'élus en revanche on voit même si
on va y revenir tout à l'heure une
petite poussée en vote au moins du RN on
voit que l'hélice ne sont pas aussi
ridicules qu'on aurait pu le penser en
termes de voix donc on voit que même si
et bien on a un sénat qui garde cette
image je dirais relativement en lien
avec sa composition précédente il y a
des évolutions des signaux faibles au
niveau local et que le vote des grands
électeurs qui étaient probablement plus
prévisible il y a encore quelques
élections sénatoriales aujourd'hui et
moins évident et plus éclaté et moins
perceptible notamment à Paris
ce qui montre que ce champ politique
local il évolue il évolue lentement mais
il évolue quand même
une communication c'est quelque chose
que vous avez constaté vous sur le
terrain effectivement cette évolution du
vote cette parfois cette dépolitisation
le fait qu'il faille revenir convaincre
aujourd'hui qu'une étiquette politique
ça ne suffit pas oui je pense que c'est
véritablement ce qui se passe là depuis
déjà 2020 mais qui s'est accentué
aujourd'hui on voit bien que avant
lorsqu'il y avait des grands électeurs
généralement elles étaient amenées à
suivre j'allais dire un mot d'ordre dans
les grandes villes en particulier et
donc on se posait pas de questions si le
maire était d'une couleur politique le
corps des grands électeurs qui était
désignés dans cette commune aller suivre
la même couleur politique que le maire
aujourd'hui force est de constater que
ça n'existe plus et que l'on voit bien
que d'abord parce que aux dernières
élections municipales bon nombre de
conseils municipaux de liste ont été
composées de personnalités d'horizon
assez divers rassemblés sous une même
étiquette d'abord et avant tout
municipal et local et que forcément
chacun reprend quelque part sa liberté
de vote au moment également
dessinatoriales et que l'on ne peut plus
tabler sur une homogénéité complète du
corps des grands électeurs merci
beaucoup on continue évidemment notre
émission spéciale notre soirée élection
sénatoriale on vous propose tout de
suite
un tour de résidence des principales
réactions politiques depuis le début de
cette soirée des réactions qui ont été
compilées réunis par flore à sauvage
après ça montre une chose c'est que les
élections sénatoriales ne sont pas
automatiques qu'il y a beaucoup plus de
suspense beaucoup plus de rapports de
force politique qui s'expriment que ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer certes ce sont
des grands électeurs et on pourrait dans
certaines circonscriptions se dire bon
ben voilà ça va voter comme ci comme ça
mais il y a des surprises aussi
possibles et c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé personne ne vote de droit
dans les bottes de du patron du groupe
au Sénat on sait que les sénateurs ont
chacun une sensibilité dans chacun une
autonomie de pensée ils ont chacun une
autonomie politique même s'ils sont en
cohérents et globalement quand on est à
droite on vote avec la droite et quand
on est au centre mais là ça devient plus
compliqué parce qu'on peut voter parfois
avec la droite assez souvent et puis sur
certains textes on peut voter aussi avec
la gauche
en plus on sait que les centrices voilà
sont parfois des carpes et des lapins et
que c'est pas forcément
il faut le dire mais comme dans d'autres
parties on peut dire les choses
différentes qui sont liées à l'histoire
politique française en tout cas c'est
que c'est compliqué au centre et on va
le voir ça te va devenir de plus en plus
compliqué entrer notamment au centre
droit dans notre vie politique ce qui se
passe au Sénat représente totalement
majorité scénariiale et majorité
présidentielle ça match pas forcément au
Sénat il y a des modems qui sont dans la
majorité sénatoriale et qui sont en même
temps dans la majorité présidentielle
donc voilà c'est compliqué et on voit
effectivement très clairement très
clairement dans ces élections
sénatoriales la difficulté du parti
présidentiel avoir été implantés dans
toutes ces petites communes il faut
quand même rappeler en France il y a 72%
de nos communes qui ont moins de 1000
habitants il y a 78% qui ont moins de
10000 habitants et le parti présidentiel
a beaucoup investi dans les grands
métropoles et donc du coup il a du mal
il lui manque des grands électeurs dans
cette France des petites voir très
petites communes on va le retrouver sans
doute dans les résultats
l'habitude de dire c'est au moment du
vote du budget qu'on sait qui appartient
vraiment à la majorité qui est dans
l'opposition et donc là ça va être la
grande épreuve de vérité de voir ces
nouveaux élus et ce nouveau Sénat
comment il va se positionner sur cette
question question encore une fois tout à
fait essentielle parce qu'il n'est pas
banal dans une grande démocratie
européenne de voir la loi suprême la loi
de finances adoptée avec des mécanismes
de parlementarisme rationalisé plutôt
qu'à l'issue d'un débat avec des votes
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous c'est
une édition spéciale que nous vous
proposons ce soir sur Public Sénat
consacré évidemment aux résultats de ces
élections sénatoriales toute la
rédaction mobilisée pour vous faire
vivre en direct les principales
surprises beaucoup d'enjeux également à
analyser ce soir oui la droite est le
centre semble déjà bien parti pour
conserver leur majorité le groupe
Renaissance lui paraît en difficulté
après notamment l'échec de l'Unique
ministre candidate à cette élection
Sonia bac S en Nouvelle-Calédonie et
puis on apprend déjà l'arrivée de
sénateurs rassemblement national qui ont
été élus c'est donc le retour de
l'extrême droite dans la chambre haute
on fera évidemment le point sur les
personnalités qui ont perdu leur siège
celles et ceux qui au contraire arrivent
à la Haute Assemblée on est présent
également dans quatre départements
quatre points chauds de ce de cette
soirée électorale on est dans le Nord à
Lille avec Samia duchire on est avec
Mathias Arès dans la Moselle à Metz dans
les Hauts-de-Seine Nanterre avec Audrey
bettaz et enfin à Steve Jourdain est à
Paris pour nous faire vivre le scrutin
de la capitale depuis l'Hôtel de Ville
Alexandre Poussard est avec nous dans
cette salle des conférences pour
recueillir le plus de réactions de
personnalités politiques elles sont
nombreuses ils sont nombreux à avoir
rejoint le Sénat évidemment cette soirée
et puis les résultats évidemment les
résultats c'est avec quand un Calmet que
nous retrouverons très régulièrement
pour des points complets départements
par département bonsoir Quentin et on va
commencer par les principaux résultats
de cette soirée électorale oui la
principale information ce soir c'est
cette stabilité qui s'annonce au Palais
du Luxembourg ce soir la droite et le
centre qui devrait conserver la majorité
absolue à la chambre haute du Parlement
mais vous le disiez c'est information le
retour du rassemblement national au
Sénat avec au moins trois sièges de
sénateurs un dans le Pas-de-Calais un
dans le Nord et ainsi que en
Seine-et-Marne on va y revenir mais
parmi ces sénateurs élus il y a
Christopher Zurich qui est donc élu dans
le Pas-de-Calais qui est fait son entrée
au Sénat une contreperformance dans ce
même département pour la majorité
présidentielle puisque l'ancienne
ministre de la Santé Brigitte
bourguignon est-elle battue elle était
seconde de liste de Jean-Marie
vanderenberg elle n'est pas ce soir et
c'est également une
contreperformance pour une autre
candidate de renaissance de la majorité
présidentielle il s'agit de Sonia bakkes
qui était qui est actuellement
secrétaire d'État à la citoyenneté et
qui est également battu en
Nouvelle-Calédonie le groupe écologiste
et qui est bien nous a informé se
réjouir de voir son groupe passé de 12 à
16 membres avec cet un symbole la plus
jeune sénatrice qui s'appelle Mathilde
Olivier qui est bien apparemment est élu
pour les Français taburde France on va
voir d'autres personnalités comme
Corinne narratiga qui manque du bureau
national du Parti socialiste elle est
élue en scène Saint-Denis et elle fait
même élire un deuxième socialiste sur sa
liste on va passer effectivement à la
Seine-Saint-Denis on va voir également
que les communistes réalisent une
contreperformance dans le 93 puisque
seul Fabien gay est réélu pour le PCF la
Seine-Saint-Denis qui perdrait donc un
siège malgré donc cette la victoire de
Fabien gay enfin le testeur Vincent capo
canelas qui est un sénateur centriste et
bien lui il serait bien réélu on va voir
d'autres élus dans ce département de la
Seine-Saint-Denis puisque et bien
Thierry et Mayenne est réélu pour les LR
et également on voit un nouvel arrivant
le candidat du Parti radical de gauche
Ahmed la wedge on continue on termine
avec cette salve de résultats pour ce
qui concerne la Seine-et-Marne puisque
je vous le disais tout à l'heure mais
c'est donc une surprise un troisième élu
rassemblement national est élu dans le
département de la Seine-et-Marne il
s'agit de Aymeric Durox pour leur
rassemblement national les LR il est
centristes et qui perdent chacun un
siège anne-charlarcher pierre cuppert
sont réélu pour les LR et on voit
effectivement la gauche qui arrive
également à faire élire Vincent et blé
ainsi qu'une élue communiste Marianne
Margate on voit un élu horizon qui est
bien prend la suite d'une horizon il
s'appelle Louis Vogel voilà pour les
grands enseignements de ce que l'on peut
dire à l'heure qu'il est sur les
résultats au sénatoriales 2023 merci
beaucoup Quentin calmé depuis le tout
nouveau plateau des émissions de de
Public Sénat je vous présente tout de
suite nos invités politiques Claude
malurey bonsoir vous êtes président du
groupe Les Indépendants sénateurs de
l'Allier Dominique et ça sonne bonsoir
c'est natrice LR des Alpes-Maritimes
j'accueille Yann chanterelles bonsoir
sénateur socialiste des Français de
l'étranger
également avec nous Pascal perinot
politologue professeur à Sciences Po
Paris bonsoir et bienvenue et enfin
Benjamin Morel constitutionnaliste
maître de conférence en droit public à
Paris de Panthéon Assas et vous êtes
l'auteur de la France en miettes aux
éditions du Cerf bonsoir Yann
une soirée de victoire pour pour le
Parti socialiste oui c'est une soirée de
victoire même pour la gauche en général
puisque on progresse à ces élections et
il y a deux enseignements qui sont très
importants parce que sur les bandes de
la gauche non seulement on progresse
mais on assiste aussi un rajeunissement
une nouvelle génération de
parlementaires qui vont arriver ici au
Palais du Luxembourg et je pense que
c'est une très bonne chose justement
pour le renouvellement de cette
institution et qui vont apporter aussi
une petite fraîcheur pour je l'espère
aussi la conquête future de pouvoir en
2027 mais ça c'est ça c'est une autre
histoire il reste encore de nombreuses
batailles à mener mais il y a ça mais il
y a aussi un enseignement important
aussi à noter c'est la chute du parti du
président de la République d'ailleurs le
président de la République est en train
de donner actuellement une interview qui
est d'ailleurs très insultant et ça
montre le peu de cas qui fait du
Parlement et il a été sanctionné pour ça
le peu de cas qui fait justement de tous
les corps intermédiaires des élus locaux
qui ont sanctionné son parti et le
mépris qui manifeste vis-à-vis du
Parlement de faire une interview au
moment en ajustement les résultats des
élections sénatoriales pour justement
passer très rapidement à autre chose
parce que c'est une claque que le
Président de la République vient de
recevoir par la part des grandes
électeurs et des élus locaux partout en
France on précise tout de même que
aujourd'hui vous n'êtes quand même pas
majoritaire parce que quand on parle de
victoire voilà et vous êtes actuellement
en progression voilà il y a 64 sénateurs
socialistes peut-être l'ensemble de la
gauche vous espérez atteindre la
centaine de sénateurs nous on sait que
le groupe socialiste sera va avoir des
sièges supplémentaires ça peut l'être de
2 à 5 les écologistes ont déjà plus de 4
sièges les communistes devraient
progresser donc on devrait atteindre
sans problème la centaine de sièges
qu'on a l'objectif qu'on s'était fixé
bien évidemment c'est un collège
électoral identique par rapport à la
dernière érection sénatoriale quand je
vous dis il y a une progression c'est
quand on regarde par rapport au collège
qu'avant la leçon c'est aussi que il
faut être uni parce que il y a des
endroits où on n'était pas unis et là on
a perdu des sièges donc on aurait pu en
gagner encore plus et là où on a été uni
effectivement nous avons gagné des
sièges donc ça montre aussi le message
qui est envoyé aussi bien par nos notre
électorat que par les grands électeurs
c'est unissez-vous unissez-vous ça
permet de gagner ça permet d'avoir une
politique dans une seconde que le
malheur la réponse sur l'intervention
télévisée du chef de l'État ce soir
est-ce insultant pour le Parlement et
plus particulièrement le Sénat côté chef
de l'État il est toujours dans la même
situation quelque soit le président de
toute façon vous savez c'est Freud un
jour disait raconter cette histoire
c'était une dame qui lui disait monsieur
le professeur mon fils ça ne va pas du
tout il est adolescent
tout ce que je peux faire tout le temps
tout le temps c'est pas ce qu'il faut je
me fais engueuler etc
dites-moi dites moi ce qu'il faut faire
et produisiez vous savez madame quoi que
vous fassiez vous aurez toujours tort
le président de la République c'est
depuis longtemps quel qu'il soit le
punching ball d'ailleurs une fois qu'il
l'est plus en général il retrouve toute
sa
en tout cas
le être président de la République la
France c'est du jeu de massacre
oui d'autant plus que elle ne semble pas
se creuser aujourd'hui par ailleurs en
ce qui me concerne je considère que
regarder pendant que les Français ou
certains Français sont persuadés que le
gouvernement les mêmes vers le gouffre
les deux plus grands journaux européens
le schwiger et vie économiste disent
c'est la France qui se sont le mieux de
cette triple crise sanitaire économique
et énergétique nous sommes les seuls à
ne pas reconnaître un certain nombre de
mini alors la critique est normale mais
en France elle est comme d'habitude
toujours un petit peu plus acerbe
qu'ailleurs vous pourrez répondre une
question et ça donne ou bien de
chanterelles sur ce sur ce point mais
les résultats priorité évidemment filent
dans les Hauts-de-Seine à Nanterre
rejoindre Audrey buttaz un point complet
des résultats dans ce département
et oui on vous avait promis des
surprises dans les Hauts-de-Seine et il
y en a eu et c'est la liste LR de Roger
caoutchi qui ont fait les frais de
sénateurs élus au lieu de 3 actuellement
et même 4 c'est ce qu'il espérait
Philippe mzec et donc éliminé ce soir
c'est la dissidente Marie-Dominique
hlimane la dissidente LR qui est donc
élue ce soir qui fait son entrée au
Sénat et puis c'est une belle soirée
aussi pour les centristes puisque le
président du groupe Union centriste
conserve son siège Hervé Marseille ici
au Sénat et la modem qui était sur sa
liste en deuxième position Isabelle
Floran est elle aussi élue ce soir une
incertitude levée aussi le sénateur
macroniste Xavier yakovelli conserve son
siège il y avait des doutes du fait des
liens distendus entre Emmanuel Macron et
les élus il conservent son siège ce soir
et puis pierre ouzulias fait un siège ce
soir on l'a senti très énervé ce soir
car la deuxième place qui devait revenir
à sa deuxième de position l'écologiste
lui passe sous le nez à rendez-vous
après seulement ce soir pierre
ouzouillas qui s'est dit très énervé
contre la France insoumise qui lui a mis
une liste en face de lui et qui
l'empêche de faire ce soir ce deuxième
siège merci merci beaucoup Audrey pour
ce point complet sur la situation des
Hauts-de-Seine Hauts-de-Seine un bastion
de la droite normalement Dominique
Estrosi saunson est-ce que c'est la
douche froide pour vous de n'avoir que
deux sénateurs élus Roger carotc
Christine Labarde Philippe pepzec donc
ne repart pas pour un nouveau mandat au
Sénat non je serai plus mesurée ce n'est
pas la douche froide nous avions de
trois sénateurs LR sortant
force de constater que nous gardons
trois sénateurs de sortants une
nouvellement élue donc le nombre
elle a toujours fait partie de notre
famille politique son époux et le maire
Daniel qui lui aussi siège et porte
aussi les valeurs de notre famille
politique donc bien sûr que je ne veux
pas présager de ce que fera madame
ashlimane mais il y a fort à parier
qu'elle rejoindra le groupe les
républicains et que nous resterons sur
le même étage comme d'ailleurs à Paris
on a dit regardez à Paris les
républicains alors on peut déplorer bien
évidemment les divisions parce que une
liste unique aurait pu permettre
d'engranger certainement peut-être un
poste supplémentaire mais pour autant
nous gardons quatre sénateurs LR à Paris
également 3 sur la liste officielle et
Madame Agnès evraine vous l'avez signalé
vous-même qui est quand même président
de la fédération
LR sur Paris
Ian chanterelle vous évoquez le
renouvellement de génération
démonstration tout de suite puisque au
micro d'Alexandre poussin on retrouve
Mathilde Olivier la nouvelle benjamine
du Sénat
oui oui Thomas Thomas alors je me trouve
je me trouve en ce moment avec la
nouvelle benjamine du Sénat Mathilde
d'olivier et lui aussi natrice des
Français établies hors de France et puis
derrière moi vous l'avez vu marine
Tondelier qui est la secrétaire
nationale du parti Europe Écologie Les
Verts alors forcément on se félicite
pour les écologistes qui vont gagner des
sièges de sénateurs d'abord une réaction
avec vous Mathilde Olivier qu'est-ce que
vous ressentez à ce moment où vous
entrez à la Haute Assemblée à 29 ans
émue très heureuse et puis pour
l'instant c'est c'est vraiment le début
pour moi ça fait quelques heures
maintenant que que j'ai appris mon
élection donc donc aigu et heureuse
alors parlez-nous de votre parcours d'où
vous venez comment vous en êtes venus à
vous engager en politique et à vous
présenter au sénatorial et ben là
maintenant ça fait 10 ans donc un tiers
de ma vie que j'habite à l'étranger donc
je suis je suis sénatrice maintenant
pour les Françaises et les Français à
établi en France donc c'est là
maintenant ça fait quatre ans que
j'habite à Vienne en Autriche et que je
suis depuis deux ans maintenant
conseillère des Françaises et des
Français établis hors de France donc
pour ma circonscription qui est
l'Autriche la Slovaquie et la Slovénie
donc voilà et je suis originaire de
Bretagne j'ai fini et j'ai grandi à
Rennes et puis j'ai mes attaches dans le
Finistère sur quelle thématique vous
avez envie de travailler ici au Sénat
alors pour moi c'est super important de
représenter les les problématiques des
Françaises et des Français établies hors
de France je pense que ces derniers mois
on a vu toutes les catastrophes qui
climatiques partout dans le monde une
Canada avec les feux de forêts moi dans
ma circonscription en Slovénie avec les
inondations à Hong Kong il y a très peu
il y a peu de temps aussi des des
inondations sans précédent donc c'est
aussi travailler autour de autour autour
de ces problématiques des Françaises et
des Français établir de France et puis
je pense que pour nous en tant que
Français d'étrangers on est aussi témoin
de ces changements climatiques et donc
c'est se faire le relais aussi de notre
fin de
du changement climatique qu'on voit
partout sur la planète maintenant en
quelques mots pour finir vous les
représenter cette génération climat oui
tout à fait je pense que en tant que
jeune femme élu au Sénat je pense que je
serai la plus jeune élue et donc c'est
important pour moi en effet de
représenter la génération climat et
d'avoir aussi une représentation et une
un renouvellement de nos institutions et
je suis très contente que d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts est permis à la fois
le renouvellement enfin le
renouvellement la féminisation de notre
groupe au Sénat merci beaucoup Mathieu
Olivier
merci Alexandre pour pour cette première
réaction de la nouvelle benjamine du
Sénat des résultats c'est évidemment
prioritaire des résultats dans le Nord
si je ne me trompe avec Quentin Calmel
qui qui a les derniers résultats
officiels Quentin oui c'est un
département important le Nord puisque
c'est le deuxième circonscription avec
le plus de sénateurs à élire puisqu'on
compte 11 siège à pourvoir dans le
département et c'est le troisième
sénateur RN qui fait son entrée dans ce
département il s'appelle Joshua Hochard
et donc cela signe et bien trois élus
pour le rassemblement national ce soir
en ces élections c'est natoriales 2023
une bonne performance pour le groupe des
indépendants le groupe de Claude malurey
puisque Dany va te Blade et réélu et
fait même deux sièges et un troisième
sénateur horizon Franck dersin va
rejoindre ce groupe Les Indépendants
donc le Nord qui va comme cela fournir
trois sénateurs pour ce groupe les
indépendants de la droite Macron
compatible le sénateur centriste Olivier
Hainaut et réélu ainsi que et bien un
autre une deuxième centriste
Marc-Philippe de Bresse ne fait qu'un
seul siège et donc et bien Brigitte
l'herbier qui n'est pas réélu on voit
également deux sièges pour les
communistes Eric Bocquet et Michel
gréaume ainsi que deux sièges pour les
socialistes Patrick caner et Audrey
linkenheeld mais donc c'est cette
information cette bonne performance pour
les communistes a priori dans le Nord
avec deux sièges qui devraient pouvoir
permettre d'après les informations du
groupe communiste du Sénat de maintenir
l'existence d'un groupe communiste
puisqu'il faut être 10 sièges de
sénateurs pour avoir un groupe voilà ce
qu'on pouvait dire pour les résultats du
Nord Tam merci merci beaucoup Quentin
pour toutes ces explications il nous
accueillons sur ce plateau les sénateurs
Union centriste de Haute-Savoie Loïc
Hervé bonsoir
Pascal perinaut tout d'abord peut-être
un mot sur les enseignements à nouveau
de ce scrutin notamment là on voit dans
le Nord et bien l'élection
d'un des trois sénateurs rassemblements
national que nous avons pour l'instant
on voit aussi à certaines permanences
notamment le groupe communiste qui
résiste même si bien ça reste un petit
groupe au Sénat
le micro Pascal le micro on voit du côté
du rassemblement national et on le
voyait d'ailleurs dès le début de la
soirée je regardais dans des zones
rurales un département par exemple comme
les Pyrénées-Atlantiques et on voyait
que 10 parfois 14 % des grands électeurs
avaient choisi le ou la candidate du
rassemblement national donc on voit
maintenant que ce corps des grands
électeurs qui était très allergiques au
vote du Front National et du
rassemblement national les de moins en
moins c'est un corps qui est
profondément enraciné dans la France
profonde et donc ça n'est pas tellement
étonnant donc le rassemblement national
et au fond revient au Sénat il avait été
au Sénat simplement c'est un Front
National qui change regardez pour
l'instant trois sénateurs trois
sénateurs Nord Pas de Calais
Seine-et-Marne avant c'était le Var et
les Bouches-du-Rhône c'est à dire c'est
un rassemblement national qui a
profondément changé
c'est un rassemblement national
populaire liée à des terres
industrielles en souffrance à des
grandes banlieues dans lequel en effet
on galère et on voit maintenant la
capacité du rassemblement national a
attiré au niveau de ce corps des grands
électeurs à attiré voilà cette cette
souffrance sociale et on préfère
des départements les plus à gauche de
France toutes les sensibilités de Gauchy
étaient représentées maintenant on en
est loin donc on voit bien que quelque
part la gauche a perdu a perdu le peuple
justement la gauche on se tourne vers un
élu important de cette gauche Patrick
canaire qui est évidemment le président
du groupe socialiste ici au Sénat qui
est avec Samia de chir à Lille
oui dommage je suis avec Patrick canard
vous venez d'être réélu sénateur du Nord
votre liste cependant on avait fait que
deux sièges vous en visiez trois c'est
une victoire mais c'est en même temps
une déception oui c'est toujours une
déception quand un ami n'est pas élu
sénateur et il est vrai que la
dispersion du nombre de listes a été
pour beaucoup d'ailleurs une grande
difficulté et nous avions
malheureusement chez les socialistes une
dissidence qui a fait un nombre de voix
malheureusement les empêchant d'arriver
premier et de nous empêchant d'avoir le
troisième siège je le regrette mais
voilà la vie tournera et je suis
convaincu que Bertrand Ringo sera un
très bon futur je l'espère plus tard
sénateur et je salue Audrey linkennel de
la deuxième de ma livre qui sera qui
était lu ce soir
comment vivez-vous l'élection ici d'un
sénateurs rassemblement national dans le
Nord je la vis très mal comme dans le
Pas-de-Calais lire c'est une élection
qui doit toutes et tous nous interpeller
tous les républicains doivent
aujourd'hui se mobiliser on voit bien
que la vague noire est en train de
progresser y compris dans un département
avec l'histoire qui est la nôtre et bien
que tous les républicains se mobilisent
pour empêcher cela et ça passe aussi par
des politiques publiques au niveau local
mais au niveau national qui fasse que
celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui croient
dans le Front national n'y croit plus
demain est-ce que c'est pas aussi
un petit peu je vous
avais plus de gauche ici en tout dans le
Nord
le mode de calcul de la proportionnel à
la plus forte moyenne autorise ce type
d'élection voilà c'est une
interpellation et qui peut d'ailleurs
nous poser une question sur le mode de
scrutin potentiel et c'est un autre
débat que j'aurai au Sénat en tout
dernier mot sur votre groupe puisque
vous présidez le groupe socialiste au
Sénat des remontées que vous avez
qu'est-ce qui s'annonce une progression
pour vous ou une stabilité alors nous
avons une stabilité puisque a priori
nous avons aujourd'hui 33 élus par
rapport à 33 sortants alors qu'il y
avait 11 sortants qui ne se
représentaient pas donc je suis très
content il nous reste encore des
résultats notamment en outre-mer qui
peuvent nous permettre de d'envisager
une progression légère mais comme tout
le monde progresse y compris chez le
camarade communiste chez les élus Verts
bien peut-être que la barre descendes je
m'étais fixé que nous nous étions fixés
pour être atteinte merci beaucoup
Patrick canner président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat tout juste réélu
sénateur du Nord en direct avec nous
depuis la préfecture à Lille merci
beaucoup Samia de chirur rappelle que
vous êtes avec Olivier Molinari dans le
Nord anne-charles bézina peut-être sur
le le retour de sénateur du
Rassemblement National Marine Le Pen
parlait d'une incongruité politique le
fait qui est pas de représentants ne
sont partis ici alors en effet c'est
vrai que le Sénat ne représente pas la
vie politique de la même façon que
l'Assemblée nationale on a le sentiment
que si incarne moins les personnalités
que les territoires et je rejoins ce qui
a été dit à propos de la progression du
rassemblement national qui finalement
nous montre bien que c'est une
implantation territoriale qui est la
réussite du rassemblement national
aujourd'hui c'est pas tant cette
objectif de dédiabolisation que
l'objectif de territorialisation de ce
parti qui réussit ce soir et on a parlé
notamment pour le groupe horizon pour le
groupe de la majorité de différences de
stratégies et au fond on le voit bien le
Sénat à sa place notamment dans une
représentation très différencier de la
vie politique mais qui est quand même
une véritable représentation nationale
c'est-à-dire que cette entrée du
rassemblement national vient corriger
alors une incongruité peut-être pas
nécessairement une différence en tout
cas du Sénat et prouve aussi que
contrairement à ce que l'on croit le
Sénat sait se renouveler certes les
vagues sont beaucoup moins fortes mais
le rajeunissement l'évolution notamment
on le voit avec des groupes et des
listes qui ne sont pas nécessairement
Unis donc beaucoup de choses dans la vie
politique évoluent et le Sénat
nécessairement par vague aussi évolue
Benjamin moral vous êtes d'accord on
voit là et bien finalement le Sénat qui
suit le mouvement du renouvellement
renouvellement quand même des
générations avec certains aussi partis
qui commencent à s'implanter davantage
et le RN c'est normal aujourd'hui dans
notre pays alors le Sénat c'est une
force de stabilisation cette seconde
chambre elle était construite elle a été
pensée pour produire le temps long en
réalité pour que vous n'ayez pas de choc
politique ou en tout cas qu'elle ne les
enregistre pas si vous avez une
formation politique qui s'inscrit dans
le paysage politique de manière manière
claire pendant 20 ans 30 ans et bien
elle est représentée de façon
conséquente au Sénat si elle est
evanescente et bien elle n'y fait pas
son entrée donc si jamais on a une
incrustation de rassemblance nationale
dans la vie politique locale oui ce qui
est intéressant dans cette élection
c'est pas tant le nombre de sénateurs RN
au fond il y en aura pas beaucoup il y
aura pour pas qu'il y aura pas un groupe
ils seront peut-être trois quatre cinq
mais ce qui est important c'est ce que
disait Pascal tout à l'heure le taux de
conseiller municipaux qui ont voté pour
le RN quand vous avez jusqu'à 10 15% de
conseillers municipaux qui votent dans
certains départements pour le
rassemblement national ça signifie
quelque chose ça signifie que vous avez
un ancrage qui est en train de se faire
ça signifie que pour beaucoup de
conseils municipaux ce qui était tabou
ne les plus aujourd'hui parce que et
bien majoritairement leurs électeurs ont
voté RN et parce que vous avez quand
même eu une implantation des députés la
stratégie de la cravate le fait de et
ben apparaître comme étant un député
faisant le job au niveau local c'est
quelque chose qui un an a pu marquer
justement ce collège électoral et ça et
bien ça veut dire que pour l'avenir
potentiellement des élites locales c'est
potentiellement des élus locaux qui
pourraient et bien représenter de
malrasement national donc c'est plutôt
au-delà des quelques sénateurs élus une
bonne élection pour le rassemblement
national ce soir Loïc Hervé peut-être on
ne vous a pas encore donné la parole
pour une première réaction globale pour
votre famille politique quel bilan vous
faites de cette soirée alors vous savez
que l'ensemble des obédiens centristes
sont dans un groupe unique au Sénat qui
est le groupe Union centriste qui est la
deuxième
jambe de la majorité sénatoriale et 57
sénateurs donc une une croissance de ce
groupe de manière linéaire depuis
maintenant près d'une quinzaine d'années
qui va continuer ceci et qui en tout cas
avec une stabilité probable de de notre
effectif peut-être quelques quelques
gains et ça on ne le saura pas tout de
suite puisque ça dépendra de la
signature de chaque sénatrice chaque
sénateur au moment de l'inscription dans
son groupe donc ça ça va être
intéressant notamment chez nos nos amis
d'horizons de voir s'ils vont dans un
groupe proprement dit ou s'il souhaite
intégrer la majorité sénatoriale on a
des regrouper mais déjà des
inter-orisants dans notre groupe par
exemple donc ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est important et qui et qui en
fait est personnel ça n'est pas du tout
une démarche partisane il y a personne
ici qui va dire un sénateur là où il
doit aller siéger et même dans les
groupes vous avez vous savez où vous
avez plusieurs possibilités en étant
membre complet rattachés à parenté il y
a plusieurs il y a des nuances on verra
ça au moment de l'élection du président
du Sénat à peu près en début de semaine
non pas au début de semaine cette
semaine la semaine d'après pour savoir
exactement ce qu'il en est du groupe du
groupe UC ce qui est intéressant aussi à
voir c'est les scores de nos sortants
qui sont des scores élevés donc là y
compris dans la première série c'est à
ceux qui ont été élus au premier tour
dans ces départements où il y a au
scrutin majoritaire où il y a un ou deux
sénateurs et là on a des 60-70 près de
80% de de pour certains collègues donc
c'est vraiment que là il y a eu une
plébiscite pour ces natrices aussi la
capacité du groupe avec à la fois des
personnes qui peuvent être proches de la
macronie d'autres qui sont au contraire
vraiment dans le dans l'opposition vous
assumez toujours cet aspect aussi
baroque alors que vous êtes l'une des
gens que vous l'avez dit de la majorité
sénatoriale quand vous prenez la clé de
lecture de l'Assemblée nationale ici
c'est pas baroque du tout puisque la
majorité sénatoriale qui est présidée
par le président du Sénat à l'archet les
deux présidents de groupe Bruno
Retailleau Hervé Marseille gère l'un
comme l'autre leur groupe et leur
diversité dans Dominique qui a aussi au
sein du groupe Bel-Air il y a aussi au
sein du groupe l a des diversités et le
président Marseille va gérer ses
diversités là encore une fois les
sénateurs qui adhérents au groupe Union
centriste adhérents à la majorité
sénatoriale qui soutient le président du
Sénat donc il y a pas d'ambiguïté là
évidemment ils peuvent avoir eux-mêmes
des options qui sont plus proches de la
majorité présidentielle mais
cette logique là n'existe
pas ici elle était elle est extérieure
ça donne aussi à ce groupe le micro
l'Union centriste un rôle pivot qui
l'avait déjà avant qui va continuer de
conserver tout à fait rien ne peut se
faire sans les centristes dans cette
assemblée ça n'est pas complètement
nouveau quand vous regardez l'histoire
voilà la longue histoire de
l'institution c'est une une assemblée
qui respire l'équilibre et le point
d'équilibre de la vie politique ça reste
entre la droite et la gauche en effet le
centre donc ça n'est pas du tout
étonnant et en plus de ça il y a un
président du Sénat qui a beaucoup joué
qui n'a pas clivé si les gens l'archet
n'a jamais cherché à cliver il y aurait
pu avoir quelqu'un
issu par exemple de LR qui clique
davantage lui ça n'a jamais été sa
stratégie donc il est au cœur du
dispositif dans lequel en effet les
centriste joue un rôle parce que au-delà
de l'Union centriste quand vous prenez
le groupe du R quand vous prenez le
groupe que dirige Claude malurey vous
avez aussi j'allais dire toute une série
de centrist donc les centrices c'est
encore beaucoup plus que l'Union
centriste qui reste le premier groupe
dans cette qui représente cette mouvance
mais qui est très importante si vous
voulez dans le pays le pays souffre des
clivages des affrontements
la mesure de la gravité de la crise
migratoire qui est devant nous voilà on
est toujours dans une forme
d'immobilisme et d'impuissance du en
même temps
parce que vous vous êtes prêts à des
compromis nous n'aurons aucun compromis
dans la mesure où il y a un message de
régularisation des clandestins face à la
gravité de la situation on ne peut pas
envoyer ce message de faiblesse à ceux
qui veulent faire de notre pays une
terre d'émigration nous ne pouvons pas
accepter que les passeurs et gain de
cause parce que si demain nous disons
que ceux qui arrivent clandestinement
vont être et que ce n'est qu'une
question de délai régularisé on va
accélérer les flux qui sont déjà massifs
donc pour nous nous refusons nous leur
disons très clairement très clairement
une partie de la déclaration d'Eric
sciotique qui réagissait aux propos
d'Emmanuel Macron qui était invité chez
nos confrères de TF1 et France 2 qui
disait à propos des migrants que la
France fait sa part évidemment et
réagissait aux nombreux discours du Pape
François lors rencontres méditerranéenne
à Marseille on peut tient lancer cette
thématique de l'immigration Dominique et
choisis ça sonne parce que ça va être un
des textes sur lequel les vous nous
parliez toutes les nuances
centrisme mais on peut aussi parler des
nuances chez elle ou dans d'autres
parties là on va compter les voix et ça
va être un texte assez important dans
les prochaines semaines pour savoir
comment différentes majorité ce
construisent qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez oui ça va être un texte
éminemment important qui aurait dû déjà
arriver en discussion depuis un certain
nombre de semaines sur lequel oui sur
lequel la majorité sénatoriale a déjà
largement travaillé puisque le texte
était pratiquement fin prêt au vu de
l'ordre du jour qui était annoncé tout
cela a été reculé on nous dit que le
Sénat effectivement devrait être saisi
en premier au début du mois de novembre
ça sera voilà ça sera certainement un
texte sur lequel il nous faut encore
travailler travailler au sein de la
majorité sénatoriale avec bien
évidemment le respect
la conviction et de l'ADN de chacun des
groupes j'avoue que ça sera pas facile
mais je crois que ce que nous
recherchons d'abord et avant tout c'est
de pouvoir composer de pouvoir discuter
de pouvoir négocier avec les centristes
de façon à ce que nous arrivions à un
texte qui soit utile pour le pays tout à
fait clair il y a un vrai sujet de
position dans la majorité entre LR et
centrices ce sujet c'est la question de
la régularisation des étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui occupent un
métier en tension le i carvé donc ça va
être aussi une façon d'éprouver la
cohérence de votre majorité il y a deux
sujets il y a le sujet on va dire de des
sujets migratoires et de la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine en tant que
telle
texte plutôt partie de texte plutôt
porté par Gérald Darmanin et une autre
partie qui touche plus ou qui sont de
ressources humaines de marché du travail
où nous savons et moi j'ai de la
Haute-Savoie mais je sais qu'il y a
d'autres territoires et ils s'y
représentent qui peuvent mais le même
problème nous avons des métiers qui sont
en extrême tension j'ai participé aux
universités du Medef à la fin du mois
d'août je peux vous assurer que cette
préoccupation des caisses la question
des recrutements et et fondamental je
comprends la réticence de certains
je la comprends je la comprends au sens
où le risque c'est le message envoyé
l'appel d'air ça j'entends en revanche
dans un pays dans lequel dans
l'hôtellerie restauration le bâtiment
l'industrie la santé aujourd'hui il y a
des postes qui ne sont pas pourvus et un
certain nombre de postes qui sont
occupés parfois par des personnes qui ne
sont plus à jour de leur de leur titre
ça pose une autre difficulté donc il
faut qu'on arrive à trouver un compromis
entre ces deux entre ces deux lignes de
tension
et ça nous avec le groupe
UC avec nos collègues de la majorité
assez naturel évidemment nous sommes
prêts à engager ce débat qui est
essentiel il y aura pas de réformes sur
le Sénat faut bien clair là-dessus c'est
pas possible un mot rapide vient de
chanterelles sur ce sur ce débat à venir
vous vous créez que finalement
l'équilibre initial du texte soit
abandonné oui bah en même temps le texte
initial n'est pas très équilibré
contrairement à ce qu'on pense il y a
une petite mesure est là qui est la
régularisation pour les métiers en
tension mais quand vous regardez
globalement le texte un texte très à
droite démagogique qui fait la chasse
aux immigrés clairement nous on est pour
la régularisation des métiers en tension
même de tous les travailleurs pour
certains d'entre nous moi j'en fais
partie parce que c'est une réalité aussi
démographique de notre pays vous verrez
si nous avons ce discours démagogique de
monsieur scioti qui ne parle que
d'immigration matin midi et soir il dit
que nous sommes pas une terre d'immigrés
mais c'est un rigolo lui-même il est il
est il vient d'où il est issu d'une
famille d'immigrés il est descendant
d'immigré bien sûr que la France est une
terre d'immigrations et je peux vous
dire quand on va voir même nos
compatriotes où les grands électeurs
nous parlent pas du sujet de
l'immigration et pourtant c'est martelé
matin midi et soir dans les médias leur
sujet de préoccupation c'est le pouvoir
d'achat c'est la désertification
médicale c'est les sujets de santé
sceléducation ça n'est pas l'immigration
ça n'est pas ce qu'on essaye de nous
seriner en permanence mais en tout cas
on combattra ce texte vous garantir avec
toutes les bandes
décentristes on va continuer parce qu'on
vous promet dans dans une minute on vous
promet un autre débat politique avec des
présidents de de groupe ici au Sénat
président et présidente de groupe mais
d'abord en rejoint Quentin calmé merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
rejoint Quentin calmé pour un point
complet des résultats Quentin oui tout à
fait Thomas l'enseignement de cette
soirée c'est la relative stabilité de la
majorité ici au Sénat ce soir avec ces
élections sénatoriales la droite et le
centre qui devrait conserver une
majorité absolue ce soir mais c'est une
information importante l'arrivée le
retour plutôt au Sénat d'élus du RA
nationale il devrait y avoir au moins
trois sénateurs du rassemblement
national dans les départements du nord
du Pas-de-Calais de la Seine-et-Marne
d'ailleurs on va le voir s'afficher sur
notre écran c'est l'une des
personnalités qui fait son entrée
aujourd'hui qui était lui qui s'appelle
Christopher Zurich et donc l'un des
sénateurs l'un des trois sénateurs du
rassemblement national qui rentre à la
Chambre haute ce soir on le voit aussi
une bonne performance relativement bonne
performance de la gauche sénatoriale
Patrick Kanner est ainsi réélu dans le
département du Nord et également une
proche d'Olivier Faure Corinne narratiga
en Seine-Saint-Denis qui fait même élire
une deuxième personnalité socialiste sur
sa liste Corinne rassigen qui est proche
d'Olivier Faure et donc ce soir le
groupe socialiste qui se réjouit de
pouvoir conserver une forme de stabilité
au sein de la chambre haute du parlement
on verra très précisément à la fin de la
soirée électorale si ce groupe
socialiste engrange des sièges avec
effectivement effectivement les
résultats notamment des autres mers on
continue avec les écologistes car dans
l'Isère leur chef de fil Guillaume
Gontard et réélu aujourd'hui Guillaume
Gontard élu dans l'Isère et le groupe
écologiste qui se réjouit de voir son
groupe passé de 12 à 16 sièges c'est sur
cette projection que et bien les
écologistes du Sénat table et je voulais
terminer en mentionnant les résultats de
la Moselle un département important qui
réélit 5 sièges de sénateurs et une
bonne performance pour la droite et le
centre au Sénat puisque on voit
Jean-Marie maison l'Union centriste être
réélu ainsi que Catherine bertrichti DLR
qui est également est élu et avec une
troisième personnalité sur leur liste et
qui est également élue monsieur Khalifé
Khalifé et également on voit qu'un
socialiste est élu Michael Weber qui
remplacera l'ancien ministre socialiste
Jean-Marc dechigny quand à Christine
Herzog qui était seconde sur la liste de
Monsieur Jean-Louis Masson elle est
réélu voilà ce que l'on pouvait vous
dire un peu sur les grandes lignes de
tous les résultats que l'on a obtenus
pour ces élections sénatoriales 2023 et
on verra maintenant à la suite des
résultats Thomas pour ces sénateurs
merci beaucoup Quentin et pardon j'étais
en train de faire signer un photographe
qui faisait des photos en direct que on
allait reprendre l'antenne d'où ce geste
qui n'était pas très sympathique
un débat comme promis entre président et
présidente de groupe ici au sénage
accueil Bruno Retailleau bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes président du groupe
LR au Sénat et sénateur de la Vendée
également avec Noël
présidente du groupe communiste au Sénat
et sénatrice de la Seine-Saint-Denis
encore quelques jours jusqu'au 1er
octobre merci bonsoir bonsoir ou
François Patriot bonsoir bonsoir
président du groupe Renaissance et
sénateurs de la Côte-d'Or et enfin sur
ce plateau nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir Hervé Marseille président
du groupe Union centriste président de
l'UDA et vous venez d'être réélu dans
votre département des Hauts-de-Seine
félicitations merci bienvenue à vous
tous Bruno retaille ou parlait d'une
majorité sénatoriale confortée qu'est-ce
qui vous fait employer cette cette
expression on va dire plutôt optimiste
tout simplement parce que demain lorsque
le Sénat va se réinstaller c'est la
majorité sénatoriale qui sera l'axe
principal du Sénat cette majorité
sénatoriale elle est composée du premier
groupe parlementaire que je préside
c'est LR et nos amis sont tristes voilà
et on va retrouver une stabilité
vous perdez quand même quelques
sénateurs et tout à l'heure dominicaines
trois ou quatre sénateurs et ça n'est
pas encore définitif on en gagne dans la
on en gagne en Isère donc je trouve que
c'est plutôt une performance dans les
temps politiques qui courent qui sont
marqués par l'instabilité au contraire
d'avoir cette forme de stabilité et je
pense justement que beaucoup de grands
électeurs apprécient le travail du Sénat
vous savez lorsque j'ai été élu pour la
première fois président de groupe en
2014 je ne pouvais pas faire un plateau
radio ou télévision sans qu'on ne
commence traditionnellement vos
confrères me poser toujours mais à quoi
ça sert le Sénat aujourd'hui quand je
suis invité sur un plateau j'ai jamais
une seule question sur l'utilité du
Sénat parce que le Sénat c'est imposé
dans le débat public je pense que le
Sénat face à cette assemblée qui est
souvent hystérisée c'est un pôle de
stabilité c'est la fonction du Sénat et
c'est aussi la voie des territoires et
je pense que avec un pouvoir qui est
souvent très recentralisateur bien je
pense que les îles du locaux veulent
aussi donner à la majorité sénatoriale
une voix pour que s'exprime justement
cette volonté d'une meilleure
répartition des pouvoirs sur le
territoire vous parler de la majorité de
la droite et du centre je me penche vers
her
vé aujourd'hui 57 sénateurs dans votre
groupe est-ce que vous visez la
stabilité ou des gains pour cette
élection
quand on se présente à des élections en
général on espère toujours avoir plus
mais alors à cette heure-ci
on est bien d'accord autant ça peut
arriver non ça peut arriver
l'un des exemples mais autrement à cette
heure-ci moi je suis très satisfait des
résultats d'abord parce que on sait
depuis les dernières élections
municipales qu'en termes de projection
on pouvait imaginer
une forme de stabilité comme vient de le
dire Bruno Retailleau bon je pense que
nous allons enrichir le groupe de
plusieurs membres et que on devrait
atteindre la soixantaine de membres et
certainement un peu plus bon
oui parce que tout ça il y a deux
élections en fait vous avez l'élection
des sénateurs qui est une chose et puis
ensuite il y a le chemin qui les mène au
Sénat et sur le chemin qui les mène au
Sénat il y a toutes sortes de tentations
et
on les emmène dans des boutiques ici ou
là pour leur prédire un avenir radieux
en fonction des choix qui vont faire
[Musique]
la boutique Union centriste dans la
boutique
il y a des promotions et donc vous
n'êtes pas encore tout à fait sûr de pas
encore venir dans le groupe Union
centrée ce qui est évident c'est qu'il y
a une stabilité et que à l'évidence on
va gagner quelques quelques sièges qui
va effectivement asseoir davantage
encore la majorité au Sénat et qui va
aussi enrichir la diversité parce que
les sénateurs qui sont élus sont pas
uniformes on embrigade pas les
consciences ni leur façon de voter on
est dans un groupe chez nous où le vote
est libre et donc faut convaincre tout
le monde à chaque fois
c'est ce que vous nous dites
non c'est pas la référence c'est ça je
veux dire parce que c'est ce qui peut
être difficilement compréhensible pour
certains qui ne sont pas férus de du
fonctionnement du Sénat c'est à dire
qu'on peut être à la fois membre de la
majorité sénatoriale et de la majorité
présidentielle
assassin l'enjeu ce soir pour pour le
parti communiste pour le groupe commis
c'était de rester un groupe
est-ce que vous avez atteint cet
objectif même si vous perdez les
sénateurs non on l'a atteint mais on a
dépassé cet objectif puisque à l'heure
où je vous parle nous serions 17
sénatrices et sénateurs membres de mon
groupe donc un groupe renforcé avec de
nouveaux élus j'entendais tout à l'heure
sur le plateau dire que le groupe
communiste finirait à 10 dans des
plaises à ces personnes nous finirons
certainement assurément à 17 et
peut-être à 18 donc je suis fier de de
ce gain de sénatrice et des sénateurs
qui siègeront au sein de mon groupe même
si je ne serai plus là la gauche la
gauche sénatoriale va sortir renforcer
de ce scrutin et je ne peux que m'en
féliciter parce que dans ce pays
aujourd'hui les Françaises et les
Français ont besoin d'une gauche qui non
seulement s'oppose au projet du
gouvernement voir au projet porter par
nos de la droite mais surtout qui
propose des alternatives et je crois que
c'est ce que nous avons fait durant ces
dernières années et je crois que c'est
ce qui a fait que des grands électrices
et des grandes électrices et des grands
électeurs ont fait le choix de voter
pour nos candidats de la France
insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
ce que c'est ce que j'entends mais c'est
ce que j'entends dans votre sujet c'est
pas mon sujet la stratégie de des
parties de gauche ici au Sénat de ne pas
faire de place à les filles
alors là je m'oppose à ce à ses propos
puisque j'ai fait partie de celles et
ceux qui ont discuté avec la France
insoumise il n'y a pas eu de rupture
avec la France insoumise il n'y a pas eu
de suite donné à des à des discussions
mais la question n'était pas de rentrer
dans une opposition moi mon ma stratégie
c'était de faire en sorte que la gauche
sorte renforcée de ce scrutin et que
particulièrement mon groupe sorte
renforcé de ce scrutin après n'allait
pas chercher des discussions ou des
tactiques qui auraient fait que non
voilà je crois que le travail de mon
groupe le travail de chaque sénatrice et
de chaque sénateur communiste
républicain citoyens écologiste ces
dernières années a montré l'utilité
d'avoir ces élus au sein d'une assemblée
comme le Sénat avec donc une majorité de
droite
je crois que on a montré notre capacité
justement à ne pas simplement ce que je
disais tout à l'heure à ne pas
simplement s'opposer mais à aller vers
des propositions alternatives et je
crois que en ce sens les élus et les
grandes électricités les grandes
électeurs ont entendu ce message une
information importante à celle de la
réélection de Gérard Larcher le
président du Sénat et donc réélu dans
les Yvelines ce n'était pas une surprise
mais c'était officiel il est réélu donc
pour la 5ème fois cinquième mandat de
sénateur François Patriat même question
dans quel état sort votre groupe est-ce
que vous passez une soirée compliquée
aujourd'hui d'abord je rappelle que la
situation du Sénat qu'on avait évoqué
avant c'est une grande stabilité avec
quelques sièges qui vont changer
quelques roues vont gagner quelques-uns
d'autres vont en perdre quelques-uns
pour ce qui concerne notre groupe le
challenge était difficile pour deux
raisons
et dans la campagne c'était contre tous
nous avions à la fois la gauche et la
droite contre nous espérons bien gagner
des sièges sur le dos de la majorité sur
le dos de renaissance qu'en est-il au
bout au bout au bout du compte vous avez
prévu beaucoup beaucoup d'effets que je
constate c'est que quatre ne se
représentaient pas sur les quatre qui se
représentés pour aujourd'hui nous
pensons sauver peut-être un ou deux
sièges de remplacement et que pour ce
qui concerne les sièges en métropole
nous avons aujourd'hui perdu trois
sénateurs à la Richard d'une voix une
voix il y a quand même par exemple de 8
voix une voix huit vois et quand même
c'était très chaud et puis Frédéric
marchand je regrette bien entendu et je
le rends hommage pour les campagnes
qu'ils ont menées mais dans le même
temps nous en gagnant
de la secrétaire d'État Sonia baquet
secrétaire d'État la citoyenneté c'est
la première le premier échec que l'on a
appris aujourd'hui un membre du
gouvernement elle peut encore rester
membre du gouvernement malgré cet échec
elle
Elisabeth Band qui décideront ce n'est
pas moi qui peut aujourd'hui cela je
pense que Sony abacaisse est une bonne
ministre qu'elle a fait un gros travail
sur le terrain mais quand Nouvelle
Calédonie vous connaissez les jeux des
parties des appartenants de ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui loyaux de ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui indépendantistes c'est
compliqué là-bas j'espérais je
souhaitais qu'elle soit élu je le
pensais même c'est pour nous c'est vrai
une grande désillusion je ne pensais
pour elle ce soir mais dans le même
temps
j'ai évoqué que nous en perdions 3 nous
allons en gagner seulement deux ou trois
donc je pense que le groupe
contrairement à ce que nous a prédit ne
descendra pas demain au dessous de 20 je
pense que c'est une belle résistance
dans le contexte que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui le contexte politique dans
le contexte qui est évoqué aujourd'hui
dans l'environnement après tout ce soir
je peux dire que je respire un peu et
que dans le même temps je voudrais
féliciter mes amis qui ont été élu dans
des conditions très difficiles parfois à
quelques voix ils ont mené des combats
héroïques avec un groupe on va dire
affilié au parti horizon qui va voir
peut-être son son audience progressée
ici au Sénat est-ce que c'est un match
quelle est votre analyse
un petit peu mais je comprends
je pense qu'il est optimiste de nature
et peut-être même de et peut-être même
de volonté non je pense que la France
traverse une crise démocratique je le
dis je pense que le Sénat dans cette
crise démocratique et là je voudrais
parler de façon transpartisanale le
Sénat a montré son sens de la
responsabilité on a eu des discussions
difficiles je pense aux retraites ou on
était opposés mais jamais il y a eu
débordement jamais il les invictive les
injures qui a pu avoir l'Assemblée
nationale je vais livrer un chiffre que
on m'a confié et que peut savent c'est
une statistique je crois que la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale en
une seule année
amis je crois en sanction individuelle
pour des députés qui a fait vivre des
écarts de 98 le Sénat depuis 1958 depuis
le début de la cinquième république 6
sanctions je crois que la hauteur de nos
débats le respect que nous avons en
dehors de nos différences
mais il y a un respect et quand on débat
on ne s'en prend pas aux uns ou aux
autres on essaie d'argumenter et ça
c'est ça la beauté de la politique et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui le Sénat c'est
beaucoup de Français comme je le disais
tout à l'heure en introduction
considère que le Sénat a toute sa place
c'est aussi à cause de cela et il y a
assassy ça se voit aussi dans les
commissions d'enquête dans l'émission
enfin elles sont d'ailleurs qu'aux
présidées par vous en avez présidé
certaines par des forces politiques qui
s'opposent
ça ça répond à une demande d'une partie
de l'opinion française générale où vous
bénéficiez effectivement de l'effet
miroir de l'Assemblée nationale quand
vous voilà démontrer cette capacités à
travailler ensemble
en tout cas
cas pour des travaux on ne réfléchit pas
à ce fameux effet miroir qui pourrait
exister nous faisons ce que nous avons à
faire et nous essayons de le faire au
mieux et quand nous sommes dans des
commissions d'enquêtes effectivement
avec des binômes un sénateur les
républicains et en l'occurrence une
sénatrice communiste comme ça pour les
cabinets de conseils
mais comme ça a été le cas aussi sur la
pénurie des médicaments avec avec
Laurence Cohen et une une présidente qui
était membre du grand du groupe santé
nous essayons de travailler l'intérêt
général et non pas les intérêts
partisans moi je le dis souvent sur les
cabinets conseils j'aurais pu aller plus
loin comme communisme mais je me suis
tenu à au périmètre que nous nous étions
fixés ensemble et il fallait respecter
ce ce périmètre mais là où je rejoins un
peu les propos qui ont été évoqués
reprenons la sur les conséquences de ces
élections sénatoriales je pense que la
réforme des retraites et la bataille
contre la réforme des retraites en tout
cas pour ce qui nous concerne contre la
réforme des retraites a marqué aussi les
esprits chez les grandes électricités et
les grandes électeurs qui ne sont pas
que des élus mais je crois que la façon
dont nous avons su mener la cette
bataille ici au Sénat et je ne parle pas
c'est pas mon sujet de l'Assemblée
nationale mais la façon dont nous
l'avons mené ici avec sérieux rigueur
respect en faisant œuvre de proposition
et pas simplement être dans l'opposition
à une réforme à nous a permis de marquer
des points et je pense que c'est
effectivement ça comment dire la marque
de fabrique aussi du du Sénat c'est une
chambre qui compte c'est une chambre qui
compte dans nos institutions et qui a
cette capacité à être quelque part un
contre-pouvoir et je pense que c'est
effectivement très important pour une
démocratie est-ce que vous considérez
aujourd'hui que la majorité sénatoriale
François et du côté du contre-pouvoir
comme le dit Eliana ceci ou est-ce que
ça peut être aussi un partenaire on l'a
vu par exemple sur la réforme des
retraites ou et bien pour le coup le
gouvernement et la majorité signatariale
étaient sur la même ligne est-ce que ça
ça peut se reproduire je redis ce que
dit le président du Sénat prenant Gérard
lacher dit nous sommes le position les
choses soient claires républicains les
centristes dans leur majorité sont dans
l'opposition au gouvernement les
communistes et les socialistes le sont
aussi ce que je pense c'est que nous
allons continuer à reproduire ce que
nous avons fait par le passé c'est à
dire continuer à dialoguer faire
d'ouverture pour faire en sorte de
trouver des majorités tantôt avec la
droite tantôt avec la gauche on l'a vu
sur les retraites on l'a vu par la
version l'environnement ou sur
l'industrie on l'a vu sur l'économie
verte on l'a vu donc on peut trouver
avec eux des majorités sur lequel le
Sénat se retrouve vous pensez sur le sur
la loi immigration c'est le prochain
grand texte qui va arriver ici
on verra quel sera le texte définit
ivement je on verra bien ce que seront
les sujets qui sont des lignes rouges
moi je ne désespère pas qu'il y a une
majorité au Sénat sur un texte produit
par Gérald Darmanin
sur cette même question de de la future
loi immigration ça va peut-être pas être
si facile de trouver
tous les points de convergence entre LR
et les centrist
à l'évidence il y a des différences mais
enfin l'essentiel du texte est passé en
commission des lois il y a déjà
plusieurs mois au Sénat bon il a été
examiné et
90% ou 95 % du texte a été adopté après
il y a des différences et chacun les
assume et on travaille à les réduire je
crois que ce qui a été dit c'est quand
même la marque du dialogue et surtout le
fait que le Sénat pour les raisons qui
ont été indiquées par les uns et les
autres et devenu le point d'équilibre
des institutions parlementaires il n'y a
pas de majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
et donc le Sénat a une majorité qui
permet de dialoguer et donc de trouver
des compromis et d'avancer donc on va
continuer parce que derrière tout ça
qu'est-ce qu'il y a il y a quand même la
nécessité de répondre aux Français aux
Françaises c'est pas le problème de
savoir si on est d'accord pas d'accord
s'il y a des chicayas le problème c'est
savoir si on apporte des réponses aux
attentes de nos concitoyens donc le
gouvernement met des textes sur la table
on les discute bon à nous de trouver des
compromis j’ajoute que grâce à la
majorité qui se dégage aussi à la
commission mixte paritaire le
gouvernement cherche toujours le
dialogue et le compromis afin de trouver
des solutions quoi qu'il en coûte
j'allais dire à la commission mixte
paritaire parce que retourner à
l'Assemblée nationale ce n'est pas une
sinécure donc j'allais dire que sa force
au dialogue sa force mais il faut
abandonner le volet métier en tension
dans ce texte est-ce que c'est votre
ligne rouge aussi
alors une fois qu'on a dit que tout le
monde avait des lignes rouges il faut
bien trouver une solution pour dépasser
la ligne donc sinon bon il y a plus de
texte et donc ou alors il y en aurait un
il sera voté je sais pas comment à
l'Assemblée donc
je crois qu'on peut trouver des
solutions
de réécriture de l'article 3
et puis avec du réglementaire parce que
dans cette loi il y a quand même
beaucoup d'écriture qui aurait pu être
réglementaires bon il y a une volonté de
l'exécutif pour des raisons évidentes et
politiques c'est comme ça mais je veux
dire on peut faire du règlementaire ça
peut être une des solutions qui a
d'ailleurs déjà été évoquée au moment de
l'examen du texte il y a plusieurs mois
il je viens de réécrire cet article 3
Bruno retaille pour que la ligne rouge
passe à l'oranger avant de venir sur le
plateau et pas pour faire plaisir à
François Patriat j'ai écouté
attentivement
email Macron
déjà une première réflexion je sais pas
jusqu'à jusqu'où elle ira sur la fameuse
article 3 puisque son développement
était le suivant c'est exactement
l'argument que nous avons développé
depuis le départ pour écarter cet
article 3 les Betty en tension qui
régulariseraient massivement sur ces
métiers là des clandestins prime à la
fraude il a dit mais attendez il y a
quelque chose qui n'aurait pas de sens
c'est si c'est clandestins prenait
régulariser prenait le travail d'un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes qui
sont aujourd'hui au chômage ouais c'est
etc
vous comprenez ça je me méfie toujours
de la même temps mais il y a un bouger
je veux maintenant je veux savoir
exactement quel sera le texte mais il
est clair que aujourd'hui ce qui nous
heurte et c'est une question à la fois
de principe c'est à dire que on ne veut
pas régulariser massivement des
clandestins parce que nous considérons
que c'est une prime à la fraude c'est à
dire d'être entré sur le territoire
illégalement et ensuite on pense qu'il y
a une abdication c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
500 000 étrangers qui sont régulièrement
inscrits au chômage ils sont sans emploi
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait on a un million
400000 jeunes qui ne sont ni en emploi
ni en stage ni à l'école et je dirais et
enfin je vois bien qui peut y avoir
certains patrons j'espère qu'ils sont
minoritaires qui voudraient exercer une
baisse une pression à la baisse des
salaires
ça ça marche pas ça ça ne marche pas et
bien assassin votre avis sur ce point
particulier et peut-être aussi une
réaction aux propos d'Emmanuel Macron
que qui disait chez nos confrères de TF1
et France 2 la France fait sa part sur
l'accueil des migrants excusez-moi de le
dire de cette façon là mais le président
de la République aurait dû écouter le
pape
c'était une question sur le pape et sur
ce qu'a dit le Pape exactement et le
Pape a dit des paroles sensées sur les
migrants et il me semble que toute la
classe politique devrait être attentive
moi qui ne suis pas croyante mais être
attentive à ce qu'il a pu dire hier à
Marseille personnellement et c'est un
combat que je mène depuis longtemps je
suis pour la régularisation de tous les
sans-papiers et pas simplement les
travailleurs qui les étrangers qui
travaillent dans des métiers en tension
une seconde on écoute Yannick Jadot qui
est en direct
en puissance de notre implantation dans
France et sur le territoire parisien
l'Union a été gagnante à Paris
incontestablement et en fait elle se
renforce avec la montée des écologistes
donc on est là au Sénat avec
les Françaises et les Français de
l'étranger Mathilde et puis d'autres qui
vont nous rejoindre pas forcément ce
soir mais dès mardi pour le pour nos
premières réunions de groupe à Paris
vous avez été élu dans une alliance avec
les socialistes et les communistes sont
les insoumis est-ce que c'est un pied de
nez qui est fait à la nupestres et à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon non c'est une union
qui a cherché à être efficace elle est
efficace puisque nous avons huit élus
trois écologistes encore une fois c'est
historique donc il y a deux pieds nés à
personne sinon à la droite parisienne
le match à Paris c'est 8 4 8 4 en faveur
de la gauche et des écologistes c'est ça
la victoire à Paris on dit que vous
venez au Sénat à Paris avec des
arrière-pensées en vue des municipales
de 2026 est-ce que vous y pensez vous
savez alors le scrutin sénatorial
c'est vrai que les Françaises et les
Français ne le comprennent pas bien
nous-mêmes parfois on a eu du mal mais
le scrutin sénatorial c'est fait pour
élire des sénatrices et des sénateurs
donc je suis très heureux d'être
sénateur ce soir
vous arrivez dans une institution de
certains Français connaissent mal à
leurs yeux peuvent paraître parfois
poussiéreux
ancienne qu'est-ce que vous leur dit
pourquoi vous êtes venus au CNF
finalement moi je suis venu au Sénat
parce que après m'être battu pendant 14
ans au Parlement européen pour arracher
des règles en européennes sur le climat
sur la pollution de l'air sur les
espèces protégées sur les énergies
renouvelables efficacées sur beaucoup de
choses la France est particulièrement
rotin la France n'applique pas le droit
européen donc moi je vais être au Sénat
pour à la fois porter tout le projet
écologiste sur l'immigration sur la
décentralisation sur la proportionnelle
mais faire en sorte que la France soit
la hauteur du défi écologique vous avez
écouté comme moi le président de la
République il continue à être dans le
déni de l'urgence de l'action climatique
et bien les écologistes au Sénat comme
les écologistes à l'Assemblée comme les
écologistes au Parlement européen dans
nos villes et puis le parti écologiste
et ben nous allons rappeler que c'est
urgence ça peut être un magnifique
magnifique opportunité pour le social
pour l'industrie
de Paris l'ex-candidat malheureux à la
présidentielle votre réaction à cette
poussée des écologistes François Patriat
au Cénac qui passe donc à 16
parlementaires alors qu'ils n'étaient
que 12 ça montre aussi l'implantation
des écologistes dans le territoire
au vu des résultats des municipales
mécaniquement vu les villes qu'ils ont
gagné vu ce qu'ils ont gagné puisque
vous savez que les élections
sénatoriales n'est que la résultante des
municipales et là je pensais qu'il
pouvait en gagner 6 7 8 4 bon c'est bien
ils ont progressé un peu dans le secteur
peut je sais pas si ce sera chez
définitif mais c'est une progression qui
est légitime normale au vu mathématiques
au vu des élections municipales voilà et
l'avenue Janick Jadot c'est ça fait un
grand tribun supplémentaire qui va
relever au niveau avec d'autres le
niveau du Sénat on est tous fiers ici de
d'avoir une assemblée qui est
respectueuse qui est concrète qui s'est
montré ce qui est la démocratie est
débarras républicains il en fera partie
les liens assassin c'est difficile de
faire progresser les les idées
écologistes au Sénat
oui mais je crois que c'est un petit peu
vrai un petit peu vrai partout
moi je suis une écologiste depuis de
longue de longue années je crois que
c'est un train sec à notre engagement de
de communiste après il y a effectivement
une certaine originalité puis je crois
que dans le pays les gens ont pris
conscience effectivement de la question
environnementale de la question
écologique et il faut il faut il est
nécessaire que chacune et chacun enfin
chaque force politique s'empare de ces
sujets qui sont des sujets transverses
voilà et après voilà quoi qu'il y ait un
groupe écologiste de gauche parce qu'il
faut le préciser quand même ça un groupe
écologiste de gauche je ne peux que que
mon féliciter bien évidemment pour une
Retailleau tout à l'heure Emmanuel
Macron que vous avez écouté
attentivement a également annoncé
renoncé à ce projet de loi qui devait
permettre la revente à perte du
carburant quel est votre réaction ce
texte qui devait et bien sans doute
occuper un petit peu du mois d'octobre
pour les parlementaires écoutez j'avais
été un des premiers lorsque j'ai
découvert l'interview de la première
ministre dans un journal du matin un
journal parisien du matin j'avais été un
des premiers à indiquer que c'était une
idée qui était une fausse bonne idée
pour deux raisons d'abord que parce
qu'on allait tuer les petits c'est à
dire les près de 6000 stations essence
qui sont dans la prospérer dans la
France rurale et que en plus pour les
grands distributeurs ce qu'ils allaient
perdre à la pompe il le gagnera la
caisse donc bien entendu je n'ai pas
compris très franchement ça montre que
le gouvernement est un peu désemparé il
a sans doute il annonce une nouvelle
aide pour compenser le prix élevé du
carburant et de limiter au travailleur
et au plus modeste 100 euros par voiture
et par an j'imagine que c'est la
reconduction à peu près peut-être que
François Patriot nous confirmera la
reconduction du dispositif plus ciblée
qui avait été votée lors du PLF 203
c'était une mauvaise idée autant
l'oublier dans le fait c'est vrai que
j'ai un peu douté du résultat en termes
de centime je dis que ça pouvait baisser
d'avoir annoncé 40 47 cm ça me
paraissait un peu démesuré par rapport à
la capacité qu'on les distributeurs de
le faire aujourd'hui pour les petites
distributeurs j'étais rassuré puisque le
gouvernement avait dit qu'il y aurait un
plan d'accompagnement qui prendrait en
compte 10% de petits distributeurs qui
le feraient maintenant le gouvernement
comprend que il y a une obstruction qui
a une volonté de ne pas aboutir il en
tient compte et pour notre mesure c'est
plutôt sage
dernier mot non mais il y avait un côté
Shadok
pardon je souris un peu parce que d'un
côté on crée des conditions d'une quasi
faillite des petites stations et de
l'autre côté il aurait fallu les
subventionner est-ce que c'est ça le
modèle français
un dernier homo Hervé Marseille parce
que elle est presse les élections
sénatoriales il va y avoir une autre
bataille sans doute celle du plateau on
vient d'apprendre que Gérard Larcher
était réélu est-ce que vous allez vous
présenter avec Marseille
vous me rassurer en me disant que
président de la recherche a été réélu
parce qu'on était inquiet ici on était
plusieurs et donc à l'évidence il y a un
président qui fait l'unanimité dans la
majorité sénatoriale et je ne doute pas
que elle voudra le reconduire ceci étant
dit je voudrais juste dire d'un mot
quelque chose sur le fait que vous
n'avez pas parler du rassemblement
national qui fait son entrée au cinéma
mais je voulais dire que le Sénat c'est
une institution démocratique qui n'est
pas étanche au pays et quand il se passe
des choses dans le pays qu'on peut
apprécier ou ne pas apprécier le Sénat
est répercute ce que pensent les élus
puisque c'est eux pivote et quand il y a
des courants qui se créent dans
l'opinion qui est celle des élus et ben
on le retrouve ici aussi au Sénat et
donc normal que c'est légitime non mais
il y a des
députés du rassemblement ça a
démultiplié l'influence dans des
départements regardez le Pas-de-Calais
la moitié des des députés sont membres
du RN il y a forcément une influence qui
se crée en plus de de on a vu partout
que les candidats du rassemblement
national faisaient des voix à des fautes
faire des siestes faisaient des voix il
faut raconter ça fait partie comme les
Verts qui représente une une tendance
dans l'opinion le rassemblement national
c'est comme ça il représente une
tendance dans l'opinion et l'opinion des
élus qui se manifeste il faudra en tenir
compte parce que de plus en plus merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat à très bientôt sur sur nos
antennes on va retrouver Quentin calmer
tout de suite pour un point complet des
des résultats de ces élections
sénatoriales Quentin oui tout à fait
Thomas et puis une information
intéressante que vous en donnez vos
invités en plateau puisque les
présidents de groupe que vous venez
d'interviewer nous donne eux-mêmes et
bien les projections pour leur groupe
politique on commence avec des
républicains un groupe composé de 145
sénateurs selon leur chef de fil il
pourrait perdre 3 ou 4 sénateurs les
centrices qui sont actuellement 57 mises
sur une soixantaine je cite d'élus Union
centriste les communistes devraient
progresser selon Eliana SSI qui vient de
le dire en plateau qui passerait de 15 à
17 peut-être 18 sénateurs mais
Renaissance qui est actuellement à 24 ne
devrait pas passer en dessous de 20
selon leur chef de fil François patriars
que l'on vient d'entendre sur votre
plateau je voulais vous donner les
résultats dans les Yvelines en
département important avec 6 sièges à
pourvoir et on a appris la réélection ce
soir du président du sénagère lycé pour
la cinquième fois il est élu au Sénat ce
soir c'est donc et bien cette réélection
qui porte sur sa liste trois autres
sénateurs dont Sophie prima la
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques du Sénat et à l'air qui
réalise donc quatre sièges c'est donc la
perte d'un siège pour la droite et le
centre dans un appartement au profit
d'une candidate écologiste elle
s'appelle Ghislaine Séné elle est donc
et élue ce soir pour les écologistes à
noter enfin dans ce département la
réélection du sénateur Martin lévrier de
la majorité présidentielle on continue
avec un des nôtres départements très
important et qui est ancienne il s'agit
du Nord allons-y puisque et bien dans le
nord on voit le chef de fil des
socialistes Patrick Kanner être réélu ce
soir il emmène dans sa réélection une
autre élu Audrey linkenheeld donc les
socialistes quittablent au moins sur une
stabilité de leur groupe politique on
verra le détail un peu plus tard dans la
soirée notamment avec les résultats dans
les outre-mer Marc Philippe de Bresse
pour les LR ne réalise qu'un seul siège
ce qui signifie que la deuxième de liste
Brigitte l'herbier n'est pas réélu et
dans ce département le nord c'est une
information très importante ce
département a élu est l'un des trois
sénateurs rassemblement national il
s'agit de Joshua qui fait donc son
entrée au Sénat ce soir bonne
performance pour la droite Macron
compatible le groupe de Claude malurey
qui devrait voir trois sièges dans ce
département du Nord en plus de celui de
Denis l2D avec son deuxième de liste
ainsi que de Franck dersin pour horizon
enfin Olivier et nos élus centriste et
réélu et tout comme un autre candidat
divers droites Ghislain Cambier et enfin
et bien deux sièges pour les communistes
Eric Bocquet et Michel gréaume voilà
pour les résultats qu'on pouvait vous
donner Thomas pour ces élections
sénatoriales merci beaucoup Quentin on
vous retrouve évidemment
tout au long de cette soirée électorale
on est ensemble jusqu'à 22h30 sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat nouveau débat
nouveau invités j'accueille Sébastien
Chenu bonsoir vice-président du
rassemblement national également
à parisienne Benjamin Morel
constitutionnaliste et maître de
conférence en droit public à Paris de
Panthéon Assas et nous
accueillons et Pascal Perrineau
politologue et professeur à Sciences Po
Paris rebond soit merci à tous de
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
Sébastien Chenu des sénateurs du
rassemblement national vous dites quoi
enfin
oui enfin tout ça et je veux dire assez
normal puisque ça correspond
aux évolutions politiques que nous
constatons quelque temps et le fait que
le rassemblement national revienne
arrive on peut le dire comme on veut au
Sénat était pour nous en tous les cas
attendus ce qui les témoin c'est les
scores avec lesquels nous arrivons nos
candidats partout sur le territoire on
multiplie par trois quatre voire 5 les
résultats de la précédente du président
renouvellement sénatorial dans les mêmes
départements donc ça veut dire que nous
avons sur un corps électoral qui n'a pas
beaucoup bougé parce qu'il y avait pas
eu beaucoup de changements aux
municipales et bien nous avons convaincu
des électeurs de voter pour nos
candidats et en cela c'est une deuxième
victoire la première c'est de faire
entrer trois sénateurs ça démarre Nord
et Pas de Calais trois jeunes élus trois
élus de terrain et la seconde c'est les
scores que nous faisons qui je crois
bouscule beaucoup évidemment ce qui
était attendu est-ce que c'est surprise
parce que vous aviez moins de
conseillers municipaux après les
dernières municipales par rapport à
celle de 2014 qu'elle en est
l'explication pour vous est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'il y a aussi eu des grands
électeurs indécis que vous avez donc
convaincu oui évidemment je pense que
nous progressons et nous réussissons à
convaincre de la pertinence de nos
analyses et de nos solutions les
Français et leur représentants c'est à
dire les grands électeurs qui votaient
c'est une évidence et ça se passe
partout en France partout sur le
territoire puisque du Lot-et-Garonne où
nous passons je crois de 22 voix la
dernière fois à 100 voix aujourd'hui
jusque évidemment au nord nous avions
238 voies nous en avons 433 sur un corps
électoral identique et bien oui nous
considérons que nous avons réussi à
convaincre des grands électeurs et ça
aura forcément des conséquences
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie on parlera
évidemment des résultats de la gauche du
Parti socialiste mais votre réaction à
l'entrée ou au retour de de sénateurs du
rassemblement national voilà vous dites
c'est c'est finalement logique
comment vous réagissez vous savez quand
on connaît bien la carte électorale
française on sait que un très grand
nombre de d'élus n'ont pas de
d'engagement politique
identifié ce qui veut dire que alors que
un maire d'une toute petite commune a le
même poids que amer d'une commune plus
importante voilà il s'est sans doute
passé des choses à ce niveau-là il y
avait quand même un sénateur Front
national
oui non mais je veux dire pour être très
précis et qui vous a quitté mais on peut
pas dire qu'il a quitté l'extrême droite
puisqu'il est allé chez Zemmour voilà
donc
ça veut dire que là où on a bien
identifié que il y avait un sujet avec
les zones rurales je pense que c'est là
que le sujet va se être identifié
évidemment c'est très tôt pour pour le
pour l'affirmer comme cela il faut
regarder les résultats précisément mais
moi ce qui m'étonne de manière relative
d'abord le Front National est un parti
où le rassemblement national est un
parti qui s'est installé dans la vie
politique française on peut le déplorer
c'est mon cas on peut le combattre c'est
mon cas mais c'est une réalité
électorale ça veut dire que nous avons
la responsabilité en tout cas la gauche
de d'ouvrir les yeux d'un certain nombre
de personnes d'élus et des lecteurs pour
qu'ils ne se fourvoyent pas aujourd'hui
je ne pense pas que le score soit
absolument phénoménal pour autant je dis
il y avait un sénateur d'ores et déjà
d'autres qu'il était de manière qui
tangentait le Front national donc je ne
crois pas que ce soit quelque chose
d'absolument spectaculaire
c'était des terres historiquement à
gauche on en parlait tout à l'heure le
Nord le Pas-de-Calais on observe cela
quand même alors historiquement à gauche
c'est gentil de vous en rappeler mais je
pense que les choses ont quand même
évolué on sait très bien d'ailleurs
marine le met Le Pen elle est élu dans
le Pas-de-Calais donc voilà les réalités
électorales et politiques ne sont plus
exactement mais vous avez raison j'ai
connu une période où le nord et le
Pas-de-Calais était
un territoire où la gauche était très
implantée ce n'est pas exactement comme
cela aujourd'hui voilà après c'était une
question de combat politique en tout cas
moi c'est celui que je mène Sophie
Ravinel et son reste sur cette entrée de
sénateur du rassemblement national
est-ce une forme d'anomalie politique
qui
qui est désormais derrière nous
à se résorber puisque effectivement le
résultat aurait pu être encore plus
important même si voilà il s'agit
effectivement de convaincre comme le
disait très bien Marie-Pierre de la
Gontrie un certain nombre de grands
électeurs qui n'ont pas forcément
d'attache politique extrêmement forte
dans certains dans certains
environnements dans certaines régions
ce qu'il y a et donc se démocratiquement
effectivement on arrive vers quelque
chose de voilà alors évidemment le Sénat
et Pascal Perrineau on parlera très bien
n'est qu'une forme de représentation de
la vie politique nationale très
spécifique et donc évidemment la
question du rassemblement national et
extrêmement différente ici qu'elle est
ailleurs dans le pays donc je pense que
là déjà c'est très clair mais
effectivement et comme cela a été dit je
ne peux que le répéter ça traduit une
entrée dans les esprits et j'allais dire
une notabilisation entre guillemets du
RN qui est l'effort que le rassemblement
international tente de faire à
l'Assemblée nationale et je pense que
cette notabilisation à l'Assemblée
nationale qui semble fonctionner a pu
porter des fruits aux yeux d'un certain
nombre de grands électeurs et que on
peut mettre ça
disons comme une forme de réussite pour
Marine Le Pen évidemment on va Sébastien
Chenu on va quand même relativiser pour
l'instant on a seulement trois sénateurs
RN qui sont assurés d'entrée au Sénat le
groupe paraît loin quelle voie vous
pouvez faire porter au Sénat aujourd'hui
avec trois
élections vous ne réussirez pas à faire
élire un maire un conseiller
départemental un député un sénateur et
puis finalement on réussit toujours au
bout du compte à faire élire sur nos
convictions car les élus qui votent pour
nous savent très bien pourquoi ils
votent savent très bien ce qu'ils
attendent savent très bien la démarche
qu'ils font en envoyant des élus du
rassemblement national et la parole
qu'ils veulent porter dans cette
hémicycle comme dans celui de
l'Assemblée nationale justement qui sera
la stratégie ici au Sénat ce sera la
même logique que l'assemblée
c'est-à-dire nous opposer à la politique
du président de République faire des
propositions et travailler avec ceux qui
ont votaient en tous les cas ce qui
pourra aller dans le bon sens où on
n'est pas des gens en sectaire mais on
cherche pas à ressembler aux autres
c'est peut-être ça notre spécificité
nous on n'a pas du tout envie de
ressembler aux socialistes ou
républicains on n'a pas envie de copier
des gens qui ont mis le pays dans cet
état-là c'est ce que disait
Oscar Wilde soyez vous-même les autres
sont déjà pris nous sommes nous-mêmes
nos élus sont eux-mêmes ils défendent
leur conviction et je crois que elles ne
sont pas interchangeables avec les
parties du système qui ont mis encore
une fois le pays dans la dans l'état que
nous connaissons
tactique pour le rassemblement national
il va pas avoir un groupe et il n'aura
pas destinateur qui permettront de faire
pression sur la majorité mais c'est une
vraie victoire stratégique parce qu'il
faut comprendre que cette élection est
extrêmement défavorable au rassemblement
national on dit le Sénat est
structurellement à droite c'est pas tout
à fait vrai le Sénat est
structurellement au centre droit parce
que les territoires sur-reprétés sont
ceux du centre droit et parce que qui
plus est les élections locales avec
l'abstention qui est inhérente fait que
c'est plutôt un électorat sont tristes
qui votent je dirais différentiellement
de manière plus importante pas
réellement le lectorat du rassemblement
national donc structurellement cette
chambre n'est pas favorable à une
implantation du RN pourtant dans
certains départements on a des chiffres
importants non pas en termes de
sénateurs en effet mais en termes de
conseillers municipaux qui ont pu voter
pour le rassemblement national de grands
électeurs jusqu'à 15 % et donc là vous
voyez que un tabou a exploser que pour
des élus locaux qui et ben ont vu leurs
électeurs voter RN pour des élus locaux
qui et ben ont vu s'implanter des
députés le vote RN est devenu quelque
chose de possible et donc ça montre que
cet ancrage là aujourd'hui il existe
est-ce qu'il est structurel est-ce qu'il
est conjoncturel à voir mais c'est
sénatoriales quand même là-dessus sont
révélatrice
ce chiffre de 3 sénateurs pour l'instant
Pascal Perrineau l'ascension elle est
supérieure il peut encore y avoir des
marges de franchi aux prochaines
élections c'est un mouvement bien sûr
que non quand vous prenez absolument
tous les départements vous apercevez que
par rapport aux élections précédentes en
effet les candidats et les candidats du
rassemblement national progressent
c'est là on le dit on le répète à côté
de l'Assemblée nationale représente la
population le Sénat ça représente les
territoires et c'est très bien comme ça
c'est tout à fait légitime dans une
démocratie que les territoires soient
représentés à côté en effet de la
population et qu'il n'y ait pas de
territoire abandonné même la Lozère est
là son
voilà son sénateur et c'est une très
bonne chose mais vous savez on le dit
depuis des années sur le terrain des
territoires on parle de plus en plus de
fracture territoriales on parle de la
capacité du rassemblement national à se
faire le porteur des territoires qui se
sentent à tort ou à raison mais qui se
sentent en souffrance on voit bien les
terrains sur lequel ils sont élus le
Pas-de-Calais le nord la Seine-et-Marne
c'est pas n'importe quel type de terrain
ce sont des terrains dans lequel la
fracture territoriale est extrêmement
importante et puis
élus ces grands électeurs qui ont voté
pour un candidat du RN même si ils ne
sont pas conseillés municipaux du
rassemblement national ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que le rassemblement
national parle ou de là des élus du
rassemblement national il parle à
d'autres élus et ça on le sait depuis
un certain temps des élus qui sont de
droites du centre de gauche ça tape un
peu partout
même si dans certains départements bien
sûr ça a coûté plus cher à la droite
qu'à la gauche quoi que quand on regarde
la performance de la gauche dans le Nord
on peut on puisse on puisse s'interroger
et puis dernière remarque vous savez moi
ça m'avait frappé à la dernière élection
présidentielle
au second tour Marine Le Pen avait gagné
dans plus de communes qu'Emmanuel Macron
ça veut bien dire que quand on parle des
territoires et bien c'est pas tellement
étonnant que le rassemblement national
face de bons scores pourquoi parce que
Emmanuel Macron il faisait très bon
score dans des communes très peuplées
des métropoles etc alors que Marine Le
Pen faisait dans les petites et moyennes
communes et bien oui elle battait le
président de la République on va parler
de la gauche avec vous Marie-Pierre
delagontrie la stratégie de partir
finalement unie cette élection
sénatoriale c'est-à-dire les parties
représentées ici au Sénat mais sans elle
et fille sans la France insoumise pour
vous elle est validée par les résultats
de ce soir moi je vais attendre de voir
l'ensemble des résultats parce que
effectivement j'étais très concentré sur
ce qui se passait à Paris mais
ce qui est incontestable c'est que
puisque ça a été largement développé
les sénateurs représentent les
territoires et donc sont élus par les
les élus des territoires il était assez
logique que ce qui n'ont pas d'élus dans
les territoires en l'occurrence la
France insoumise n'est pas naturellement
de sièges possibles donc malgré oui mais
là du Pesse était un accord électoral au
moment des législatives bien après on
peut raisonner sur ce que c'est que la
nupette sur la stratégie à long terme
très bien on a des d'ailleurs des avis
qui ne sont pas homogènes au sein de la
nups sur ce sujet mais ici sur cette
élection simplement moi je prends
l'exemple de Paris après tout parlons de
ce qu'on connaît à Paris c'est simple la
France insoumise est dans l'opposition
municipale donc il y avait une logique à
ce que nous fassions une liste de
rassemblements et ça je m'en réjouis
avec l'ensemble de la gauche qui
composent la majorité municipale mais
voilà avec une Française soumise qui
s'oppose à la politique que nous menons
à Paris et ça a été le cas comme ça dans
la plupart des départements où ils sont
par exemple en opposition ça donne une
image de
des forces de gauche alors que l'Union
est réclamé par aux électeurs écoutez je
ne sais pas ça donne une image d'une
image de désunions parce que moi je vois
à Paris nous progressons nous avons fait
huit sièges sur 12 je crois que c'est
voilà retrouver un format d'union de la
gauche encore une fois cohérent parce
que vous savez faut pas prendre les
électeurs pour des idiots c'est-à-dire
que on ne peut pas à la fois ça les
grands mais les grands électeurs sont
des électeurs je veux dire que on ne
peut pas s'affronter sur une politique
municipale toute l'année et se
rassembler
sur Paris sauf que ça vaut partout c'est
à dire que dans les départements où vous
avez ou dans des régions où vous avez
une Française soumise qui s'affrontent
avec la gauche locale voilà donc ça
serait même me semble-t-il un signe
d'incohérence que tout à coup vous savez
le côté embrassant nos folles ville
aurait pu être
mal compris donc les électeurs ils ont
besoin de cohérence si tout le débat que
nous avons d'ailleurs aujourd'hui sur
les européennes etc c'est quelle est la
cohérence d'une d'un rassemblement
Sophie de Ravinel on entend Marie-Pierre
de la Gontrie d'évidence il y a des
résistances à la nippéisation du groupe
socialiste au Sénat qui en tout cas ces
dernières années effectivement n'était
pas du tout du côté de cette nouvelle
alliance j'allais dire de c'est depuis
ces dernières années et encore moins ces
derniers mois et encore moins ces
dernières semaines et encore moins ces
derniers jours l'ambiance est à
l'explosion de la new peste d'ailleurs
un sondage Ifop a indique que 68% des
électeurs ont une vision plutôt négative
de cette UPS parce que à force de
disputes à force de tension à force
d'explosion et là la Fête de l'Humanité
était quand même un festival en la
matière avec les dernières tensions
entre Fabien Roussel et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qu'il traite de Dorio les
socialistes de DA voilà on est dans des
espèces de de
et donc et oui évidemment et puis ça ne
pouvait déjà au Sénat il n'y avait
j'allais dire pas de place pour les
insoumis et c'est du fait de cette
représentation du terrain de qui est
finalement une photographie de 2020 des
élections municipales et dans laquelle
les insoumis n'ont pas n'avaient pas
leur place alors Jean-Luc Mélenchon peut
bien vouloir s'investir pour 2026 il y a
là aujourd'hui une forme d'union de la
gauche or un soumis et tout le monde se
conforte et ils sont finalement très
confortables à se retrouver communiste
écologiste et socialiste qui se
connaissent et qui s'apprécient et
c'était effectivement vous nous l'avez
dit le cas à Paris justement rejoint
quand un Calmet pour un point complet
des résultats du scrutin à Paris Quentin
Thomas juste un mot pour rebondir sur ce
que vous disiez en plateau car le groupe
socialiste du Sénat fait savoir aux
journalistes que et bien la gauche en
l'occurrence les socialistes auraient pu
bien faire deux sièges de plus dans deux
départements au moins en Essonne ou dans
les Hauts de Seine s'il n'y avait pas eu
de candidature la insoumise donc selon
eux c'est dissidence de LFI font perdre
au groupe de gauche en l'occurrence au
groupe socialiste au moins deux sièges
ce soir lors de ces élections
sénatoriales mais effectivement les
résultats pour l'élection à Paris ont
enfin été rendus officiels par le
ministère de l'Intérieur et c'est une
circonscription importante car Paris
renouvelle 12 sièges c'est la
circonscription qui renouvelle le plus
de siège ce soir et la gauche qui
réalise une bonne performance puisque ce
la liste d'union et bien gagne un siège
avec huit sénateurs élus au total pour
la gauche dont des figures connues du
grand public comme Yannick Jadot le
candidat aux dernières élections à la
dernière élection présidentielle pour
les écologistes ou encore Yann Brossat
porte-parole du Parti communiste
français le groupe Renaissance perd à
Paris un siège puisque le sénateur
Julien barjetton n'est pas réélu à
droite la liste officielle LR menée par
Catherine Dumas réalise trois sièges
plus celui pour les républicains de la
dissidente qui est et bien la présidente
de la Fédération les républicains de
Paris mais donc le Sarkozy St Pierre
Charron n'est pas réélu il est battu ce
soir le l'information est donc
maintenant officielle Pierre Charron qui
va donc quitter la chambre haute du
parlement et donc cette bonne
performance pour le rassemblement
l'union de la gauche écologiste
communiste et socialiste à Paris voilà
pour ce qu'on pouvait dire de ces
résultats dans cette circonscription
importante avec 12 sièges Tam merci
beaucoup Quentin pour ce nouveau point
résultat Sébastien Chenu un dernier mot
avant que vous quittiez sur ce plateau
néanmoins le Sénat on le voit il y a
encore ses forces qui restent toujours
aussi importantes c'est la majorité de
la droite et du centre c'est la gauche
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire ce temple
de stabilité pour les parties
traditionnels
très bien dit le Sénat n'a pas la même
vocation que l'Assemblée nationale et ça
représentation n'est pas la même que
celle de l'Assemblée nationale donc il
est moins ouvert peut-être au changement
et à la violence ou à la rapidité des
changements politiques que les Français
souhaitent donc comme Marine Le Pen
je pense que c'est une maison plus
conservatrice qui évidemment change
beaucoup moins vite ses habitudes et sa
représentation mais c'est en train
d'évoluer aussi et on le voit bien le
Sénat a évolué dans la représentation de
ces sénateurs et la moyenne d'âge ABC il
s'est féminisé il sait quelque part
modernisé il est en train aussi
d'effectuer sa mue politique aujourd'hui
l'accueil des forces politiques qui
avaient plus de difficultés super élire
il rassemblement national entre ce soir
au Sénat avec plaisir avec bonheur et
avec respect aussi merci beaucoup merci
Sébastien Chenu on va rejoindre tout de
suite Alexandre Poussard qui est avec
Yann Brossat nouvelle nouveau sénateur
de Paris sénateur communiste Alexandre
sénateur communiste à Paris sur une
liste d'union de la gauche entre
socialiste communiste et écologiste
est-ce que c'est une victoire politique
pour un Ingo parce que ça reflète sa
majorité municipale en tout cas c'est
une pour pour la gauche et les
écologistes à Paris incontestablement
nous avons gagné les dernières élections
municipales contrairement à ce que
certains nous disaient que ce soir nous
avons gagné les élections sénatoriales
très largement puisque nous avons un
sénateur de plus que lors du Sénat
précédent et ça augure bien de la suite
en tout cas ça nous renforce et ça me
conduit à penser que nous pouvons tout à
fait continuer notre travail et et tout
ça est très positif est-ce que ça montre
aussi cet exemple parisien qu'une autre
union de la gauche est possible que la
nups autour de la France insoumise vous
savez l'union de la gauche elle a existé
avant la nupesse et elle existera sous
des formes différentes dans les années
qui viennent ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on
a besoin d'une gauche populaire sociale
et je pense d'ailleurs que Fabien
Roussel l'incarne bien en ce moment et
je pense que cette voie là a besoin
d'être entendue c'est sûr vous allez et
bien faire entendre la voix de Fabien
Roussel à au Sénat en tout cas je suis
porte-parole du Parti communiste et j'ai
bien l'intention de porter la parole de
cette gauche là gauche qui se bat pour
le pouvoir d'achat pour l'augmentation
des salaires on est dans une période où
le travail ne paye plus ou les Français
ont des difficultés énormes n'arrivent
plus à boucler leur fin de mois et donc
je pense que la justice sociale c'est ça
qui doit coller à l'image de la gauche
c'est ça que nous devons porter et en
tout cas moi j'ai envie de porter
prioritairement ça plutôt que de se
perdre parfois dans des débats dans
lesquels les Français dans leur grande
majorité ne se reconnaissent pas du tout
en tout cas le bloc de gauche au Sénat
sort renforcé de ces élections
sénatoriales quel style d'opposition de
gauche au Sénat vous souhaitez est-ce
que ça doit être le même style que
justement la nups à l'Assemblée
nationale où on est vraiment dans le
bruit dans la colère en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il y a effectivement
plus de sénateurs de gauche et plus de
sénateurs communistes d'ailleurs puisque
notre groupe sera renforcé c'était déjà
le cas lors du renouvellement précédent
je pense qu'on a besoin d'une opposition
déterminée ferme qui a qui sait se faire
entendre et c'est ce que nous avons
toujours fait d'ailleurs au Sénat et
donc nous devons continuer sur ce que
nous avons fait sous la houlette d'Elian
assassis au cours des dernières années
c'est nous par exemple qui avons obtenu
la commission d'enquête sur les cabinets
de conseils nous qui avons révélé le
scandale McKinsey c'est comme ça qu'on
est utile c'est pas le niveau des
décibels qui fait qu'on se fait
remarquer c'est la pertinence de ce
qu'on dit et en tout cas nous allons
continuer sur sur ce mouvement là merci
beaucoup
Ian brossa pour votre réaction merci à
Alexandre pour cette réaction politique
évidemment n'hésitez pas si vous avez
d'autres invités à nous faire signe une
déclaration celle de Gérard Larcher qui
je vous le rappelle a été réélu sénateur
des Yvelines le Sénat continuera à être
ce contre-pouvoir à la démocratie si on
se projette un peu dans les enjeux la
démocratie j'oublie indispensable et
c'était un mot important effectivement
et il faut toujours citer j'ai Beaupré
sinon ça c'est sinon les soucis
commencent je redeviens sérieux les
enjeux de ces prochaines semaines parce
qu'elles Perrineau alors on peut
commencer tiens par Gérard Larcher qui
va certainement être élu pour la
cinquième fois à la présidence du Sénat
avec un rôle est-ce que pour vous ce
rôle va son rôle va peut-être évoluer
entre je suis précis la première partie
du second mandat d'Emmanuel Macron est
la seconde partie qui s'ouvre maintenant
c'est à dire que là il y a comment dire
une forme d'institutionnalisation dans
le paysage de Gérard Larcher de la
majorité LR Union centriste qui le
soutient c'est-à-dire que la majorité va
être obligé encore plus qu'auparavant de
faire avec le Sénat tel qu'il est c'est
à dire que le Sénat va dans ce rôle de
contrepoids que le président du Sénat
apprécie beaucoup va peser véritablement
beaucoup et la majorité va être obligée
de le prendre en compte on le voit par
exemple dans la volonté si le projet de
loi immigration vient de commencer par
le Sénat certaines bonnes manières sont
faites au Sénat cela veut dire quelque
chose mais les sénateurs ont de la
mémoire ça n'a pas commencé comme ça le
premier quinquennat d'emmel Macron
voilà vous savez jamais trop tard pour
apprendre et là peut-être que le
deuxième quin pas d'Emmanuel Macron et
des forces qui le soutiennent sera le
quinquennat où ils apprendront j'allais
dire à faire avec cette France des
territoires qui s'incarnent dans cette
institution et puis on va voir le Sénat
jouer un rôle de plus en plus important
dans j'allais dire l'équilibre
démocratique vous savez la démocratie
représentative et beaucoup critiquée on
dit voilà le président a trop de pouvoir
il y a pas assez de contre-pouvoirs ah
oui mais là il y a le Sénat qui vient de
d'être ressourcée du moins pour la
moitié de ces sénateurs et je crois
qu'il y a là non pas la réponse
mais une réponse à la crise de la
démocratie représentative on aussi un
vrai changement de manière du
gouvernement vis-à-vis du Sénat bien sûr
après l'élection de 2022 et la majorité
relative à l'Assemblée nationale est-ce
que ça va donc se renforcer pour vous
Benjamin Morel alors on pourrait le
penser même si c'est vrai que donner une
interview le soir dessinateurial
expliqué que le Sénat est renouvelé par
tiers ce soir n'était peut-être pas la
meilleure façon de tendre la main au
Sénat
Macron
je ne suis pas tout à fait sûr que ce
soit la bonne façon en effet de renouer
avec le snap mais objectivement
aujourd'hui la majorité a besoin du
Sénat pour des raisons simples en
réalité la majorité est relative et qui
plus est elle est fracturée et donc elle
n'a pas intérêt à ce que le Sénat joue
les troubles fêtes vous savez lorsqu'une
seconde chambre veut parasiter la vie de
la première elle a deux ressources soit
elle joue sur ses divisions en adoptant
des amendements qui divisent les modems
les horizons et les renaiscances soit
elle fait perdre du temps le Sénat était
bon camarade lors de la réforme des
retraites si le Sénat avait voulu à
perdre du temps et bien il aurait pu et
on le fait il a joué de de son propre
règlement pour accélérer
de manière extrêmement appuyée sur son
propre règlement en effet en appui du
gouvernement vous voyez que là-dessus
Emmanuel Macron a plutôt besoin du Sénat
l'autre élément c'est que cette majorité
est en relative s'appuie malgré tout
essentiellement sur NRJ or le Sénat
étant abdominante de droite si vous
déposez un texte d'abord ici le but est
clair faire que le texte qui sort du
Sénat et la couleur de la droite et la
couleur de LR pour qu'il soit acceptable
par le groupe d'érections nationale ça
marche pas si bien à sur chaque texte
néanmoins fondamentalement depuis un an
ça ne manque ça ne marche pas si mal au
bout du compte donc si jamais le
gouvernement veut avoir le soutien au
moins tacite d'une partie de la droite
sénatoriale et ben il doit la considérer
il doit l'écouter il y a eu que trois
dernières mots lors de la dernière
législature ce qui montre bien
qu'aujourd'hui on est arrivé dans une
situation de bicamérisme quasi
égalitaire Sophie dravinel ça va tout ce
qu'on est en train de décrire va se
concrétiser là dans dans quelques
semaines autour du texte de loi sur
l'immigration oui absolument évidemment
c'est un texte de loi essentiel très
attendu par les Français et on va voir
effectivement les jeux entre les deux
chambres à cette occasion là et le rôle
évidemment du d'une forme de
restructuration
d'une vie politique française pour
prendre un tout petit peu de chant par
rapport au sol Sénat où l'on voit que la
majorité présidentielle a été évidemment
secoué fortement ce soir alors
symboliquement avec la défaite de Sonia
paquets ce qui est la secrétaire d'État
à la citoyenneté qui va démissionner
sans doute cette semaine face à
l'indépendantiste Robert Zowie qui fait
d'ailleurs entre indépendantistes de
nouvelles Calédonie son entrée au Sénat
et là c'est quand même c'est un choc et
c'est évidemment cette
reconstitution
face à une disons bipartisme on retrouve
un peu cet équilibre là alors évidemment
symboliquement à Paris Julien barjoton
qui était de la majorité présidentielle
a été écartée c'était pas si étonnant
que cela puisque avec Pierre Charron on
voyait bien que tous les deux se
prenaient un petit peu les mêmes
électeurs mais ça dit symboliquement
aussi quelque chose de cet échec
d'Emmanuel Macron et de ce que lui-même
finalement a reconnu lorsqu'il était à
Saint-Denis où il a invité l'ensemble
des parties et quand il a dit mais je ne
vais pas pouvoir enfin il l'a dit on l'a
interprété comme ça et de fait je ne
veux pas pouvoir me représenter mon
autorité est déjà entamée et finalement
et bien on le lit aussi sur le terrain
législatif parlementaire
à essayer de réinventer des des ovnis de
de discussion
constitutionnelle c'est assez
intéressant ça ne débouche pas forcément
sur grand-chose mais en tout cas il y a
toujours cette volonté de d'inventer on
retourne auprès d'Alexandre Poussard qui
est avec un nouvel invité Francis piner
ma mère du 16 e qui était candidat sur
la liste LR de Catherine Dumas à Paris
effectivement Thomas la liste LR de
Catherine Dumas qui a réussi à élire
trois sièges de sénateurs malgré les
divisions de la droite parisienne
puisqu'il y avait trois listes de
droites c'est donc un succès pour votre
liste Francis spinner nous avions une
cénatrice au sein du groupe changer
Paris demain au Conseil de Paris nous
aurions trois sénateurs plus quelqu'un
qui se dit proche de nous donc il y
avait quatre sénateurs de droite divisés
avant dans tous les groupes aujourd'hui
nous sommes un gros Buddy derrière
Rachida Dati madame Hidalgo a beau dire
que nous sommes divisés en réalité nous
avons réussi à maintenir trois sièges
sur la liste unique et puis les
dissidences finalement n'ont pas
prospéré à une exception près mais il y
a quand même des divisions comment s'est
passé cette campagne parisienne à droite
ça a été difficile au sein de votre camp
vous avez il y a des gens qui
considèrent la politique comme une
ambition collective pour changer Paris
c'était notre groupe puis il y a des
gens pour qui c'est une aventure
personnelle
qui sont plus soucieux de leur avenir
que de l'ambition collective on parlait
d'Agnès Evren je parle de ceux qui ont
fait des listes dissidentes et
finalement bien les électeurs ont
tranché et majoritairement nous avons
remporté les trois quarts des sièges de
la droite à Paris un mot sur pierre
Charron qui était sénateur sortant de
Paris qui a fait sa liste dissidente et
qui a été battue il quitte le Sénat
c'est quand même une figure de la droite
parisienne il paraît
ça m'avait échappé mais c'est
certainement vrai puisque vous dites
mais il n'était plus conseillé de Paris
dans le 15e arrondissement qui était son
arrondissement d'élection
il n'avait pas été maintenu dans ses
fonctions et c'est difficile de rester
élu de Paris quand on est plus conseillé
de Paris c'est aussi un échec pour la
majorité présidentielle pour Emmanuel
Macron avec Renaissance qui qui perd son
siège de sénateur à Paris oui mais quand
madame Hidalgo crie victoire puisqu'elle
a réussi à réunir tous les gens qui se
disputent au Conseil de Paris surtout
les sujets mais qui ne sont unis que
pour rafler les places mais le seul gain
que fait madame Hidalgo et ses amis il
n'est pas au détriment de la droite
parisienne il est au détriment de la
majorité présidentielle donc c'est une
victoire monsieur barjetton était son
ancien adjoint socialiste aux finances
il avait été élu par une partie des
socialistes ces gens-là sont venus à la
maison c'est pas une victoire c'est le
statu quo merci beaucoup Francis spinner
merci
merci beaucoup Alexandre pour cette
nouvelle réaction à votre micro vous
retrouve bien sûr si vous avez d'autres
invités dans cette salle des conférences
mais tout de suite on va rejoindre
Quentin Quentin Calmet qui se trouve
dans le studio à quelques mètres de nous
pour un nouveau point sur les résultats
Quentin voilà on poursuit ce marathon de
la soirée électorale des cinématographe
2023 avec un focus sur les personnalités
marquantes qui sont réels ou battu lors
de ces élections sénatoriales on va
commencer avec le président de
l'institution Gérard lyncher réélu dans
les Yvelines effectivement c'est la
cinquième élection au poste de sénateurs
de Gérard Larcher autre et bien
personnalité majeure c'est Patrick
canner dans le Nord qui est réélu et
c'est important car les socialistes se
revendiquent toujours le deuxième groupe
en importance numérique au Sénat autre
président de groupe troisième groupe
aussi au Sénat à la chambre haute le
centriste Hervé Marseille son groupe
pourrait d'ailleurs gagner engranger
quatre à cinq sièges supplémentaires
faire comme c'est le cas pour lui dans
les Hauts-de-Seine puisque sa deuxième
de liste Isabelle Floren est également
élue on continue avec les présidents de
groupe pour les écologistes puisque
Guillaume Gontard en Isère et réélu les
écologistes qui se tarent d'avoir fait
passer leur groupe de 12 à 16 sénateurs
ont vérifiant si cette affirmation est
réalisée à la fin de la soirée et
électorale contre-performance pour les
candidats de renaissance de la majorité
présidentielle on le dit depuis ce midi
puisque et bien effectivement Sonya bac
S en Nouvelle-Calédonie et battue même
chose pour une autre candidate soutenue
par la majorité présidentielle ancienne
ministre de la Santé Brigitte
bourguignon et battu dans le
Pas-de-Calais de Pas-de-Calais où on va
voir effectivement un élu RN arrivé au
Sénat on continue avec les personnalités
marquantes ancien candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 l'écologie
Yannick Jadot et Telus sur la liste
d'union de la gauche à Paris il fera son
au Palais du Luxembourg tout comme le
porte-parole du Parti communiste
français élu sur cette même liste
d'unions à Paris et on termine avec des
présidents de commission permanente au
Sénat a commencé par le sénateur LR
Christian Cambon il est réélu dans le
Val-de-Marne et vous voyez une dernière
personnalité Pierre Charron qui lui est
battu à Paris le Sarkozy c'était
effectivement battu comme on venait de
l'évoquer lors de cette interview voilà
pour les personnalités marquantes et qui
et bien sont gagnantes ou perdants de ce
soir ta main merci
la majorité présidentielle majorité
présidentielle le paradoxe tout de même
c'est qu'on a dit qu'Emmanuel Macron
allait devoir s'appuyer sur le Sénat
mais
os Renaissance on entendu à travers les
personnalités égrainées par Quentin
Brigitte bourguignon Sonia bac S qui ne
parviennent pas à être élus un élu
parisien comme Julien barjoton qui qui
échoue également c'est un des aveux
alors c'est un des aveux qu'il faut
relativiser par rapport à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure il faut du temps
pour s'implanter au Sénat ça a mis 20
ans en général de Gaulle et d'ailleurs
assez successeur a vraiment existé au
Sénat donc le fait qu'une formation qui
aujourd'hui a 5-6 ans ne soit pas
réellement implanté dans la seconde
chambre cela peut s'entendre après ce
que l'on peut également constater c'est
qu'elle n'a pas fait grand chose pour
s'y implanter il y a deux stratégies
d'implantation au Sénat soit vous
débauchez des élus auquel cas il faut
quand même arriver à obtenir ensuite à
ces délu locaux pour qu'il soit
reconduit et beaucoup et bien qui ont pu
être tentés par le groupe macroniste ont
largué les voiles à prendre cette
étiquette quand même aujourd'hui pour
ceux qui ont choisi cette étiquette et
qui du coup on levait les voiles de leur
partie d'origine ils n'ont pas amené
leurs grands électeurs et donc vous
voyez que forcément ensuite être
reconduit devient plus difficile plus
compliqué certains ils sont parvenus
parce que les élections sénatoriales
Paris quand même sur un capital
personnel une implantation mais c'est
évidemment plus compliqué l'autre
stratégie lorsque vous voulez vous
implanter au Sénat et ben c'est de
gagner les élections locales et c'est la
stratégie la plus efficace la plus
pérenne or la majorité ne s'est pas
réellement investi dans la formation de
militants dans la formation des Lulu
locaux et dans la conquête des échelons
sur intermédiaire pour le parti au
pouvoir c'est toujours difficile c'est
toujours des élections sanctions mais
néanmoins et bien vous avez une
possibilité de construire des réseaux
etc de vous investir et de former un
parti politique avec des élus formés et
ça forcément c'est pas si évident petite
question toujours pour vous Benjamin
concernant Sonia Vaquez il y a
évidemment pas de règle
institutionnelles mais une ministre
battue est-ce qu'elle peut rester à son
poste il y a pas de règle
institutionnelle en effet on est
purement dans la convention et certains
battus n'ont pas démissionné
historiquement néanmoins là c'est
compliqué d'abord parce qu'il y a une
équation personnelle qui a fait que son
nez sa défaite mettant grande partie du
et ensuite parce que on est quand même
sur un point extrêmement chaud je vous
rappelle que le dossier n'est au
calédonien il va falloir faire quelque
chose c'est à dire que les chances des
accords de Nouméa arrivant il va quand
même falloir demain envisager un accord
entre les différents partis en
Nouvelle-Calédonie une ministre battue à
ça fait mauvais genre
démon sur ce dossier particulièrement
oui et bien c'est ce qu'on peut dire
puisque c'est évidemment au delà d'elle
la figure d'Emmanuel Macron qui se soit
prend un coup parce que évidemment les
grands électeurs ont tranché c'est 95%
de conseiller municipaux évidemment mais
de fait il y a il y a un signal qui est
envoyé et ce signal là il est mauvais
pour le chef de l'État je pense que
effectivement la démission danse dans
cet ordre là et est assez est inévitable
ce qu'il faut se dire c'est que le parti
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2020 si je ne me
trompe à effet 2, je parle sous votre
contrôle 2,22%
aux municipales et donc finalement
c'était un échec et il est assez logique
que nous soyons aujourd'hui dans le
reflet de cet échec alors il y a aussi
quand même un élément qu'il faut bien
garder en tête c'est que dans dans
l'alliance macroniste il y a différentes
tendances c'est que ici au Sénat il y a
un groupe horizon qui peut plutôt
grossir il y a aussi des sénateurs
centrices qui pour certains peuvent être
favorables à la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron donc ce n'est pas si simple et
bon peut-être l'échec n'est pas aussi
important qu'on peut le penser
apparemment il y a un échec mais
méfions-nous parce que vous avez dans
les forces qui sont élues ce soir des
forces qui restent plus ou moins fidèles
au chef de l'État mais dont le centre de
gravité est plus à droite et au centre
au fond la macronie au Sénat évolue
comme l'électorat macroniens a évolué de
l'espace central que Macron appelait de
ses vœux vers le centreisme associé à la
droite et la droite associée au
centrisme
conforte un peu sa stratégie Édouard
Philippe oui ça de manière claire
en effet des élus dans des terres assez
différentes j'étais en train de pointer
ça l'Orne la Marne la Seine-et-Marne le
Nord l'Indre-et-Loire voyez bon même les
lois aussi
des terrains tout à fait différents et
il y a là un parti horizon qui révèle en
fait le fait que c'est un parti d'élus
locaux le maire du Havre d'ailleurs
l'avait conçu comme ça quand il conçoit
horizon il voit bien les faiblesses du
parti macronien il se dit il ne faut pas
que j'ai ces faiblesses donc il va
constituer un appareil politique horizon
qui est un parti d'élus des parties
d'élus et bien ça marche mais surtout
quand sont des élus locaux pour avoir
des sénateurs mais la poutre va
continuer de travailler pour reprendre
l'expression cher à l'ancien prémisse
mais Sophie dramanel ce qui va être
quand même très intéressant dans les
prochains mois c'est la capacité
d'Édouard Philippe à se détacher quand
même de d'Emmanuel Macron et du bilan
d'Emmanuel c'est ça qu'on va ausculter à
la loupe oui au fil des déclarations des
prises de position etc
ça a commencé de façon très très solide
de même façon qui disons presque pour
certains de la même manière qu'il
s'était détaché de des républicains
d'aujourd'hui je j'étais assez proche
d'Antoine rufnac qui était son
prédécesseur au Havre un grand élu de la
droite qui avait été assez frappé par
cette façon qu'avait eu Édouard Philippe
de de rompre avec toute une tradition
toute une histoire avec des amis ce
qu'il avait fait élire etc et du coup
Antoine reflnac n'est plus là il est
décédé mais de fait il y a la mémoire
qui reste et la mémoire de gestes et je
pense qu'effectivement il doit Philippe
est tout à fait capable de de poursuivre
sur cette dynamique qui est celle d'une
rupture et d'avancer en rupture avec
ceux qui qui avec qui il a été compagnon
de route
[Musique]
que le Sénat est renouvelé aujourd'hui
par moitié jusqu'aux années 2000
partières et que vous avez ce suffrage
universel indirect le but en réalité
c'est que vous ne vous inscrivez au
Sénat que dans le temps long et donc on
voit les choses évoluées on voit les
choses changer regardez par exemple le
groupe socialiste il a beaucoup des
crues depuis 2011 donc il y a des choses
qui se passent mais ces choses elles se
passent relativement lentement ça
signifie pas qu'il ne faut pas être
sensible et bien aux signaux faible ce
qui peut se passer dans cette chambre on
a en effet notamment une recomposition
des centres on a une petite montée en
voie du rassemblement national ces
éléments fera voir dans les années dans
les années suivantes dans les élections
suivantes et bien s'ils vont croissants
ou si on a une renomalisation oui alors
une autre réaction celle de la
secrétaire nationale d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts alors que pour le coup le
groupe écologiste va gagner quand même
quatre sièges et se considèrent comme
victorieux dans cette élection
oui donc je suis avec Marine tondeelier
la secrétaire nationale du parti
europécologie les Verts bonsoir bonsoir
marine Tondelier bonsoir alors les
écologistes gagnent des sièges ce soir
au Sénat vous en féliciter on est
extrêmement fier premièrement d'envoyer
au Sénat Mathilde Olivier la plus jeune
représentante de ce nouveau Sénat à
seulement 29 ans elle élue des Français
de l'étranger à Vienne et puis voilà en
tout on a cette élue ce soir dont 5
nouveaux c'est beaucoup et ça c'est chez
les gens voilà qu'avec qui on travaille
depuis longtemps il y a sûrement aussi
d'autres nouveaux élus avec qui on va
pouvoir discuter donc on est extrêmement
fier de la tournure que prend notre
groupe ce soir et de tout ce qu'on va
pouvoir porter dans mandat qui vient
alors des gains de siège pour les
écologistes qui se base notamment sur
des accords électoraux avec les
socialistes avec les communistes mais
sans les insoumis il n'y a pas eu
d'alliance de la nupesse pour ses
sénatoriales finalement est-ce que ça
rééquilibre le rapport de force au sein
de la gauche face aux insomnies alors
moi je me réjouis quand tout le monde
gagne je ne me réjouirai jamais de la
défaite d'un partenaire c'est aussi
simple que ça les verres ont été les
dans ces discussions à vouloir que la fi
est un siège supplémentaire c'était un
Puy-de-Dôme le Parti communiste et le
Parti socialiste ce sont des péchés de
faire un accord sans nous et nous ont
réintégré ensuite aux discussions mais
l'accord avait été scellé entre les deux
et très sincèrement c'est pas ça qu'on
aurait voulu donc voilà moi je suis pas
je me réjouis pas de dire on est plus
fort que l'autre on est meilleur mes
adversaires sont à droite et l'extrême
droite ça a toujours été comme ça mais
justement à l'extrême droite une
réaction sur les trois sénateurs
rassemblement national qui font leur
entrée à la rotation blé notamment dans
votre région les hauts de France je
rappelle que vous êtes concerne
municipal d'opposition à Hénin-Beaumont
c'est logique compte tenu du paysage
local notamment dans les Hauts-de-France
bah oui c'est une continu une continuité
et puis c'est aussi très lié à la
sociologie de cette région on voit bien
que après la fermeture des mines de
charbon après rien industrialisation
ratée il y a une crise politique sociale
économique judiciaire au politique
d'ailleurs parfois et c'est extrêmement
difficile de travailler dans cette
région les écologistes le font avec
beaucoup d'énergie on est passé pas loin
d'un siège dans le Nord et je reste une
grosse pensée à célinec ce soir mais ça
ne suffit pas après pour les nouveaux
qui sont élus ce soir moi je connais
plus particulièrement Christopher Zurich
qui est premier adjoint à Hénin-Beaumont
et c'est vrai que vous allez voir il est
jeune lui aussi on va sûrement vouloir
le présenter comme le gendre idéal qui
renouvelle la politique côté RN moi je
sais qu'il l'a formé d'où il vient avec
qui il a appris et je peux vous dire que
ne vous fait pas aux apparences mais ça
vous aurez quelques années pour le voir
d'accord donc c'est votre adversaire
politique et un aboiement qui qui entre
Sénat merci beaucoup marine Tondelier
pour votre réaction
merci à tous les deux merci alexandre
Poussin pour cette réaction rejoint tout
de suite Quentin Calmet alors on va on
arrive au bout de cette soirée élection
sénatoriale content on va se projeter un
peu dans les prochains jours prochaine
semaine les échéances à venir ici au
Sénat oui Thomas la première date que
l'on peut retenir après les élections
sénatoriales de ce soir et se
renouvellement de 170 sièges sur les 348
que compte la chambre haute c'est la
date du 26 septembre c'est dans 48
heures puisque les groupes politiques
vont élire leur président de groupe on
devrait y voir plus clair aussi à ce
moment-là sur la composition exacte de
ces groupes politiques parce qu'il y a
encore alors où l'on se parle des
sénateurs qui n'ont pas dit dans quel
groupe politique ils vont le sièger par
exemple et bien il y a une catégorie
d'élus qui s'appelle les divers droits
qui sont 14 on va voir avec cette
réunion de groupe politique dans les
prochains jours si c'est 14 élus vont
aller chez les LR les centristes ou vers
le groupe des indépendants de Claude
malurey ou encore vers d'autres groupes
donc ça ce sera à suivre dans les 48
prochaines heures à partir du 2 octobre
et ce sera à vivre en direct et en
intégralité sur l'antenne du public
c'est là on va voir l'élection au
plateau élection à la présidence du
Sénat puisque avec la rédaction de
Gérard on verra si il est bien un
candidat à sa succession stylée le 2
octobre le 4 octobre vous le voyez c'est
ensuite la répartition des commissions
permanentes chaque sénateur appartient à
une commission permanente la commission
des lois la plus prestigieuse celle des
Affaires étrangères présidents
présidents actuellement par Christian
Cambron etc et bien le 4 octobre on
verra la répartition de ces commissions
pour tous les 348 sénateurs et enfin la
dernière date c'est le 10 octobre la
reprise des travaux parlementaires qu'on
suivra bien sûr sur l'antenne de Public
Sénat sur public sénat.fr notamment avec
votre serviteur voilà merci merci
beaucoup Quentin et surtout
avec toutes ces échéances
et sur public sénat.fr vous pouvez aussi
bien sûr retrouver tous les résultats
des élections sénatoriales minute par
minute et actualisée et bien sûr tous
les articles de décryptage de notre
rédaction web un mot sur le groupe
socialiste Sophie de Ravinel qui est
plutôt stable ils sont aujourd'hui
autour de 64 sénateurs qu'elle est
l'enjeu pour vous encore pour la suite
et bien c'est un enjeu un peu global
pour la gauche puisque il va avoir comme
cela a été très bien expliqué des
élections pour savoir qui va présider le
groupe donc il est Patrick Kanner et il
a face à lui
Eric kerrouj qui vient d'être réélu dans
les Landes
absolument avec je crois plus de 63% des
voix est-ce que ce sont deux lignes
finalement politique et stratégiques qui
s'opposent c'est-à-dire que ça te dit
quelque chose de la nuit pèse dont nous
parlions auparavant ça dit quelque chose
des liens avec les insoumis puisque Eric
et rouge est proche d'Olivier Faure qui
évidemment n'est pas tout à fait sur la
même ligne que Patrick Kanner même si
Patrick Kanner affirme qu'il veut être
un président
mais c'est vrai que il est assez proche
de Nicolas Mayer Rossignol en tout cas
au Congrès c'était le cas et c'est
effectivement cette ligne au sein du PS
qui est assez clivante entre prohup
c'est-à-dire la nuit pêche étant associé
aux insoumis et celle hostile à la
présence des insoumis et de fait ce
qu'il va ce qui va compter pour la suite
et pour les prochains travaux
parlementaires ce sera le travail avec
l'Assemblée et il est vrai que rouge a
des liens avec les insoumis plus
constructif peut-être que les avait
Patrick Kanner on fait encore un match
Benjamin Morel qui va falloir suivre
pour dire si la nuque arrive ou non au
Sénat malgré l'absence totale de LFI oui
bah évidemment le l'élection d'Eric
kerouges changerait quelque peu la donne
parce que en effet le lien entre les
deux chambres entre les groupes des deux
chambres et important pour la reprise
des propositions de loi etc ce sont des
éléments qui peuvent être extrêmement
importants surtout avec une majorité
relative à l'assemblée qui fait que tout
n'est pas si évident par ailleurs
évidemment ça faciliterait les rapports
de la nuque qui aujourd'hui sont on l'a
déjà dit tendu il y a également deux
autres groupes qui vont devoir changer
de président le groupe radical puisque
représente pas et le groupe communiste
avec Éliane assassy qui s'en va donc il
y a des enjeux en tant que président de
groupe il y a pas forcément danger pour
le plateau Gérard Larcher va être réélu
sur un plateau et la question se pose
aujourd'hui dans une majorité qui est de
plus en plus clivée entre centriste et
LR une polarisation quand même on le
voit sur la loi immigration d'une
succession un jour de Gérard Larcher qui
mieux que lui peut tenir cette majorité
aujourd'hui cette succession elle est
loin d'être évident elle est un mot de
conclusion très rapide parce qu'elle
Perino nous reste une minute dans ce
débat on parle trop de stabilité c'est
une fois de plus le Sénat a fait la
preuve de son équilibre c'est un point
et ça devient de plus en plus un point
d'équilibre du régime politique français
reste à savoir si dans les jours qui
viennent en effet cet équilibre va
évoluer évoluer vers le centre parce que
ce soir on fait de très bons scores
est-ce que ils vont laisser un peu de
place au centre gauche ou à ce qu'il en
reste parce que c'est vrai que l'on peut
dire que la macronie est dans un piteux
état et puis il y a cette question en
effet de l'axe que choisiront les
socialistes est-ce qu'ils vont décider
de ressusciter une baisse qui est dans
un état de mort clinique
ou bien est-ce qu'ils vont pratiquer un
socialisme qui restera socialiste
d'ouverture et qui est plus adapté à ce
qu'elle sème ça va nous donner de très
bons débats dans de prochaines émissions
sur l'antenne depuis Xena merci encore
merci à tous d'avoir participé à cette
soirée électorale merci Tam c'était un
grand bonheur de partager ces cinq
heures d'antenne avec vous partager on
va remercier évidemment toutes les
équipes de Public Sénat les équipes
techniques les équipes éditoriales tous
ceux qui nous ont monté ce magnifique
plateau dans dans ce décor majestueux
merci à alexandre Poussin merci
à calmé merci à tous nos duplexeurs qui
ont été fidèles au poste pendant toute
cette soirée et merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis et très bonne soirée sur
public c'est soirée et à demain sur
notre antenne
[Musique]